Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Was ist ein Juggernaut?
Ein Juggernaut oder Juggernaut, das ist vor allem eine Metapher.
Rätselhaft. Ist er auf dem Bild drauf, auf dem Cover der Juganaut? Was ist ein Juganaut?
Auf dem Cover sieht man ein Juganaut. Das ist so ein Zeremonienwagen, der so groß ist und so schwer ist, dass wenn er einmal sich in Gang gesetzt hat, er nicht mehr zu stoppen ist. Du kannst ja vorstellen, dass das eine Metapher ist, die vielfach eingesetzt wird. Interessanterweise nicht im Deutschen, aber im Englischen kommt sie sehr häufig vor. Und wir haben das Ganze natürlich deshalb verwendet, weil Marx diese Metapher prägt und man kann jetzt schon ahnen, wofür. Naja, vielleicht für den Kapitalismus. Um das zu sagen, also wir reden hier über das Kinderbuch, das Ole und ich zusammen geschrieben haben. Nick Martin-Sternitzke hat die Illustrationen wunderbar gestaltet. Und zwar heißt das Buch Die Kleinen Holzdiebe und das Rätsel des Juggernaut. Und das ist jetzt im Handel erhältlich und auch schon sehr erfolgreich.
Man kann es kaufen und du hast dann schon signiert.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist hier nicht möglich. Das ist nur bei selbst schuld, dass es noch eine Anthologie, die ich bei Hansa rausgebe. Das kann man über meinen Twitter-Account dann nachvollziehen. Hier muss man mich treffen und vielleicht noch einen Stift mitbringen. Ab zehn Jahren, also für die nicht ganz Kleinen oder Vorlesen. Ja, ich hörte jetzt auch schon mehrmals von Eltern, die sagten, ja, also ich lese das meinem achtjährigen Kind vor.
Und am Ende ist es ja eine Geschichte. Du als Ideologie-Kritiker weißt natürlich besonders gut, wie man als Ideologie-Agenda-Setter eine Ideologie versteckt, ohne dass man merkt, ah so, Lehre steckt auch noch drin.
Ja, das ist ja...
Damit ist es eigentlich ein Buch, ich hab's noch nicht gelesen, liegt noch um, aber das ich ja eignen müsste ab dem Zugeständnis oder dem Vertrauen, dass das Kind überhaupt was versteht.
Richtig und Kinder verstehen ja sehr viel. Kinder haben ja jetzt nicht einen Bildungsschatz, auf den sie sich beziehen können, wenn sie etwas bezipieren, aber sie verstehen ja ganz viel und verstehen vor allem auch eine Logik. Und diese Logik war...
Sie verlangen geradezu eine Logik.
Ja.
Wenn mein kleiner mich abends darum bittet, mir noch mal eine Geschichte auszudenken, darin vorkommen muss ein Krogodil, ein Esel und er selbst, dann sind die Personen damit gesetzt, aber die Logik, für die bin ich dann zuständig. Und die muss aber auch passen. Am Ende sollen alle Freunde sein. Da muss man den Weg finden.
Ja, hier sind auch am Ende viele zumindest Freunde. Aber es gibt schon auch Kampf. Es ist ja ein Abenteuer-Roman. Wir wollten ja jetzt nicht in ein Erklärbuch schreiben, Kapitalismus-Kritik für Anfänger, sondern wir wollten ja schon auch einen Roman schreiben. Insofern, das Buch ist überall erhältlich.
Ich kenne ja die 8-Jährigen aus Minecraft. Wenn nachts die Zombies kommen und man muss ihnen vorher eine Grube gegraben haben, sonst klappt es nicht, dann wird auch gekämpft.
Naja, ein bisschen Kampfflugend sein.
Kein unbekanntes Genre für Kindergartenkinder. Und dann frühe Schüler. Sehr gut.
Wir haben heute so viele Themen, da so viel passiert ist in diesem Sommermonat. Da ist ja zunächst einmal Solingen. Das liegt jetzt nahe darüber zu sprechen. Ich würde mal einen Clip abspielen, den wir schon mal hörten vor Monaten. Und zwar von Christoph Möllers, einem Staatsrechtler, der uns jetzt hier nochmal etwas in Erinnerung ruft.
Eine wirklich attraktive Sache an der AfD, das kann ich wirklich so sagen, ist, dass sie ja tatsächlich an Politik glaubt. Also, dass die AfD-Politiker glauben, sie könnten das Land verändern mit politischen Mitteln. Vielleicht nicht so, wie ich mir das vorstelle, aber sie haben schon diesen Gestaltungsoptimismus.
Das ist ja eine kleine Provokation. Er sitzt dort mit Carolin Imke, die auch dann gleich zurückschreckt vor einer solchen Aussage.
Zu Recht.
Zu Recht. Aber doch ist es ja so, dass das Versprechen der AfD zunächst einmal ist, mit uns wird alles anders, wir sind die Alternative.
Ja, aber man darf, man darf durchaus, und ich komme nun wirklich aus einer Theorielehre, der besonders nachgesagt wird, dass eine Steuerungsfantasie nun wirklich das Allerdäblichste ist. Man kann allenfalls noch irgendeine Irritation oder wie auch immer, aber man darf an Politik glauben. Also diese Idee von Joe Biden kommt ins Amt und er hat 51 Senatoren auf einer Seite, aber der eine, der die 51 rund macht, ist eben Joe Manchin und der schlägt ihm alles kurz und klein. Ansonsten gäbe es in Amerika jetzt ein Elterngeld und ordentliches Gesundheitssystem, wie auch immer, gilt, wie auch in Deutschland, ohne Christian Lindner wäre wirklich alles besser. Also das ist nicht nur naiver Glaube, sondern er sagt es auf der Bühne ein bisschen frech und ich verstehe das auch. Ich würde es wahrscheinlich auf der Bühne auch so machen, wenn die Gelegenheit da ist. Und es ist so, wenn Carolin Ehmke einem gegenüber sitzt, aber trotzdem angezogene Handbremse.
Aber gehen wir doch mal mit diesem Satz um und sagen, es gibt offenbar eine Sehnsucht nach Veränderung und es gibt den Wunsch, dass die Politik das doch bitte machen soll. Und dann hören wir ein paar Tage vor Solingen, unsere Innenministerin Nancy Faeser, die Folgendes sagt.
Mit Messern werden eben brutale Gewalttaten begangen, die schlimme Verletzungen nach sich ziehen oder sogar tödlich enden können. Deswegen ist aus meiner Sicht wichtig, dass wir ein schärferes Waffenrecht brauchen und striktere Kontrollen.
Ja, das, was sie da sagt, läuft ja unter einem unausgesprochenen, und da, finde ich, sollte man dann auch Möllers ernst nehmen, nämlich, dass die Politik in der Lage wäre, hier etwas zu steuern, nämlich etwas zu verhindern.
Richtig.
So, und dieses Verhindern ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, denn die Debatte jetzt, also anders als bei Döhnhausen bin ich an Solingen nicht vorbeigekommen. Und in dieser Diskussion zu Solingen läuft ja unausgesprochen, sondern einfach und dann zu naiv gesetzt, die Idee mit, man könnte hier eingreifen und folgende Fälle verhindern. Diese Fälle sind trotz aller Diskussionen so selten, dass man automatisch in dieses Präventionsparadox hineinläuft, also die erfolgreiche Politik hat hier keinen Maßstab. Denn einfach nur am Ende zu sagen, Schulz, wir wählen dich wieder, weil null Leute wurden 2025 getötet von Islamisten, ist irgendwie kein Kriterium. Und jetzt läuft die Debatte deswegen ja unter einer Devise, die, wenn man sie expliziert, man kommt dann so ins Stauden und fragt sich beim Fernsehschauen, ach so, ja, wir sollten wirklich den Mord mal verbieten.
Genau, das ist ja das, was Nancy Faeser hier vorschlägt.
Ausländer durften hier Deutsche töten, wusste ich gar nicht. Ja, also so oder dieser Maxime. Und da muss man nochmal ganz deutlich sagen, dass Töten, insbesondere das Arglistige und Hinterhältige, war schon immer verboten, selbst bevor es Verbote gab. Also noch vor der Positivierung des Rechts gab es religiöse, was auch immer. Ich will jetzt nicht Gesetze sagen, die sagten, nein, tu das nicht. Es hat Konsequenzen, die reichen dir zum Nachteil, du wirst dann eingesperrt oder selbst getötet oder wie auch immer. Also das ist eigentlich schon geregelt. Da ist kein Ansatz, um heute noch mal zusätzlich durch politische Steuerung etwas zu verbieten, was nicht schon längst verboten ist. Ja. Das gilt insbesondere für die Tatwaffe. Das Messer, also man darf mit Messern nicht auf Menschen einstechen. Hätten wir jetzt eine amerikanische Waffenkultur, hätte er irgendwie geschossen und es wären mehr Tote gewesen. Also wir könnten schon mal sagen, wir machen es nicht wie die Amerikaner. Wir haben ganz schön viel verhindert durch Gesetze, die wir haben. Nur das Messer, das wissen wir auch, das ist Dual Use. Also ein 6 cm Klingenmesser, damit kriegst du dein Brot noch nicht geschnitten, da dürfen es schon 12 cm sein. Und diese 12 cm kriegst du überall gekauft. Also wir haben es hier nicht mit Lachgas zu tun, wo man genau weiß, wofür es verwendet wird, damit die Leute dann einfach senkrecht umfallend sich den Kopf an der Bordsteinkante totschlagen. Sondern nein, Messer werden nur ganz selten als Tatwerkzeug im Mordversuch benutzt und ganz oft. Und zwar von jeder Person, jeden Tag zu Hause, auf Arbeit und überall. Also hier ist auch kein Ansatz, um was zu verhindern. Wir können nicht Messer verbieten.
Eine Kontrolle müsste ja so flächendeckend und total sein, dass man in einem absoluten Überwachungsstaat leben würde mit Körperscannern, die sofort sehen, sobald jemand mit einem Messer rausgeht, dass da jemand zugreift.
Selbst da würde ich sagen, mal kristallisieren. Also die moralische geht nicht. Wir haben Grundrechte, die sollen geschützt werden. Wir sind nicht alle Messermörder. Stimmt. Also der Staat würde seine kompletten Ressourcen darauf vergeben, die eine Million Besucher bei Museums Uferfest in Frankfurt darauf abzuprüfen, ob die da ein Messer mit dabei haben.
Unmöglich.
So, also es geht einfach nicht. Wir sind hier jenseits einer Steuerungsfantasie. Also wir haben hier keinen Ansatz, das zu verhindern. Und deswegen ist diese Debatte, wie sie gerade läuft, darauf abzuklopfen, wo wird diese Verhinderungsfantasie verankert? Und es ist bei Friedrich Merz der Migrant und bei Nancy Faeser, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, das Messer. Wir kennen von Nancy Faeser diesen Aktionismus. Sie verbietet gerne mal und dann plötzlich kommt ein Gerichtsurteil und Jürgen Elsäser steht vor der Fernsehkamera, vor Millionenpublikum und sagt, bis gestern kannten uns zwei Millionen Menschen in Deutschland, jetzt 60 Millionen. So, also es kann auch nach hinten losgehen. Solche Diskussionen. Aber dass wir jetzt den Migranten und den Messer so in den Mittelpunkt setzen, finde ich total daneben. Ich habe heute morgen den Podcast von Sascha Lobo gehört. Der sagt jetzt der Islamismus. Ja klar, der Islamismus. Nur der Islamismus, der nimmt sich, wenn er sein Ziel erreichen möchte, Flugzeuge und verwendet die als Massenvernichtungswaffe. Da kommt man mit einem Messer.
Er greift schon auch mit Messern an. Also es ist ja schon so, dass wir islamistisch motivierte Taten, Messertaten in Deutschland haben und allgemein die Messerangriffe zugenommen haben, aber auch die Messerangriffe, die natürlich von Deutschen ausgeübt werden. Wir haben, glaube ich, und vielleicht kann man das schon auch fühlen, auch wenn ich da immer sehr skeptisch bin, aber wenn ich in mich hineinhorche, sicherlich an einigen Orten ein sehr aggressives Klima. Das ist zum Beispiel der Frankfurter Bahnhof. Das ist an manchen Tageszeiten auch in der Nähe der Domplatte oder so zu erleben, dass man sagt, hier fühle ich mich nicht besonders wohl und da passiert auch schon mal was. Also man merkt, dass da gerade eine Schlägerei sich anbahnt oder schon eine ist und man geht lieber schnell weiter. Das ist eine Zuspitzung, die in der Gesellschaft zunimmt. Und dann gibt es noch mal sicherlich ein gewisses Revival des Islamismus. Also es war nie weg, aber ich glaube jetzt dadurch, dass wir Afghanistan im Stich gelassen haben, dadurch, dass der sogenannte islamische Staat sich weiter ausbreitet, dass die Agitation über das Internet ziemlich gut funktioniert, ist da also wieder was los. Das Problem ist nur, wenn wir ja über Terrorismus reden, reden wir, wie du sagst, über Einzeltaten. Die Sache ist nun, den Angehörigen ist nicht damit zu helfen, zu sagen, das sind Einzeltaten. Die Leute, die ein Angstgefühl haben, denen ist auch schwerlich, immer nur mit der Statistik beizukommen, auch wenn das helfen kann. Denn es gibt natürlich immer wieder so Aussagen wie, ja, es ist sehr viel wahrscheinlicher, an Krebs zu sterben als an einem Terroranschlag. Und da können alle zustimmen. Und doch ist dieses Präsentsein von absoluter Negation in Form von Gewalt etwas nochmal anderes als die Erfahrung, dass man Krebs bekommen kann. Und da sehen wir doch jetzt eigentlich, wir haben hier so eine Politik, die vorgibt, etwas tun zu können. Aber eigentlich müsste man eine ehrliche Politik betreiben, in der man im höchsten Maße die Ohnmacht eingesteht. Im Sinne von, wirklich, wir... Also es gibt die Einzelfälle, die sind ja tatsächlich nicht einzuhägen, es sei denn, man macht jetzt zum Beispiel den totalen Überwachungsstaat. Und dann muss man aber China noch weit übertrumpfen in der Überwachung.
Also gegen die Ohnmacht möchte ich mich gerade wenden. Denn ich finde, etwas verhindern zu wollen, ist ein legitimes Anliegen der Politik. Mit allen Problemen, die das mit sich bringt. Wie zum Beispiel, wenn wir es verhindert haben, kann man daraus nicht unbedingt eine Wahlkampfstory des Erfolgs schreiben, sondern man hat etwas verhindert. Etwas ist nicht passiert. Ja, das ist das Verhinderungsparadox. Präventionsparadox. Gleichzeitig ist aber es total albern, wenn eine Verhinderungsdebatte auf, ja, dann müssen wir einfach alle Migranten verhindern. Also in Millionenfach, in Schicksale eingreifen. Oder halt alle Messer. Also es ist ja völlig absurd. Also die beiden politischen Vorschläge, die wir haben, sind absurd. Und trotzdem ist ja das Verhindern richtig. Denn du sagst ja zu Recht, den Angehörigen ist nicht mehr zu helfen. Also die Menschen sind tot. So. Es gilt also, wir müssen verhindern. Und dieses Verhindern würde ich gerne in der politischen Diskussion da verankern, wo wir alle uns davor schützen, Mörder zu werden. Und das kann man nun mal nur in sehr langfristigen, sehr ausführlichen, lebensprägenden Sozialisationsprozessen. Und das beginnt beispielsweise damit, dass wir, wenn wir in der Schule über, und wir haben häufig darüber gesprochen, Universalismus und so weiter. Wenn wir in der Schule darüber sprechen, tötet euch nicht, schlagt euch nicht, prügelt euch nicht, redet über Sachen, lasst eure Gefühle zu, schafft euch Räume, sucht euch Safe Spaces und so weiter. Dann gilt das ja nicht nur für Deutsche. Also diese Ansprache an junge Menschen ist nicht, wenn du ein Franzose bist, ist es uns egal, aber als Deutscher, schlage bitte nicht den Friedrich, der neben dir sitzt. Und das bedeutet aber, vererbt, so wie du jetzt darauf reagierst, ist das ja eine totale Selbstverständlichkeit. Und jetzt haben wir aber in den letzten Monaten und Jahren politische Diskurse gehabt, die ungefähr so laufen. In Gaza wurden 30.000 Menschen getötet. Von wem, wissen wir nicht. Tatmittel, keine Ahnung, darüber reden wir nicht. Wollte das jemand steckender Intention dahinter, darüber schweigen wir. So, wenn es auf deutschem Boden passiert, ein Afghaner, von dem wir wissen, ungefragt bislang, die Polizisten haben mit dem geredet, aber wir noch nicht. Trotzdem wissen wir, der wollte das. Das ist ein Islamist, der hat eine bestimmte Ideologie. Also wir unterstellen ihm eine eindeutige Intention. Er wollte dieses Messer, er hat getötet. Er ist der Mörder. Da ist nicht einfach jemand tot umgefallen wie in Gaza. Und man weiß gar nicht, wie das passieren konnte. Auch Kamala Harris spricht es auf der Bühne an, aber es gibt keinen Täter. Und wenn wir so einen Diskurs führen, dann einfach so, wie wir das in der Schule machen. Diese Kinder werden dann fragen, wer hat denn den Juggernauten angestoßen? Ist das einfach so passiert? Nein, das ist aufzuklären. Und da ist dann auch die Verhinderungsdebatte anzusetzen.
Das ist ja ganz langfristig. Ich meinte jetzt diese Ohnmacht im Sinne von, wenn jetzt irgendetwas am nächsten Tag passiert, wenn sich jemand entscheidet, mit einem Auto in eine Masse reinzufahren oder mit einem Messer zu stechen, dann ist das nicht in dem Sinne zu verhindern, dass man sagt, das sind die zwei Punkte, hätten wir die gehabt, dann wäre es nicht gewesen. Man kann nicht sagen, hätten wir die Straße abgesperrt, wäre der Mann nicht da mit dem Auto reingefahren. Dann wäre er mit der anderen Straße weitergekommen.
Dann könnten wir einfach sagen, es gibt gar keine Volksfeste mehr. Und jeder, der auf die Straße geht, kriegt von uns acht Security-Leute, so wie Frank-Walter Steinmeier, der dann nochmal sagen darf, dass er das ganz schlimm findet. Das ist ja so das thüringische Modell von, ich habe mir ein Eigentum erworben und jetzt baue ich erstmal einen 3-Meter-Zaund rum. Und mit 3 Metern meine ich wirklich 3 Meter. Also diese Gehöfte sind zu gemauert. Da steht nicht einfach nur ein Gartenzaun, über den man auch mal drüberspringen kann oder so, sondern nein, da ist einfach gar nichts. Also diese Art von sich abnabeln und... Also es ist halt immer Trade-off, es ist jetzt passiert. Und ich finde trotzdem, es gibt zu Recht Verhinderungsdebatten, nur die sind halt gerade falsch.
Aber die eigentlichen Debatten wären ja nicht geführt. Also beispielsweise gab es einen Tweet, den hat er dann wieder gelöscht, interessanterweise von Ulf Poschert, wo er sagte, wie gern würde er am Sonntag wählen. Also quasi um so etwas wie Solingen zu verhindern. Und ich dachte, wie wählt man denn da? Also wenn man sich jetzt mal von allen anderen Werten befreit, sondern nur sagt, das einzige, was noch zählt, ist ein zweites Solingen zu verhindern. Wen wähle ich denn da? Also das ist ja, ich habe ja gar keine Antwort. Wenn ich jetzt sage, mein einziges Ziel ist die autofreie Innenstadt, dann würde ich sagen, vermutlich Linke und Grüne wählen. Ja, so, da kann ich es klar sagen. Dann Jochen Bittner von der Zeit macht bei Twitter einen großen Aufschlag. Was geschehen müsste, statt wohlfeil und billig nach jeder Tat wie Solingen die volle Härte des Gesetzes zu fordern, ein paar Vorschläge. Ich lese die kurz vor. Das individuelle Asylrecht ersetzen durch eine Institutsgarantie, die durch einfache Gesetze ausgeformt werden kann, wozu auch Obergrenzen gehören. Kontingente für hilfsbedürftigsten Flüchtlinge, um sie direkt nach Deutschland zu holen, zugleich mehr Drittstaaten abkommen. Streichungen einfrieren der Entwicklungshilfe für Länder, die keine abgelehnten Asylbewerber aufnehmen. Entzug der deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft bei Doppelstaatlern, die Hamas, IS oder andere islamistische Gruppen unterstützen. Nun, da wird man ein Problem bekommen, welche Staatsbürgerschaft bekommen die denn dann? Also bekommen die dann die Staatsbürgerschaft des IS oder so? Verpflichtende Vorschule ab dem dritten Lebensjahr für alle Kinder von Einwanderern. Verbot von Social-Media-Nutzung bis mindestens zum 14. Lebensjahr. Zu sagen, ist der Täter von Solingen war 26 Jahre alt, er kam 22 über Bulgarien in die EU und ist dann in Deutschland untergetauft. Man hat keine Fahnung ausgeschrieben, weil er dachte, der sei unauffällig. Jetzt kann man sagen, gab es da Behördenversagen? Möglicherweise. Der hätte sich auch nicht in diese Richtung radikalisieren müssen. Und tatsächlich wissen wir ja auch beispielsweise von Familiendramen. Es kommt aus heiterem Himmel sehr häufig. Wir hatten ja solche Geschichten jetzt auch mehrmals in den letzten Monaten von sogenannten Familiendramen, muss man ja sagen. Also Männer, die dann die ganze Familie kurz und klein geschossen haben. Und wo auch dann immer alle Nachbarn sagen, er war völlig unauffällig, war alles immer normal. Das heißt, es gibt manchmal Anzeichen natürlich in diese richtige Richtung. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es auch in Deutschland ein großes Personalproblem gibt, dass wenn diese Anzeichen da sind, dass dem nachgegangen wird. Ich habe es ja auch gehört, immer wieder vor ein, zwei Jahren, aus dieser Reichsbürgerszene, wie lang man dort auch einfach aufgrund von Personalmangel oder weil man nicht die Kapazitäten klar verteilt hatte, nicht agiert hatte. Das heißt, wir erleben hier so Vorschläge von Jochen Bittner, die gar nicht auf den Fall zutreffen. Und dann muss man einfach so ehrlich sein und sagen, ich hätte gerne weniger Ausländer in Deutschland, aber Solingen hat damit jetzt mal gerade gar nichts zu tun, sondern mein eigenliches Konzept ist das. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist jetzt in einer ganz, ganz breiten Mehrheit in der Politik verankert, weit über AfD und CDU hinaus, dass man jetzt hausieren geht damit, dass man sagt, wir müssen weniger Ausländer haben und folgende Maßnahmen schlage ich vor. Und das ist jetzt quasi Solingen als Anlass genommen für etwas ganz anderes. Also eigentlich auch für eine ganz klare Unterscheidung wieder. Du hattest das Buch vorgestellt, wie wir uns Rassismus beibringen in Wir und die Anderen. Und dann geht man nochmal genau nach und guckt, wer sind denn die Anderen und wer sind wir?
Also Gilda Sahibis Buch ist in doppelten Belangen genau richtig. Zum einen Rassismus ist schon mal eine Beobachtung von wie Debatten laufen, noch bevor man einen Vorwurf draus macht. Sondern einfach nur so als Hinweis, wenn wir in diese Richtung gehen, kommt irgendwann eine Grenze. Und wenn wir die überschritten haben, ist es im Grunde nur noch eine Übersetzung von Ausländer raus. So dann fordert Weidel ein Muratorium von fünf Jahren für Ausländer. Also wir wollen uns nicht vorstellen, wie Deutschland 2029 aussehen, wenn 1,4 Millionen Menschen in Rente gehen und 700.000 nachrücken. Und wir dann keinen Migrations-Zuzug haben. Das ist ja völlig absurd. Davon sind ja dann so Märzensvorschläge nur abgeschwächt.
Jens Spahn ja auch sitzt bei Lanz und zitiert Peter Schollertour, der wohl irgendwann mal sagte, wenn man Halbkalkutta hier hinholt, dann hat man irgendwann Kalkutta. Sehr interessant, einen Tag später in der Bild-Zeitung, ein Artikel, das Geheimnis der indischen Pizzaboten, klingt auch schon wie ein Kinderbuch. Es geht darum, dass 53.000 Menschen mit indischem Pass 2011 bei uns gelebt haben. Mittlerweile sind es 246.000. Und was ist da also los? Deutschland will so dringend benötigte Fachkräfte ausbilden. Wer sein Studium abschließt und ein Jobangebot mit mindestens 2.900 Euro brutto bekommt, darf bleiben. Deutschland ist mittlerweile ein beliebtes Ziel. Es liegt näher an der Heimat als die USA und ist günstiger als Großbritannien. Indische Studenten kommen meist nach Berlin, da an der Hauptstadt viele Menschen Englisch sprechen und es Privatunis extra für Inder gibt. Um ihr teures Leben in der Hauptstadt zu finanzieren, fahren viele der mittlerweile rund 30.000 Inder in Berlin nebenbei Essen aus. Für 20 Stunden Arbeit die Woche bekommen sie rund 1000 Euro netto im Monat. Ein Wirtschaftsstudent, Mohit24, sagt, wir kommen aus der Oberschicht, haben in Indien Diener und sind nicht stolz auf diesen Job, aber beim Ausfahren haben wir wenigstens keinen Chef, der uns anschreit. Das ist also die neue Wirklichkeit, in die sich Jens Spahn noch nicht so eingefügt hat, obwohl er in Berlin lebt.
Genau, und das führt zu Gilda Sahibis zweite große Lehre. Das Wählerpublikum, gerade in Deutschland, in so einer trägen alten Republik, hat rassistische Belange.
Ja.
Und die muss man jetzt mal deutlich markieren, als es gibt rassistische und dann legitime politische Belange.
Und legitimes Politisches ist durchaus auch Sicherheit. Also es ist schon so, dass es zum Beispiel am Frankfurter Bahnhof teils desaströs ist.
Absolut.
Das ist aber nicht, dass man dort steht und sagt, das haben wir jetzt von der Flüchtlingskrise oder so was, sondern da stimmt ganz, ganz viel im Ganzen nicht.
Genau. Und wollte man die rassistischen Belange mal als das, was sie sind, entzaubern, nämlich rassistische Belange, die, wenn sie politisch ausgelebt werden, kontraproduktiv sind, weil die führen zu mehr Gewalt und zu mehr Unzufriedenheit und zu mehr sozialer, sozioökonomischer Asymmetrie, die dann wiederum zu Gewalt. Also es sind ja, klar, man kann sich das bei Frankfurt, der Bahnhofsviertel anschauen und sagen, das sind alles Ausländer oder es sind alles Arme.
Ja, oder Drogenabhängige.
Oder Drogenabhängige. Also genau, egal wie man die Einflugsschneise wählt, man kommt da zu politischen Problemen hinter den rassistischen. Aber man muss halt eine klare Grenze ziehen. Und um diese Grenzziehung erfolgreich zu bewältigen, erinnere ich nochmal an Arne Semmsrott, seine Beobachtung des Innenministeriums. Dort haben in Personalunion dieselben Beamten mit Migration und mit innerer Sicherheit zu tun. Und diese Themen müssen jetzt entkoppelt werden. Also meine Forderung für die nächste Bundesregierung, ja, wir blicken da auf 70 Jahre Geschichte eines Ministeriums für innere Sicherheit und Migration. Aber wir brauchen jetzt entweder für innere Sicherheit oder für Migration ein unterschiedenes Ministerium. Das kann nicht mehr in Personalunion in gleicher Weisungsbefugnis gemacht werden, sondern Migration in Deutschland, finde ich ja, Altenrepublik, ist eine eigene Herausforderung, der man sich bewältigen, also stellen muss, die man echt bewältigen muss. Ansonsten sieht es hier düster aus. Und dann könnte man auch sagen, okay, wir haben einen Zugezogenen, der uns Probleme macht und der legt aber noch mal auf einen Fokus auf die anderen Zugezogenen, die uns eben keine Probleme machen. Und egal, wie man es dreht und wendet, und man muss nicht nur von Messern mördern. Es gibt auch noch andere Probleme, die uns durch Zuzug beschert werden. Aber unsere Sozialkassen und so weiter können auf Zuzug nicht verzichten. Der Arbeitsmarkt wird seit Jahren mehrheitlich pro Jahr von Nicht-Deutschen aufgefüllt. Und auf die kann man auch mal einen Fokus legen. Man kann auch abfeiern, dass sich hier Menschen, so wie wir das in Deutschland wollen, sich ordentlich deutsch verhalten. Weil die machen das ja. Da kann man auch mal einen Fokus drauf legen.
Abfeiern ist ein gutes Stichwort. Ich habe noch mal nachgedacht, nachdem ich ein Gespräch sah in den Sternstunden der Philosophie mit Elke Heidenreich. Und da trampelt sie noch mal so ein bisschen los gegen die, die alle laufend jammern. Und dann sagt sie, ja, natürlich bin ich sehr privilegiert, aber es wird auch wahnsinnig viel gejammert und ich vertrage das nicht mehr. Dann habe ich so drüber nachgedacht und habe gedacht, ja, es stimmt. Es wird unglaublich viel gejammert. Das heißt, du gehst irgendwo in eine Bar, in eine Kneipe. Sobald ein Gespräch beginnt, hörst du Gejammer und also nicht Gejammer in Form von Kritik. Also da ist es nicht ein Gejammer, das sagt ja, jetzt haben wir leider das Problem der Schuldenbremse und folgendes, sondern es ist eher so, dass man schon Angst hat. Der wird hoffentlich nicht gleich Ausländer oder so sagen, dass ich dann jetzt da eine Diskussion reingehen muss. Ja, ich sitze in Berlin in einem Taxi und es wird los gejammert. Es wird aber gejammert im Sinne von der Taxifahrer sagt so Geschehen nach der Buchpremiere. Ja, hier ist viel los und so, aber auch zu viel. Also es sind auch jeweils Christopher Street Day 300.000. Das ist zu viel. Das ist einfach zu viel, sagt er dann. Und man denkt so, ja, aber warum? Also was soll ich jetzt darauf antworten? Dann darf ich natürlich reden lassen, weil das für mich ja alles Material ist. Und ich würde sagen, es wird wahnsinnig viel gejammert. Und dann habe ich über die Politik nachgedacht und habe an Kamala Harris noch mal denken müssen, die ich ja hier auch schon kritisch beäugt habe. Aber was sie ja macht oder was da versucht wird zu tun, ist ja gute Laune zu verbreiten. Jetzt kann man sagen, das ist eine Strategie der Endpolitisierung und das ist es zum einen auch. Aber das, was hier Friedrich Merz und so weiter machen, ist ja die totale Endpolitisierung. Die sagen ja einfach, wir machen nichts mehr anderes, als auf Ausländer draufkloppen. Wir bieten euch sonst nichts anderes an. Und ich habe dann noch mal geschaut in der deutschen Politik. Es gibt keinen einzigen Politiker, der für gute Laune steht.
Niemand.
Es gibt niemanden, bei dem man sagt, Mensch, das ist aber lustig, guckt man gerne zu, hat auch eine schöne Idee, gefällt mir. Es ist nicht vorhanden.
Die letzte gute Laune in Deutschland war der Schulz-Zug, würde ich sagen. Das ist jetzt ein Jahrzehnt her oder so.
Ganz kurz war. Und jetzt haben wir ja nur noch, Schulz spricht nicht, Habeck jammert, Wagenknecht zetert, Merz zetert, von der AfD brauchen wir gar nicht reden.
So wie ich das verstehe, wachen auch in Deutschland sehr viele junge Leute morgens auf und hoffen, dass Tim Waltz wieder eine Rede irgendwo gehalten hat. Dass man so ein bisschen Joy rüber vererbt bekommt. Weil die Probleme sind ja an sich dieselben. Elke Heidenreich sagt ja auch ganz klar, das größte Problem ist die Armut. Nur sie kann sich halt rausnehmen davon. Aber das Problem ist die Armut, die überall ist.
Nur das Gejammer findet ja auch bei Leuten statt, die nicht von Armut oder sonst was betroffen sind. Also Elke Heidenreich umgibt sich ja jetzt nicht laufen mit Leuten, denen es wahnsinnig schlecht ökonomisch geht, sondern sie wird viele Leute treffen, denen es eigentlich relativ gut geht, die aber auch nur im Jammer-Modus sind. Und dann ist natürlich das sehr nahe, wenn man laufend jammert, dass man sich doch in Sündenburg aussucht. Und das passiert ja jetzt gerade in so großem Maße. Es ist ja die absolute Kapitulation. Also wenn man das auch nochmal sich klarmacht, wenn man sich von allen humanen Werten bereit ist zu befreien und einfach nur mal überlegt, wem nutzt was. Hilft es irgendjemanden in Deutschland, wenn Flüchtlinge eine Bezahlkarte haben müssen?
Den Banken, die diese ausstellen, um eine Rechnung zu stellen.
Aber geht es den allgemeinen Wählern damit besser? Bekommen die 10 Euro mehr, wenn Flüchtlinge eine Bezahlkarte haben? Nein.
Da gibt es auch einen sehr schönen Gregor Gysi, der sitzt in der Bundespressekonferenz bei diesen Formaten des politischen, also Bürgersprechstunde, und fragt dann auch ins Publikum, naja, aber so funktioniert doch der Bundestag nicht. Wenn wir irgendjemandem kein Geld überweisen, heißt das doch nicht, dass wir es dann ihn überweisen.
Jaja.
So, also dieser Bogenschlag ist nicht. Genau, und ich würde hier nochmal zum Abschluss dieses Themas. Immer wenn eine politische Forderung im Raum steht, von der du zurecht sagst, also Freude verbreitet die jetzt nicht unbedingt, dann hat es ja häufig damit zu tun, dass irgendwer sagt, es ist zu viel. Wir brauchen eigentlich weniger. Also zu viele Leute beim Christopher Street Day. Friedrich Merz hat sich ja auch schon hinreisen lassen im Fernsehen zu sagen, es sind einfach zu viele Kinder in der Schule. Und dann kann man ja immer so suchen, wo ist eigentlich der Gegenpunkt. Also wenn zu viele Leute irgendwie durch die Stadt transportiert werden müssen, gibt es vielleicht zu wenig Busse und Bahnen. Ja. Wenn das in der Schule nicht klappt, vielleicht sind es nicht zu viele Schüler, sondern zu wenig Lehrer und so. Und man kann, also da wo man das Jammern sieht, weiß man doch jetzt, das ist doch die amerikanische Lehre. Ja, dann tauscht man einfach den 81-jährigen, senilen Opa aus gegen jemanden, der halt Freude hat. So und wenn Friedrich Merz schlechte Stimmung auf der Bühne macht und glaubt, das ist die Lösung. Nein, dann müssen wir den halt einfach austauschen. Und wenn Christian Lindner immer nur sagt, was alles nicht geht, dann brauchen wir halt einen Finanzminister, der uns einfach sagt, was geht die ganze Zeit. Also dieses Vorzeichen umkehren geht immer. Ansonsten wäre das diese intellektuelle Faulheit, die ja die klügsten Köpfe, Adam Toos, Harari und so weiter immer wieder unterstellen.
Und es ist eine intellektuelle Faulheit. Und die Tatsache ist ja auch so, dass um das noch zum Abschluss zu sagen, man hier noch, um auf Möllers zurückzukommen, Politik machen kann. Also ich kann jetzt sagen, Bezahlkarte für Flüchtlinge, so und so viele Abschiebungen mehr. Und das kostet ja alles nichts. Also das sind ja jetzt Gesetze, die einige Leute sehr stark drangsalieren. Aber es kostet den Staat an sich nicht mehr. Wenn ich jetzt sage, wir brauchen in Thüringen 50 neue Freibäder. Ach so, wie bezahlen wir die? Die Kommunen sind überschuldet, die Länder. Und da Lindner will nicht. Und eigentlich ist, ich will es nicht alles darauf zurückwinnen, aber ich glaube schon, diese Austeritätspolitik produziert schon diesen Wahn, dass man nichts mehr positiv gestalten kann, sondern dass man nur noch über Sparsamkeit und auch Sparsamkeit an Großherzigkeit zu irgendetwas kommen kann. Also ich versuche weniger großzügig gegenüber Leuten zu sein, die hier hinkommen. Ich versuche engherziger zu werden. Also alles kommt ins Sparschwein und die sollen weniger bekommen. Es gibt jetzt einen neuen Vorschlag. Ich hatte das auch nur kurz in Bild gelesen. Da wird also jetzt überlegt, wohl in Ampelkreisen, ob nicht es so sein sollte, dass Flüchtlinge, die über ein anderes EU-Land eingereist sind und dort auch dann registriert wurden, gar kein Bargeld mehr erhalten und auch keine Bezahlkarte, dass man denen nur noch ein Bett, Brot, Seife-Minimum gewährt. Also das sind diese neuen Politikmaßnahmen, die man machen kann. Aber es gibt keinerlei Gestaltung mehr ins Positive. Und das ist schon der Austeritätswahnsinn.
Wenn man sowas macht, dann aber auch wie Schlingensief. Man nimmt sich den größten Platz der Stadt. Ja. Und jeder kriegt zwei Quadratmeter. Ja.
Ich empfehle sehr diese Aktion. Das ist ja auch auf DVD dokumentiert. Ausländer raus von Schlingensief. Da können dann die Österreicher wählen, wie bei Big Brother, welcher Ausländer als erstes ausgewiesen wird. Es ist hochaktuell. Man muss eigentlich sowas wie genau in dieser Art, auch mit dieser Ironie, wieder machen.
Ich habe die Woche mit Mig noch einen populistischen Begriff geschöpft. Wenn Politiker Vorschläge machen, die sie nichts kosten, dann sollte man das Taliban-Gesetz nennen.
Taliban-Gesetz?
Denn die Taliban hat ja auch kein Budget, kann nichts machen. Also was machen sie? Sie schreiben noch Gesetze, in denen steht, Frauen dürfen zu Hause nicht mehr singen oder laut sprechen. Kostet nichts, ist im Grunde so wie eine Ehe für alle. Merkel sitzt auf der Bühne und sagt, keine Ahnung, ich habe da nichts dagegen. Also wird das halt gemacht. Es ist wirklich nur ein unterschriebener Rechtsakt. Es steht jetzt im Gesetz, verhalten sich die Beamten dann anders. Aber niemand kostet das irgendwas. Also eine ganz billige Gesetzgebung.
Nun hatte die Ehe für alle für einige dann einen positiven Effekt.
Genau, aber wenn sie zu nichts führt. Also wenn es einfach nur Drangsalierungspolitik macht, die nicht budgetrechtlich ist, dann ist das einfach Taliban-Gesetzgebung.
Und das wäre auch dann doch nochmal mein Vorwurf auch an die US-Demokraten. Man wird ja sehen, wie sich das denn entwickelt.
Umso mehr Clips spiele ich nachher noch, um Gottes Willen. Wie die uns das alles erklären.
Meine generelle Kritik auch zum Beispiel sehr häufig an die Grünen, dass sie gute Vorschläge machen zu einer Liberalisierung und darauf aber dann hängen bleiben. Also es kostet nichts, zum Beispiel die Ehe zu liberalisieren. Das ist eine Frage von Gesetz und kostet niemand etwas mehr. Aber ich will schon auch immer eine Politik haben, die etwas kostet. Denn sonst verbessert sich nicht die ökonomische Lage. Also nur mit Legalismus allein kann man es nicht machen. Und deswegen sollte man also von links auch immer eine kostenintensive Antwort haben.
Absolut. Ich will hören, wie viele Billionen es sind beim Klimawandel auch.
Wir wollen noch kurz darauf verweisen, dass der Sommersalon online ist. Den kann man also jetzt hören. Und wir sind aber schon beim nächsten Salon also in der Planung.
Es gibt zwei Salons im September.
Richtig. Einmal unseren Literatur Salon bzw. unser Salon, in dem wir wichtige Artikel und Bücher empfehlen. Wir lesen von Julia Friedrichs Crazy Rich. Sie hat ein Buch geschrieben über Deutschlands Superreiche. Ich habe es noch nicht erhalten. Wird jetzt morgen oder übermorgen ja überall im Handel sein. Und ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, da sie ja eine Journalistin ist, die großartig die Form der Reportage beherrscht und dann aber über diese genauen Beobachtungen hinausgeht und davon mehr ableitet. Und da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf.
Nachgestattet, Ul, Elite, das ist jetzt das Hallo-Oligarchie oder so genannt. Ich finde auch, wir sollten je nachdem, was wir an Deskriptionen bekommen, herauslesen, was wahrscheinlich nicht drinsteht und eine kleine Neiddebatte führen. Also wir beide auf der einen Seite gegen die, was wir da hören, sehen, erfahren.
Auf jeden Fall. Und wer will, kann sich auch unser Gespräch über das Vorgängerbuch von Julia Friedrichs anhören. Das war, ich glaube, 2020, 2021 sprachen wir über Working Class. Da hat sie sich mit den Menschen beschäftigt, die ganz wenig in Deutschland verdienen.
Said in der U-Bahn.
Ja, das ist sehr lesenswert und das kann man auch im Salon hören, wie man in den Salon kommt. Das sagen wir auch ganz schnell.
Man geht auf neu20er.de, folgt dem goldenen Button, ist also bei Steady. Wir empfehlen sehr Steady, weil Steady macht auch wenig Probleme. Letztens hat jemand geschrieben, er hat sich bei Patreon angemeldet, aber den RSS-Feed nicht gefunden. Ich weiß dann auch immer nicht so richtig weiter, weil Patreon ist nun, die machen es echt auch einfach und so. Bei Steady, wir haben wirklich ganz wenige Probleme. Man meldet sich da an, man sieht sofort, das ist dein RSS-Feed. Man klickt drauf. In welcher App willst du den abonnieren? Und dann hat man einen Podcast abonniert. Dass der Steady-Player selbst so ein bisschen blöde ist, keine Kapitelmarken anzeigt und so, das ist schade. Aber da kann man nur Steady aufrufen, dass sie es mal ordentlich machen. Aber wir sind da sehr zufrieden. Man kann auch über Apple buchen, sofern man diesen Button sieht, wo man einfach einen Klick machen kann. Man kann über Steady bei Spotify den Salon hören. Also eigentlich ist alles, ich bin sehr zufrieden technisch mit dieser Podcast-Landschaft.
Ja, und es gibt ja so gut wie nie Rückmeldung, das, was nicht funktioniert, ganz ganz selten mal ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei. Und es gibt dann in diesem Monat noch einen zweiten Salon, den Live-Salon. Der ist ausverkauft wie auch der Salon.
Der hat noch eine Karte irgendwie. Ich weiß auch nicht genau.
Dann ist er jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade ausverkauft. Jedenfalls der Dezember-Salon ist auch schon ausverkauft. Manchmal bekommen wir nochmal Anfragen. Wir haben die Karten auch gar nicht und diese beiden Termine sind ausverkauft. Im nächsten Jahr wird es wieder welche geben. Neue Termine werden wir aber dann noch im Winter erst bekannt geben, wenn alles feststeht. Jedenfalls kann man mich jetzt noch ein paar Mal woanders erleben. Ich bin zweimal in Berlin, bin in Heidelberg und im Westerwald.
Ist der Westerwald ein Wald oder ist das eine Stadt?
Ich kann jetzt den Ort sagen, Seelbach, aber den wird gar keiner kennen. Das ist für Leute, die im Westerwald leben, vielleicht ganz gut erreichbar. In Mainz auch. Man kann sich einfach über meine Homepage informieren, wenn man das sehen will. Und noch zwei Sachen. Ich habe ja doch dann viele interessante Begegnungen auch nach unserer Live-Show noch gehabt. Das ist ja immer sehr schön, auch wenn gar nicht so viel Zeit ist, mit Leuten zu reden. Und deswegen würde ich mich gerne bei zwei nochmal rückmelden. Und zwar war da eine Dame, die hat sich mit Pina Bausch beschäftigt und eine Bachelorarbeit darüber geschrieben. Mich würde diese Arbeit sehr interessieren. Also wenn sie das jetzt hier hört, kann sie mir das gerne mal per E-Mail schicken. Und dann war ein Herr da, der in Frankfurt jetzt bei der KfW angefangen hat, ihren Hauptsitz hat. Auch da hätte ich eigentlich mal zwei bis drei Fragen. Vielleicht kann er sich auch melden.
Ja, wie ist es, eine Mittagspause am Palmgarten zu verbringen zum Beispiel?
Meine Fragen waren ja spezifischer auf die Arbeit in der KfW. Aber gut, wir gehen zu unserem nächsten Thema. Und zwar der Gefangenenaustausch zwischen Deutschland, USA und Russland. Und zwar ist der Tiergartenmörder Krasikow freigelassen worden im Austausch für deutsche Gefangene, aber auch amerikanische Gefangene und einige andere russische Gefangene wurden auch ausgeliefert. Wir werden jetzt mal über dieses Thema ein bisschen abstrakter sprechen. Und da hilft der Einspruch-Podcast von der FAZ. Stefan Klehner befragt da die Strafrechtsprofessorin Nina Nestler, wie man das denn eigentlich rechtfertigen konnte, diesen Mann, der ja ganz klar ein Mörder ist und der jetzt auch nicht Reue gezeigt hat oder irgendetwas, diesen Mann freizulassen.
Es geht ja um § 456a der Strafprozessordnung.
Ja, das ist die Frage nach dem Sinn und Zweck dieser Vorschrift, die in der Literatur und in der Rechtsprechung meistens recht eindeutig beantwortet wird, dass der § 456a Strafprozessordnung der Entlastung des deutschen Justizvollzugs dient. So sagt man es jedenfalls. Meines Erachtens beruht die Vorschrift auf verschiedenen Zwecken, und zwar je nachdem, um welche der Varianten es geht. Also in der Norm gibt es ja drei Varianten, die das Gestatten, ein Verurteilten aus dem Vollzug der Freiheitsstrafe, zu entlassen oder freizulassen. Zwar erstens, wenn der Verurteilte wegen einer anderen Tat einer ausländischen Regierung ausgeliefert wird. Zweitens, wenn er an einen internationalen Strafgerichtshof ausgeliefert wird. Oder drittens, das ist die Variante, um die es hier geht, wenn er aus dem Geltungsbereich der Strafprozessordnung abgeschoben oder zurückgewiesen wird. Also wenn der Verurteilte den Geltungsbereich des deutschen Rechts sozusagen oder des Bundesgebiets verlassen muss aufgrund einer staatlichen Anordnung.
Das ist übrigens hochinteressant, dass wir bei den einen Polizistenmördern islamistisch sagen, die sollen ausreißen. Und sei es, dass sie dann von wem auch immer hofiert und gefeiert werden, als diejenigen, die hier noch Nadelstiche im Westen setzen. Und hier ist diese Diskussion genau umgedreht. Also hier kann ich mich sofort reinfühlen. Aber bei diesen Islamismus-Diskussionen, da verstehe ich es dann eben gar nicht. Und es ist auch wirklich nicht kompatibel. Also diese Debatten sind so schräg.
Nesta erläutert jetzt mal diese Norm, die dazu geführt hat, dass man so eine Legitimationsgrundlage hatte für eine Freilassung.
Und es ist natürlich so, dass der Sinn und Zweck, der hinter einer Norm steht, das ist erst mal als abstrakter Zweck formuliert. Und ob dann die Vorschrift letzten Endes zur Anwendung gelangen kann oder nicht, das hängt ja dann auch davon ab, ob denn die in der Vorschrift genannten Voraussetzungen verwirklicht sind oder nicht. Und die Voraussetzungen, die da eben für diese dritte Tatvariante genannt wird, neben der Ausreiseverfügung oder der Ausweisungsverfügung, ist eben, dass eine Ermessensentscheidung stattfindet und dass eben nach den zugrunde gelegten Ermessenskriterien diese Anforderungen erfüllt sind. Also wir haben einerseits natürlich den abstrakten Zweck, andererseits aber sehr konkrete Voraussetzungen in der Vorschrift und das sind die, die erfüllt sein müssen, damit man sie anwenden kann.
Unser Kopf ist jetzt ein bisschen durcheinander gewirbelt. Was meinen die jetzt eigentlich da? Also man kann ja nicht einfach offenbar nur sagen, wir lassen ihn mal frei, das ist so ein kleiner Deal, sondern man muss immer versuchen, so eine Rechtsgrundlage zu schaffen. Klänner fragt jetzt aber auch gleich, ob diese Norm, auf die sich bezogen wird, eigentlich zieht. Denn es geht ja auch bei dieser Norm zum Beispiel darum, dass das fiskalisch für das Land besser ist. Also natürlich, ein Gefangener in Deutschland kostet Geld, wenn er also nicht da ist. Aber ist das eine wirkliche Rechtfertigung dafür, er sagt dann auch?
Ja, wenn wir dann aber mal so auf das Ermessen gucken. Ich habe mich da mal so ein bisschen eingelesen, was da normalerweise so für Kriterien eine Rolle spielen, dann ist das zum Beispiel das Thema Haftdauer. Da ist es so, dass der ja zu lebenslanger Haft verurteilt wurde, jetzt aber noch gar nicht so lange im Gefängnis war. Dann ist es so, dass zum Beispiel auch bei der Verurteilung die besondere Schwere der Schuld festgestellt wurde. Sprich, denn das dafür, das Ermessen so auszuüben, dass man den frei lässt?
Das legt erstmal ziemlich genau den Finger in die Wunde, diese Frage.
Dann eine sehr lange Erläuterung dazu, aber natürlich hat er es damit schon auf den Punkt gebracht.
Aber das ist auch so verworren, also jemand ermordet in Berlin, in der Innenstadt einen Menschen. Und alle sehen sofort, das war eine politische Tat. Es ist so ein bisschen, wir kennen das ja in der Diskussion aus China, die unterhalten dann auch im Ausland Polizeifilialen, obwohl sie das gar nicht dürfen, um dann chinesisches Recht. Und damit ist dann vor allem auch gemeint, so Transalierungen, Bedrohung von Familien, damit irgendwelche Menschen in China sich anders verhalten. So, das wollen wir also nicht zulassen. Wir haben es also hier mit Politik zu tun. Ein juristisch abgeschlossenes Verfahren wird plötzlich durch Politik torpediert. Und die Logik, nach der das politisch torpediert wird, ist eine ökonomische, es wird ein Deal gemacht Mensch gegen Mensch. Also wir haben hier ein sehr modernes Verhalten aller Beteiligten, die jetzt händeringend nach Normen suchen in irgendwelchen Gesetzen, oder was auch immer, um das nochmal praktikabel zu machen. Ich verstehe so ein bisschen bei einer Haushaltsgesetzgebung, warum man den großen Trick, Schuldenbremse mit kleinen Tricks versucht zu umgehen. Aber hier in dem Fall fände ich es doch gut, wenn es nicht so nach, wir mussten da schon ganz schön trickst und so weiter klingen. Ja, clever. Und auf der anderen Seite das Ziel, verstehe ich nicht absolut, weil wir haben ja nicht nur den freigelassen, es sind ja auch Menschen im Gegenzug dafür freigelassen worden.
Ganz richtig. Wir hören auch gleich noch, wie das eigentlich da gelaufen ist. Kleiner, dekliniert das jetzt mal weiter durch.
Weil es war ja am Ende wohl doch eine politische Entscheidung. Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann hat Generalbundesanwalt Jens Rommel angewiesen, von der weiteren Vollstreckung abzusehen. Warum ist so eine Anweisung möglich?
Also wir haben hier dann doch das Primat des Politischen plötzlich.
Ja, der politische Befehl.
Und das ist ganz eigenartig. Wie das dann genau funktioniert, das muss uns jetzt nicht interessieren. Es hätte auch noch eine andere Möglichkeit gegeben für die Freilassung. Vielleicht, fragt Kleiner.
Man hätte das Sonderproblem vielleicht umgehen können, wenn man einfach gar nicht auf diese STPO-Normen sich gestützt hätte, sondern wenn stattdessen das Begnadigungsrecht des Bundespräsidenten ins Spiel gekommen wäre. Der Generalbundesanwalt war offenbar der Meinung, dass das besser gepasst hätte.
Nun, ich finde auch irgendwie. Ja, ist aber eigentlich nur dazu da, dass wenn jemand sehr lange in Haft war, er reuig ist und der Bundespräsident sagt, das sei eine zu hohe Strafe, dass ist eigentlich zu viel Leid diesen Menschen angetan, dass er dann Gnade walten lässt. Wenn du natürlich da einen Mörder hast, der sagt, ich bin hier Putins Agent und freue mich weiter an seinen Diensten zu sein, dann sagt man nicht, da müssen wir aber mal Gnade vor Recht ergehen lassen.
Genau, das kann man aber ausblenden und einblenden, dass der Bundespräsident eben so ein bisschen über diesem Gefüge steht, das ansonsten gilt.
Ja, das ist ein interessanter Punkt.
Und wir damit Shortcut, damit alle sehen, das ist hier Shortcut. Dieser Weg steht hier eigentlich nicht zur Verfügung.
Gibt noch eine Variante.
Gibt es ja immerhin noch das Übereinkommen über die Überstellung verurteilter Personen. Das ist ein völkerrechtlicher Vertrag, ursprünglich mal ein Europarechtsabkommen, gilt jetzt allerdings auch noch im Verhältnis zwischen Deutschland und Russland. Obwohl Russland ja dem Europarat nicht mehr angehört. Da wäre es dann so gewesen, dass Russland die Strafvollstreckung formal übernommen hätte und anschließend dann selbst eine Begnadigung des Tiergartenmörders hätte aussprechen müssen. Wäre das eine Konstruktion gewesen, die vielleicht dann besser gepasst hätte?
Also sie haben die Antwort auf die Frage im Prinzip ja gerade auch schon selbst gegeben. Das Übereinkommen sieht eben dann vor, dass eine Strafvollstreckung dann im Herkunftsland stattfindet. Und das war ja nie geplant.
Putin hat ja Krasikow quasi versichert, du bist mein Mann und deswegen werde ich dich befreien. Ja und es muss ja auch sein, Leuten dort zeigen, dass er den Krasikow befreit hat.
Na gut, er hätte natürlich eine große Begnadigungszeremonie machen können.
Jaja, aber dann hätte er ein Schauspiel aufführen müssen, wo er sagt, dass die das Schauspiel aufführen, ich mach das nicht. Und dann lässt Nesta ein Wort fallen, bei dem ich dann doch gleich ganz wach geküsst wurde.
Nebenbei bemerkt sieht man daran auch ganz gut, in was für einem absoluten Ausnahmezustand, in was für einer absoluten Ausnahmesituation wir uns da befinden. Unser Rechtssystem, das kommt in dieser Situation eines völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskriegs ganz eindeutig an seine Grenzen. Sie werden in dem ganzen Strafvollstreckungsrecht 4 49 Folgenden in der Strafprozessordnung keine Vorschrift finden, die auf so einen Fall explizit zugeschnitten ist. Einfach weil das als technisches und sehr nüchternes Rechtsgebiet eigentlich nur noch das regeln soll, was zuvor Gegenstand des gerichtlichen Ausspruchs war. Und das zeigt eigentlich sehr schön, was das für eine dramatische und auch besondere oder besorgniserregende Situation ist und wie sehr das unser Recht auch dann an seine Grenzen bringt.
Ja, wir haben ja schon thematisiert, dass wenn der Krieg einmal läuft und er ist ja immer noch contained auf die Ukraine. Vielleicht kann man sogar sagen auf diese ostukrainischen Regionen, auf die sich dann auch so Verhandlungssachen zuspitzen. Aber ökonomisch war das von Anfang an ein Weltkrieg. Öl wurde nach Indien verschifft, von dort dann irgendwie von uns gekauft. Alle fragen sich, was ist denn das für ein Quatsch? Ja, das müssen wir jetzt so machen, weil es ist ja Krieg. Wir müssen jetzt hier besondere Schauspiele aufführen und so. Und jetzt wird sogar das deutsche Rechtssystem so in Mitleidenschaft gezogen, dass sie im FAZ Einspruch Podcast einfach nur noch vom Ausnahmezustand sprechen. Das ist schon besorgniserregend, finde ich. Also das zeigt auch wieder in Amerika, es sind eben nicht nur amerikanische Präsidentschaftswahlen, sondern es steht einiges auf dem Spiel. Donald Trump müsste nicht aus der NATO aussteigen, sondern das Signal, er ist gewählt worden, reicht, um für Ausnahmezustände zu sorgen in der internationalen Verteidigungsarchitektur und so weiter und so fort. Das sind schon alles sehr bedenkliche Vorgänge.
Nicht so, dass wir eigentlich hier den Staat in seiner reinsten Form wiedersehen. Also wir haben dieses Recht. Wir haben das Recht und dann sagen wir, ja, das ist ja alles gut und schön und es läuft ja auch super. Und dann kommt so ein Zwischenfall oder eine Ausnahmesituation, der Ausnahmezustand und plötzlich gibt es irgendwelche Anweisungen von der Politik, dies und das. Und wir sehen doch jetzt gerade, du hast ja das Beispiel Fayser schon genannt, sie will auch dann anweisen, der Spruch muss verboten werden, diese Zeitschrift darf es nicht mehr geben, produziert eigentlich einen Ausnahmezustand und dann kann da das Gericht nochmal zurückrudern und sagen, ne ne, so geht das nicht. Aber hier sind wir zwischenstaatlich unterwegs und wir haben ja den Mörschheimer sehr intensiv behandelt und der sagt ja zwischen den Staaten ist nichts, das ist nicht eine höhere Institution, die alles regelt, die kann man versuchen zu etablieren, aber die ist nicht da, nur wenn man sich an diese Ordnungen dann hält, auf die man sich gar nicht hat, aber man kann auch jederzeit das brechen. Und eigentlich ist das gar nicht möglich, so einen gefangenen Austausch, aber man deichselt das dann so. Und das ließ mich aufhorchen. Und ich dachte natürlich an die politische Theologie von Karl Schmitt. Und deswegen hören wir jetzt hier mal Ausmitte.
Darf ich vorher noch? Vor, dass du jetzt hier die Torpedos rausholst. Also, Ausnahmen können die Regel durchaus bestätigen. Und das ist ja hier geschehen. Sie zeigt, also nur dadurch, dass es den Ausnahmefall gibt, wird ja uns in diesem Podcastgespräch, dieser Podcast dauert ja auch eine Stunde, und wir haben bestimmt 20 Minuten darüber diskutiert, wurden jetzt 20 Minuten noch mal die Normen betont, die üblicherweise und ansonsten immer gelten. Nur deswegen ist es ja ein Ausnahmezustand. Wenn Nancy Faeser irgendwie einen Quatsch macht, wird das ja durch die Checks and Balances, die im Start vorgesehen sind, also Verfassungsgefüge wieder eingefangen.
Da schon. Weil es aber auch nicht den politischen Willen gibt, könnte man sagen, das jetzt doch durchzuboxen.
Ja, aber hier ist doch ein großer Unterschied. Also dieser Mörder wurde freigelassen und das ist nicht, da gibt es keine Revision. Er ist jetzt einfach da. Das kann man nicht revidieren. Bei allen anderen Beispielen, die wir jetzt so nannten, also Merz macht hier Vorschläge da, Nancy Faeser verbietet irgendwie keine Ahnung. Das ist immer alles auch eine Beobachtung und eine Reflexion und Revision möglicherweise unterworfen, die für uns Wähler medial so durchdiskutiert wird, dass wir am Ende sagen, die konnte es nicht. Sie steht nicht drüber, sie konnte es nicht. Wir tauschen sie jetzt aus. Nun sagen wir im Rahmen unseres Gefüges.
Nun wird sich jetzt niemand aus der Regierung und schon gar nicht aus der Opposition ins Zeug legen, Faeser zu schützen, wenn sie irgendeine Sache unternimmt, die wieder schiefgeht. Aber wir haben doch gerade gesehen, wie der Staat eingegriffen hat bei den Klimaklebern. Das da plötzlich dann nicht mehr freie Meinungsäußerung, es ist ja alles so wichtig und so was. Sondern da ist der Staat mit aller Härte vorgegangen und produziert so einen Ausnahmezustand. Und deswegen hören wir Karl Schmitt. Die Ausnahme ist interessanter als der Normalfall. Das Normale beweist nichts. Die Ausnahme beweist alles. Sie bestätigt nicht nur die Regel. Die Regel lebt überhaupt nur von der Ausnahme. In der Ausnahme durchbricht die Kraft des wirklichen Lebens die Kruste einer in der Wiederholung erstarrten Mechanik. Das hat so etwas Vitalistisches auch. Das ist 20er, 30er Jahre. Man weiß, woher Schmitt stammt und was er so sonst gedacht hat. Darum soll es aber gar nicht gehen. Und ich finde aber diesen Gedanken sehr interessant zu sagen. Ja, die Ausnahme ist alles gar nicht die Regel. Du also genau umgekehrt, wie du es jetzt eben gesagt hast. Und er leitet dir davon dann auch seine Souveränitätsdefinition ab. Souverän ist, wer über den Ausnahmezustand entscheidet. Dass hier unter Ausnahmezustand ein allgemeiner Begriff der Staatslehre zu verstehen ist, nicht irgendeine Notverordnung oder jeder Belagerungszustand, wird sich aus dem Folgenden ergeben. Dass der Ausnahmezustand im eminenten Sinne für die juristische Definition der Staatslehre geeignet ist, hat einen systematischen rechtslogischen Grund. Die Entscheidung über die Ausnahme ist nämlich im eminenten Sinne Entscheidung. Denn eine generelle Norm, wie sie der normal geltende Rechtssatz darstellt, kann eine absolute Ausnahme niemals erfassen. Und daher auch die Entscheidung, dass ein echter Ausnahmefall gegeben ist, nicht restlos begründen. Das sagt ja Nesta in dem Sinne auch, wenn sie sagt, ja es kann gar nicht sein, dass wir ein Gesetz haben, das so etwas mit einschließt. Und dann gibt es also irgendetwas externes, das dann doch diese Entscheidung macht. Das ist dann nicht der Generalbundesanwalt allein, sondern der muss angewiesen werden. Das macht der Justizminister, der Justizminister wollte, so hören wir gleich auch noch mal, eigentlich das gar nicht so machen. Er war nicht so sehr für diesen Gefangenaustausch, aber Scholz war dafür. Also das heißt, da ist dann die Kanzlerkompetenz plötzlich das, was entscheidend ist. Und das finde ich doch interessant, dass wir in einer modernen, man würde sagen liberalen Demokratie plötzlich so einen Souveränitätsgedanken hat. Und der blitzt dann auf, wenn es um die Ausnahme geht. Und wir haben das ja auch schon früher erlebt beim Ausnahmezustand, der produziert wurde, im Zuge des 11. September. Du kennst ja auch diesen Film The Siege wahrscheinlich, der das auch sehr gut zeigt, der sogar noch vor dem 11. September herauskommt.
Also ich finde, dass dieses Faszinose im Ausnahmezustand, verstehe ich, gerade aus dieser politischen Richtung. Es gibt ja auch von Agamben dieses kleine Buch, wo er es so fast ins Unverständliche treibt. Dennoch, aus soziologischer Sicht, würde ich es fast wieder ein bisschen runter dimmen, denn ja, es bleibt halt immer ein Restrisiko. Nicht nur in der Technologie. Organisationen haben Satzungen, Hierarchien, klare Aufgabenverteilung, klare Motivationsstränge. Jeder sieht in seinem Arbeitsvertrag, warum er motiviert sein sollte jetzt, die für ihn gar nicht... Er mag sie nicht, die Arbeit, aber macht sie trotzdem und so weiter. Also man kann alles so und so weit regeln, aber nicht weiter. Und man muss sich trotzdem mit der Realität auseinandersetzen, die immer sagt, so ein bisschen weiter müsstet ihr es schon treiben. Jedes Unternehmen wird überrascht. Jede Familie muss plötzlich mit Unwägbarkeiten klarkommen. Und ich finde dann immer wieder interessant, wo, ohne jetzt so einen großen Popanz draus zu machen, wie der Ausnahmezustand, das ganze Verfassungsgefüge wird sozusagen gesprengt durch eine empirische Herausforderung, die jetzt zu bewältigen ist. Und da ist mir zuletzt von Judith Muster, die war beim Corporate Therapy Podcast, ich habe es auch schon mal erwähnt, dieser Führungsbegriff. Führung heißt nicht, der Vorgesetzte sagt dir, was du tun sollst, sondern er muss es nicht. Es steht in deinem Arbeitsvertrag, wie du dich verhalten sollst. Es steht in deiner Agenda, wann du wo erscheinen sollst. Der Dienstplan gibt dir alles vor. Nur irgendwann muss doch mal eine Entscheidung getroffen werden, die man nicht ableiten kann aus Satzung, Hierarchie, Aufgabenverteilung, Geld und so weiter. So und in dem Moment greift Führung. Und das Besondere dann ist, die Führung übernimmt nicht der Vorgesetzte, sondern derjenige, der in der Herausforderung die asymmetrischen Vorteile hat. Und es begegnet ganz häufig Lehrern, gerade heute, wenn sie Hausaufgaben geben. Und dann stellen sie plötzlich fest, also ich habe ja noch gedacht, ich verlasse mich einfach auf mein Studium von vor 30 Jahren, um auf der Höhe der Zeit zu sein. Aber die Kinder fragen einfach gbt und kriegen eine viel bessere Antwort. Und dann muss man sich seinen Kindern kurz ergeben. Wir haben von Bono dieses Buch Surrender. Es gibt Surrendermomente. Irgendwann sieht man, es geht nicht mehr weiter. Und dann muss man auf eine göttliche Fügung hoffen oder sich einfach dem Schicksal ergeben und nehmen, wie es kommt und danach wieder anfangen, im Rahmen des bisherigen das Beste daraus zu machen. Und das finde ich hier so interessant. Das ist am Ende mit einem Ausnahmezustand zu tun haben, den sie aber pragmatisch regeln müssen. Und dann kann es sein, dass die Führungskraft der junge Praktikant ist, weil es jetzt gerade erforderlich ist, dass wir mal einen ganz neuen Idee, einen ganz neuen Gedanken haben und es mal nicht so machen, wie wir es immer gemacht haben, weil dann alle sehen, das wäre der sichere Untergang. Wir brauchen jetzt was Neues. Und plötzlich sind die Schüler die Mächtigen oder die jungen Hospitanten, die so mal reinschneiden ins Unternehmen.
Jedoch unterscheidet dies ja gerade ein Unternehmen von einem Staat, denn der Staat kann diese Hierarchie ja nicht durchbrechen. Also nur der Kanzler konnte jetzt sagen, wir machen das jetzt so. Also der hat gesagt, Bushmann folgendes und und und. Und da kann jetzt nicht jemand sagen aus der dritten Reihe, ich mache das mal so und so. Sondern es geht da wirklich an die Spitze des Staates. Und Schmitt geht ja sogar noch weiter. Die Existenz des Staates bewährt hier eine zweifellose Überlegenheit über die Geltung der Rechtsnorm. Die Entscheidung macht sich frei von jeder normativen Gebundenheit und wird im eigentlichen Sinne absolut. Im Ausnahmefall suspendiert der Staat das Recht Kraft seines Selbsterhaltungsrechtes. Die zwei Elemente des Begriffs Rechtsordnung treten hier einander gegenüber und beweisen ihre begriffliche Selbstständigkeit. So wie im Normalfall das selbstständige Moment der Entscheidung auf ein Minimum zurückgedrängt werden kann, wird im Ausnahmefall die Norm vernichtet. Annichtung der Norm, Suspendierung des Rechts aus dem Selbsterhaltungstrieb des Staates. Jetzt kann man sagen, den Staat hätte es ja morgen auch noch gegeben, wenn wir den gefangenen Austausch nicht gemacht haben. Aber wir können es vielleicht ein bisschen größer einordnen, wenn wir uns den Podcast anhören von Paul Ronzheimer, Philipp Jartoff befragt.
Ein Fan von diesem Podcast.
Es sind schon manchmal ganz interessante Gespräche, die gehen natürlich jetzt auch auf.
Man nennt das Guilty Plasher. Das ist wie, wenn ich Michael Hüther höre.
Aber der ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, eben.
Nein, nein. Ich höre mir natürlich niemals irgend so einen Bildpodcast an, wenn es da um Thema Migration, CDU oder sowas geht. Mir geht es nur um etwas Außenpolitisches. Da kann man manchmal etwas erfahren, weil die Bild nun gute Quellen hat. Und da erfahren wir Folgendes.
Beispielsweise wurden mehrere deutsche Staatsbürger auch verhaftet. Glaubst du, dass Putin bewusst oder gezielt Menschen hat verhaften lassen, um Krasikow freizupressen?
Ja, absolut. Davon muss man ausgehen. Völlig richtige Zwischenfrage. Gerade der deutsche Staatsbürger, der jetzt zuletzt in Weißrussland dann zunächst ja verurteilt wurde, zur Todesstrafe verurteilt wurde. Gerade bei dem muss man davon ausgehen, dass der ganz bewusst festgenommen wurde, um insbesondere Druck auf Deutschland auszuüben. Denn das Problem für Deutschland war ja die ganze Zeit, auch bei der Frage von Nawalny immer, wie können wir hier erklären, dass wir den Tiergartenmörder freilassen, aus einem deutschen Gefängnis, und dafür in Anführungszeichen nur ein amerikanischer Staatsbürger freikommt.
Es ist wirklich so eigenartig, aber auch so klar verständlich, dass man sagt, es gibt so einen Selbsterhaltungstrieb des Staates, würde Karl Schmitt sagen. Und dieser bedeutet natürlich, dass man etwas für seine Bürger dann tut. Also im Sinne von, das ist deutsche Staatsdoktrin oder so, wir holen die zurück. Aber wir machen das jetzt nicht für jemand anderen, sondern wir machen das, wenn nur für uns. Also muss Putin dann wiederum deutsche Gefangene nehmen, unter irgendeinem willkürlichen Vorwand.
Also ein Geifel? Austausch?
Ja, dann sagt man, es sind da sieben Deutsche oder was auch immer. Die müssen wir jetzt herholen. Und dadurch kommen natürlich auch die Amerikaner mit frei. Es ging ja da vor allem um einen Journalisten, den man da freibekommen hat. Piatow sagt dann so schön.
Das ist wirklich eine so perverse Logik. Also wie gesagt, wären wir in einem Agenten-Thriller, würde das total Sinn ergeben.
Wir sind in einem Agenten-Thriller. Es ist nicht irgendwas James Bond oder so, sondern das ist der Agenten-Thriller. Das ist, wie die Staaten sich gegenüberstehen.
Putin hat im Grunde der deutschen Bundesregierung das Strongman-Prinzip übergestülpt. Weil er kann so über Menschen befinden. Wir haben dafür eigentlich Strafprozessordnungen und so weiter. Und dann hat er es einfach erzwungen, dass wir jetzt über den Ausnahmezustand diskutieren.
Ron Zimmer sagte auch, dass man einen Mörder aus dem Gefängnis freilässt. Es gab ja auch Widerstand ganz am Anfang. Insbesondere von der Außenministerin, von Annalena Baerbock. Ich glaube, am Anfang auch vom Justizminister Bushman. Aber, und auch das gehört zur politischen Debatte dazu, natürlich war es so, dass Joe Biden, dass die Mutter von Gershkovitsch, das Wall Street Journal und andere, schon seit Monaten keinen Druck, aber Kontakt gesucht haben zur Bundesregierung.
Ja, Kontakt gesucht haben ist ja eine vorsichtige Formulierung für Druck ausgeübt, dass das jetzt stattfinden soll. Und dann gibt es auch wieder ein Versprechen, das natürlich damit verbunden ist. Also wenn wir das jetzt so auf den Weg bringen, dann bekommst du, Olaf Scholz, auch nochmal von mir eine ganz klare positive Akzentuierung in den Medien.
Aber angenommen, wir wären jetzt wirklich in einem Roman. Ja. Denn Nawalny ist ja gestorben oder wurde getötet, bevor er da auch noch einbezogen werden konnte. Angenommen, Nawalny, für uns alle bekannt, und Christian Lindner macht jeden Tag diesen Tweet und wie auch immer, wäre in dieser ökonomischen Kalkulation Geisel gegen Gefangene mit aufgenommen worden.
So war es ja anfangs gedacht.
Genau. Hätten wir dann jetzt auch anders diskutiert, hätten wir mehr Verständnis für Ausnahmezustand, klar, es ging ja um Nawalny und so weiter, hätten wir es leichter abgehakt und nicht so viele Nachfragen im Einspruch-Podcast gehabt, um uns das nochmal erklären zu können. Ich glaube nämlich schon. Also Putins Logik ist man da schon sehr entgegengekommen.
Und für Putin wäre Nawalny schon, also eine Freilassung von Nawalny, ja nicht Bankrotterklärung, aber doch ein großer Kostenpunkt gewesen innerhalb der eigenen Riegen. Und deswegen hat er sich dann Nawalny anders entledigt, wollte aber unbedingt noch Krasikow frei haben und ist dann auf eine andere Strategie umgeschwenkt. Und Biden ist dann am Flughafen, begrüßt die Freigelassenen und sagt dann nochmal vor der Weltpresse, das ist so quasi das Dankeschön dann an Olaf Scholz. Man kann ihn kaum verstehen, er sagt aber, der Kanzler war unglaublich. Das hat alles ganz toll funktioniert. Wir sind also hier wieder in so einem Realismus angekommen bei Mörschheimer. Die Staaten stehen sich als Konkurrenten oder als Gegner gegenüber. Wie gehen sie miteinander um? Nun, es ist ja auch in diesem Monat noch etwas passiert, nämlich wir haben neue Entwicklungen oder neue Informationen bekommen. Die Nordstream-Sprengung ist offenbar doch ein bisschen anders verlaufen, als manche oder sehr sehr viele gerade in den deutschen Medien anfangs dachten. Wir hören noch mal einen alten Clip von Carlo Massalla.
Meines Erachtens deutet alles darauf hin, dass es eine Sabotageakt seitens der russischen Föderation war.
Ja, wie sich nun deutlich zeigt, scheint das kaum der Fall zu sein. Noch mal Ronzheimer Podcast. Bojan Panczewski, den wir schon mal hier vorgestellt hatten, war zu Gast. Er hat für das Wall Street Journal das ja alles sehr sehr gut recherchiert. Er ist der, der das aufgedeckt hat. Und Ronzheimer fragt jetzt ganz interessant.
Ich erinnere mich, dass danach alle Experten, ehrlicherweise auch ich und andere, sofort gesagt haben, es macht eigentlich Sinn, oder es macht nur Sinn, dass Russland dahinter steckt. Warum war das so?
Ich weiß es nicht. Du hast es gedacht. Ich dachte sofort, das sei Ukraine.
Ich rede jetzt nicht nur von mir, sondern auch von vielen Experten aus der Region, auch mit Geheimdienstlern, ehrlicherweise am Anfang, die sofort gesagt haben, da steckt Russland dahinter.
Ja, ich habe mir das alles anhören müssen. Aber was sind das für Experten? Die müssen ihre Expertise jetzt ein bisschen auf die Prüfung stellen. Ich meine, was hätte Russland für ein Motiv, so etwas zu machen? Das ist komplette Quatsch. Zum Damals, Jetzt und Immer gewesen.
Kompletter Quatsch. Es ist so einleuchtend. Wofür ist die Pipeline gut? Naja, dass Russland quasi einen permanenten Geldzufluss hat. Da fließt der Rohstoff durch, das Geld wird dann überwiesen. Und natürlich hat ja Russland auch einen Blick auf die Zeit danach überlegt, wenn dieser Krieg vorbei ist, könnte vielleicht doch noch mal mit Deutschland was gehen.
So wie man das ja auch alles erst nach 2014, also nach der Anekdoten der Krim und so weiter, ganz recht geschrieben hat.
So, ist ja alles möglich eine andere Regierung. Ja, also sicherlich würde Nord Stream 2 nicht mehr dann in Gang gesetzt werden, wenn jetzt die Grünen in der Regierung wären. Das ist geradezu unvorstellbar. Aber unter anderem Konstellationen und damit meine ich jetzt gar nicht AfD, könnte man sich das durchaus vorstellen, dass das in fünf oder zehn Jahren anders gelaufen wäre. Also wäre das ja im Sinne des russischen Interesses, dass man gerade da diese Pipeline schützt. Jetzt ist ganz interessant, ja.
Ich frage mich aber auch, kann man diesen kleinen Abschnitt nicht einfach reparieren? Also da liegen doch hunderte Kilometer von Rohren und die sind dann in zwei Stellen zerstört.
Gut, aber das will ja jetzt nun wirklich keiner. Also jetzt das wieder reparieren.
Ich meine jetzt so, ist die ganze Pipeline auf Dauer zerstört, nur weil da so ein O- drin ist, ist doch irgendwie...
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wird immer so ausgeblendet.
Gibt es Möglichkeiten, das wiederher zu richten. Interessant ist ja jetzt nun, dass wir eigentlich wieder in so einem Ausnahmezustand sind. Denn man kann ja jetzt nicht eigentlich da in der Ostsee rumfahren und dann so was machen. Wer wusste eigentlich davon? Panczewski kommt jetzt, er spricht dann von er, also von Zelenski.
Meine Berichterstattung ist dicht. Also der, der hat davon gewusst, also gemeint ist Zelenski. Am Anfang, dann hat er einen Anruf bekommen von den Amerikanern, die also nicht er persönlich, sondern seine, sein Büro. Die Amerikaner haben gesagt, sie haben einen Nachricht weitergeleitet, dass die Ukraine aufhören sollen mit diesem Plan, die Pipeline zu zerstören. Und so, wie ich weiß, so wie ich berichtet habe, hat er auch tatsächlich dem Militär gesagt, dass sie das Ganze stoppen sollen und die haben das aber nicht gestoppt.
Also es gab diese kleine Gruppe von Leuten, ein paar Oligarchen, ein paar Militärs, die haben sich da getroffen. Die Ukraine kam ganz gut vor an Anfang des Krieges und dann haben sie diesen Plan ausgeheckt. Darüber soll Zelenski informiert worden sein. Er habe dann aber im Moment, bevor das dann losgehen sollte, gesagt, nee, mach das lieber nicht. Wie energisch das geschehen ist, wie losgelöst die von Zelenski agieren konnten. Das steht natürlich so im Raum.
Ja, aber es steht im Raum im Sinne von dieser Raum ist, ich habe so einen zwölf sekundigen Clip des Heutes-Journal. Also es war wirklich das deutsche Millionenpublikum.
Das Wall Street Journal berichtet, die Anschläge auf die Nord Stream Pipeline seien auf höchster ukrainischer Regierungsebene gebilligt worden, anfangs auch von Präsident Zelenski. Der weist die Vorwürfe entschieden zurück.
Ja, also das Wall Street Journal und das Heute-Journal. Jetzt ist also die Rechtfertigungspflicht so ein bisschen umgedreht. Ja. Zelenski weiß halt Bescheid und er äußert sich nicht dazu. Also wissen wir jetzt alle Bescheid.
Richtig, ja. Ronsheimer fragt nach dem Informanten.
Und du hast einen gefunden, der an diesem Abend mit dabei war und von allem wusste. Welches Interesse hatte der, mit dir zu sprechen? Und wie hast du den gefunden?
Also die Details kann ich natürlich nicht erzählen.
Tja, was ist das für ein Informant, der so etwas auch noch zugibt?
Seine Meinung war einfach, dass die Beteiligten allesamt Orden bekommen sollen und dass die quasi Helden sind. Und diese Meinung, glaube ich, wird geteilt von anderen Beteiligten. Und ich würde mich, es wäre für mich nicht überraschend, wenn die Mehrheit der Ukraine auch so denkt.
Ja, der hat sich ja nicht geschämt und gesagt, eigentlich will ich damit nichts zu tun haben, sondern man ist eher stolz darauf, das gemacht zu haben. Und das ist ja aus der ukrainischen Perspektive auch sehr gut nachvollziehbar, denn das ist tatsächlich ja etwas, wo man was bewirken kann durch eine sehr, sehr gezielte Konzentration, durch einen sehr gezielten Anschlag. Nur bedeutet das ja jetzt von deutscher Seite aus, dass da quasi der Verbündete etwas macht, das gegen einen gerichtet ist. Also hinter dem Rücken wird da etwas gemacht. Und jetzt kommt ja auch diese Rechtfertigung. Egal wie es gelaufen ist, am Ende können wir alle froh sein, dass es diese Pipeline nicht mehr gibt. Aber das ist ja nicht wirklich ein Argument. Ja, das ist ja etwas, was man eigentlich hätte politisch auf den Weg bringen müssen, dass diese Pipeline nicht gebaut wird oder dass sie auch nie mehr ans Netz geht. Aber interessant ist ja, dass man jetzt so sagt, naja, es war jetzt schon dann im Grunde alles gut. Also dieser Ausnahmezustand, der da produziert wurde, wird jetzt nur so diskursiv eingehegt, weil man ihn politisch nicht einhegen kann. Also eigentlich würde das, jetzt wenn man das politisch weiterdenkt, ja eine große Debatte auslösen. Können wir überhaupt noch Unterstützung für die Ukraine leisten, wenn zugleich Infrastruktur zerstört wird? Das ist ja ein terroristischer Akt. Das geht nicht. Diese Diskussion kommt ja überhaupt nicht auf. Also große Schweigen eigentlich dazu innerhalb der Regierung. Und deswegen wird das jetzt nur diskursiv ein wenig eingehegt, indem man sagt, naja, aber wir sind doch alle froh, dass die jetzt weg ist, die Pipeline.
Ja, die Zeit heilt alle Wunden. Also wenn die glauben, sie könnten das machen, müssten dann nur zwei Jahre Schweigen und dann gibt es Orden dafür. Ist doch wirklich vielsagend.
Ja, wir schauen jetzt noch darauf, wie Polen damit umgegangen ist. Also Polen ist ja auch ein sehr wichtiger Akteur. Polen auch kein Fan dieser Pipeline. Und dann gab es ja einen Haftbefehl gegen einen Beteiligten, einen deutschen Haftbefehl. Und dieser Mensch, der hielt sich in Polen auf, der zu Fandung ausgeschrieben ist von den deutschen Behörden.
Gegen ihm gibt es ja diesen Haftbefehl, diesen berühmten Haftbefehl. Der Mann war zumindest temporär in Polen, in der Nähe von Warschau. Im Juni, Ende Juni, 21. Juni, glaube ich, hat Deutschland diesen Haftbefehl und den polnischen Kollegen gegeben. Die Polen haben den Empfang bestätigt, haben aber nicht gehandelt.
Jetzt sind wir nochmal bei dieser Sache. Es gibt da einen Haftbefehl, Recht, Normen. Ja, wir könnten jetzt auch wieder diese ganze Leier andrehen. Und wir fragen uns, warum hat ein Polen nicht gehandelt?
Dann hat ein polnischer Staatsanwalt gesagt, dass irgendwie ein Formfehler da war bei den Deutschen, bei der Deutschen, bei dem Deutschen Anzuchen, dass die nicht alles rechtens war und der war nicht so richtig ausgeschrieben. Was eigentlich kaum zu glauben ist, wenn man glaubt, wie die deutschen Behörden funktionieren, dass die Formfehler machen, ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Also, die mussten jetzt auch wieder irgendeine rechtliche Legitimation schaffen. In Wahrheit haben sie natürlich das Recht suspendiert. Also, wir sind hier wieder in diesem Karl-Schmidt-Paradigmah, eigentlich.
Ja, und wir wurden nicht nur düpiert, sondern auch gedemütigt. Ja. Bürokratie. Also, wenn wir irgendwas können.
Ja. Dann doch das. Ja, zum Schluss noch.
Frechheit.
Wie steht eigentlich der politische Außenminister zu der ganzen Geschichte?
Was mir ziemlich klar ist, dass der jetzige Außenminister Radek Sikorski sich tierisch gefreut hat, als die Pipeline in die Luft gesprengt wurde. Und er hat diesen komischen Tweet in die Welt gesetzt, wo er meinte, danke USA.
Ja, der ist dann sehr schnell wieder gelöscht worden, dieser Tweet. Aber der zeigt auch nochmal deutlich, dass dann, wenn wir auf so einer globalen zwischenstaatlichen Ebene sind, die Staaten sich, genau wie Mörscher was beschreibt, als Gegner gegenüber stehen. Und dann wird das Recht dann suspendiert, wenn es dem eigenen Staat nützt. Das heißt, wir haben so lange eigentlich diese Karl-Schmidt-Lehre, aufgrund auch von Schmidts Nazi-Mitgliedschaft, Vergangenheit, da haben wir das immer so von uns gewesen. Aber wir sehen gerade eigentlich, wie dieses Paradigma des Ausnahmezustands auf der politischen Bühne total präsent ist. Sogar so sehr aber, dass es als normal empfunden wird. Also dadurch, dass es gar keine Debatte darüber gibt, dass wir jetzt nicht in große Streitigkeiten geraten mit Polen oder so, ist das doch eigentlich schon so eine Akzeptanz, dass das so ist. Wenn ich jetzt noch mal mich erinnere an diese Enthüllungen von Snowden, da war ja auch der Versuch sehr schnell da der Bundesregierung damals, den USA zu sagen, wir sind jetzt nicht amused, aber mehr als zu sagen, unter Freunden macht man das nicht, hat man sich dann doch nicht getraut. Jetzt sind wir eigentlich an so einem Punkt, wo man selbst so etwas nicht mehr sagt, sondern einfach, dass so unter den Tisch kehrt.
Hier gilt ja noch, okay, es ist hauptsächlich russische Infrastruktur und ja, ein Mörder wird ausgeliefert, aber dafür kriegen wir ja auch Leute zurück. Das sind ja Sachen, die kann man jetzt klar, Ausnahmezustand nicht so formal rein eindeutig argumentieren, aber publizistisch kann man da sehr einfach eine Meinung haben, wir finden das gut. Und das heißt aber noch nicht, dass wir das deswegen grundlegend akzeptieren, sondern diese Ausnahme werden, also diese Brüche werden da einkalkuliert, wo man sie sich politisch leisten kann. Wir strafen jetzt niemanden für das Aus-der-Rolle-Fallen, also die Verfassung überflügeln ab.
Ich würde sagen, beim Gefangene-Austausch würde ich das absolut sagen, dass das richtig war, das zu machen. Und das ist immer gut, wenn man auch dann Leute dadurch retten kann, weil da waren ja Leute zum Tode verurteilt in Russland dann. Ich würde aber sagen, weil der Pipeline bin ich nicht dafür, dass man das so macht. Also man kann das entweder politisch lösen, dass man keine Energie von Russland nimmt, aber wir können jetzt nicht anfangen, immer da, wo uns irgendwas nicht gefällt, zu sagen, hör, dann schicken wir jetzt auch mal jemanden los, der da einen Atomkraftwerk verhindert oder da dies macht. Also wenn Staaten so anfangen, wo sind wir denn da gelandet? Da können wir uns ja gegenseitig die Drohnen in den Hof schicken.
Jetzt mach so quasi meine Argumente, weil ich wollte dir ja gerade den Karl Schmidt wieder austreiben, denn so leicht ist die Akzeptanz für solche Sachen nämlich nicht, dass man einfach hinnimmt, ah ja, da steht halt jemand über dem Gesetz. Na ja, selbst ich bin der Meinung, eine Pipeline hat im Meer einfach gar nichts zu suchen. Die muss auf dem Land sein, damit sie, wenn sie kaputt geht, wir sie reparieren können, wir wissen, was passiert mit diesem Öl, dann backern wir das einfach aus. Ja, bedeutet halt, dass Polen dafür Transitkosten bekommt. In der Ostsee kriegt das niemand. Aber es ging ja nicht darum, hier mehr Kapazität oder irgendwas besser zu machen, sondern nur, um Polen Bogen zu machen. So, wir sehen aber jetzt demnächst, also klar, es wird jetzt irgendwie verhindert wahrscheinlich, aber angenommen, wir hätten jetzt unter diesen Maßgaben, wie wir im letzten Podcast über Donald Trump sprachen oder im vorletzten, diese Person sozusagen von Rechts wegen in ständigen souveränen Ich-befinde-über-den-Ausnahmezustand. Die Akzeptanz wäre ganz gering und das würde auch große internationale Turbulenzen bedeuten, dieses Experiment tatsächlich zu wagen. Dieses amerikanische Experiment, 250 Jahre Demokratie und so weiter, das hat so weit funktioniert. Also wir akzeptieren das, obwohl es da immense Armut über, jeder verteidigt sich doch irgendwie selber mit Schusswaffen und so weiter. Aber trotzdem gilt es als akzeptiert und verteidigungswürdig. Wenn jetzt so wie wir das beschrieben hatten, das Oberstdienstgerichtshof enthebt den Präsidenten, den Verfassungsgefüge und installiert ihn, wir wüssten, das hätte keine 250 Jahre Bestand. Also diese Carl-Schmidt-Logik kann man so und so weit treiben, aber es ist eben ein Ausnahmezustand. Die Regel muss schon noch die Regel bleiben, damit der Ausnahmezustand als Ausnahmezustand... Also wir können den Ausnahmezustand jetzt nicht institutionalisieren und dann sagen, Carl Schmitt hat immer recht oder sowas.
Nein, man kann nicht ein permanentes Chaos produzieren und sagen, jetzt ist immer nur eine Person für alles verantwortlich und dediktiert. Aber auch kein permanenten Ausnahmezustand? Naja, man hat es schon sehr weit getrieben. Also ich finde zum Beispiel nach dem 11. September hat man den permanenten Ausnahmezustand sehr ausgewertet.
Aber der muss ja auch wieder juristisch nachformuliert werden.
Ja, aber dann findet man ja Mittel und Wege offenbar.
Genau.
Also das zeigt sich ja hier auch. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sehe, welche Forderungen bisweilen von CDU-Politikern laut werden, im Umgang mit pro-palästinensischen Demonstrationen, würde ich sagen, wollen die ja eigentlich auch einen permanenten Ausnahmezustand eigentlich herstellen. Mit Bezug auf die Flüchtlinge, die ja keine Wähler sind, würde auch ein permanenter Ausnahmezustand hergestellt werden. Es gibt jetzt ja schon diese ganzen Rufen, die müssen ganz anders kontrolliert werden. Die müssen also in anderer Weise noch mal als Staatsbürger zweiter Klasse, sie sind ja keine Staatsbürger, aber als Menschen zweiter Klasse auch behandelt werden in der Öffentlichkeit. Also man produziert diese Ausnahmezustände und auf der geopolitischen Ebene ist es ja wahnsinnig sichtbar. Deswegen gucken wir auch bei der einen Sache genau hin und bei der anderen gucken wir sehr genau weg. Das zeigt ja eigentlich, dass da Schmitt absolut recht hat. Nur ist es nicht immer von nöten laufenden Ausnahmezustand zu produzieren. Also wenn man jetzt irgendein Handelsabkommen mit den USA schließt, da brauche ich keinen Ausnahmezustand für. Das kann man anders machen. Das macht man mit den Schiedsgerichten.
Aber wie gesagt, ich finde so bei Karl Schmitt, ich finde es einen allgemeinen Platz zu sagen, es bleibt halt immer ein Restrisiko und jemand muss dann mal führen. Ja, also so in dieser Organisation zu zur Logik.
Nur zeigt sich ja hier diese Staatsgewalt in so einem hohen Maße, also die Staatsgewalt, die einfach dann Gnade vor Recht ergehen lässt oder die dann auch ganz brutal zuschlagen kann. Und ich sehe das schon als ein ganz großes Problem jetzt auch in Bezug auf die Pipeline, dass das einen enormen Vertrauensverlust produziert. Denn natürlich werden jetzt die meisten Leute nicht dafür sein, dass man jetzt die Pipeline wieder startet heute. Ja, aber dass es einfach von einem anderen Land einen Angriff gegeben hat, einem Land, dem man aber gleichzeitig hilft. Und jetzt die Regierung sagt, naja, wollen wir jetzt nicht überreden. Das produziert doch genau folgende Sichtweise. Okay, die machen da eh so ein ganz eigenes Ding. Alles, was hier erzählt wird, ist Quatsch.
Okay, aber dann provokant gefragt. Wir hatten ja das amerikanische neue Modell jetzt besprochen. Wenn ich jetzt sage, Donald Trump und seine Leute machen das, weil sie Carl Schmitt gelesen haben und sagen, der hatte eigentlich recht.
Ja, die haben ja Carl Schmitt gelesen.
So, würdest du jetzt sagen, die haben halt Carl Schmitt gelesen und er hat eigentlich recht? Oder gilt nicht trotzdem, nein, die Gefahren sind ganz schön groß, den Ausnahmezustand zum regulären, so regieren wir jetzt zu machen.
Das ist ja nichts Normatives. Carl Schmitt empfiehlt ja nicht, machen sie eine Ausnahmezustand.
Aber Trump leitet das ja daraus ab.
Trump leitet daraus ab, das heißt für mich eigentlich, Carl Schmitt hat recht, aber es ist trotzdem nicht praktikabel. Nee, Carl Schmitt hat recht, es wäre nur gut, wenn andere regieren. Damit die, also wenn ich möchte nicht, dass...
Ein so König ja, aber ein guter König.
Nein, den Ausnahmezustand gibt es. Der ist auch in einer liberalen Demokratie offenbar da, sonst hätten wir diese Fälle nicht. Das ist jetzt die Frage, wer ist derjenige, der über den Ausnahmezustand entscheidet? Will ich, dass das Höcke ist? Nein. Will ich, dass das Trump ist? Nein. Will ich, dass das Olaf Scholz ist? Na, manchmal vielleicht. Aber...
Aber es gäbe welche, bei denen du sagen würdest, da finde ich es okay.
Naja, uns ist ja schon mal klar, dass manche schlechter sind. Also sind auch manche wohl besser. Nein, wir würden doch bei manchen Sachen... Man kann natürlich eine fundamentale Staatskritik davon anleiten und sagen, deswegen muss also der Staat aufgelöst werden. Das halte ich jetzt für die nächsten Jahre nicht für besonders realistisch. Ich muss mir ja die Frage stellen, wer ist also derjenige, der am Ende so eine brutale Entscheidungsgewalt hat? Soll das jemand sein, von dem ich eher ausgehe, dass er da in die Richtung... Also ich finde zum Beispiel, ich vergleiche jetzt Schultz mit Baerbock, also offenbar war Baerbock gegen diesen gefangenen Austausch, ich finde, dass es erstmal dem Kanzler hoch anzurechnen, dass er für so etwas ist, weil es zwar nicht gerecht ist in dem Sinne, der Mörder wird freigelassen, aber zugleich hat er sehr viele Unschuldige oder übermäßig Bestrafte damit gerettet, zum Beispiel vor der Todesstrafe. Und dieser humane Akt ist einer, dem ich sagen würde, dass es dann ein Souveränitätsakt, den ich grundsätzlich besser finde. Aber für mich ist das nicht normativ. Also ich kann sagen, ich wünschte, es gäbe nicht diese Ausnahmezustände und diese Arten der Souveränität. Ich stelle nur fest, es ist so vorhanden.
Was ich beobachte, bei mir jetzt gerade, bei dem regulären Ausnahmezustand, wie ihn Karl Schmitt beschreibt, angewendet im Falle gefangenen Austausch, ist es für mich total unerheblich, wer da Kanzler ist. Solange diejenigen sagen, ja, das machen wir mal.
Ja, manche hätten es nicht gemacht.
Genau, manche hätten es nicht gemacht. Aber dann wäre es halt kein Ausnahmezustand. Also dann hätte man nichts angewendet, dann hätten wir gar keine Diskussion zum Ausnahmezustand. Jetzt haben wir eine Diskussion zum Ausnahmezustand, weil es zum Ausnahmezustand kam. Und in dieser konkreten Fragestellung würde ich aber jetzt sagen, das hätte von mir aus auch Merz machen können oder wer auch immer. Also da ist es mir völlig egal.
Selbstverständlich.
Beim institutionellen Ausnahmezustand, also das oberste Gericht in Amerika sagt, derjenige steht jetzt grundsätzlich drüber, was über Karl Schmitt hinausgeht. Also der Ausnahmezustand ist ein Zustand und keine Ausnahme mehr. Da würde ich sagen, da ist es dann nicht egal und dann kommen wir aber in Teufels Küche.
Genau.
Weil dann kann ich nur sagen, ja ich sage, das wäre ein guter und das wäre ein schlechter, aber ich sehe ja, dass 50% der Leute ganz andersrum optieren und das trotzdem für mich dann auch gilt.
Ich will ja auch nicht die Institutionen abschaffen, sondern wir machen nur noch der Ausnahmezustand. Das ist ja im Prinzip das, wohin dann Schmitt es getrieben hat. Er schreibt ja dann mit Hitler an der Macht diesen Text, der Führer schützt das Recht. Und das ist genau so eine Konstruktion, dass der Führer also eigentlich immer über dem Recht steht. Und was er entscheidet, auch so etwas wie den Röhm-Purz, ist in Ordnung, weil er der Führer ist und der Führer schützt das Recht. So und das ist die ganz große Gefahr. Nur glaube ich, ist die Schmitt-Lektüre deshalb sinnvoll, um auch zu zeigen, selbst da, wo alle sich die ganze Zeit auf Normen und Regeln und alles konzentrieren, wir diese Ausnahme dann doch haben, wenn es hart auf hart kommt. Also es dann nicht so ist wie an einem schönen Sonntag, wenn sowieso alles funktioniert.
Okay, dann nutzen wir mal diese Diskussion, um über Thüringen zu sprechen.
Gern.
Hast du Clips zu Thüringen?
Nein. Wir wollen richtig lospoltern oder was? Du könntest vielleicht diesen einen Clip spielen, den du schon mal im Fernsehpodcast hattest. Diese zwei Clips sehen wir erst als Montagsdemonstration, die sich gegen Lügenpresse und dergleichen zu wehrsetzen will.
Es ging ordentlich zur Sache.
Und dann sitzt dort ein Rentner unter seinem Obstbaum und ist auch nicht zufrieden.
Zwei Clips aus dem Fernsehpodcast, vom Dienstag gewünscht, zum einen Montags-Demos. Die ging es konkret darum, was da skandiert wird.
Ja, dass wir so einen Eindruck von dieser Atmosphäre bekommen.
Okay, wir hören mal rein. Wir hören vorher noch einen Rentner, der in seinem Schützenverein sitzt und noch halbwegs okaye Argumente macht.
Sie wollen das Alter nicht mehr haben. Und die meisten von den AfD-Wählern, die ich so kenne, die springen da auf den Zug auf, da werden ein paar Ruhlen rausgehauen. Das gefällt erst mal, ohne groß nachzudenken. Und dann wählen wir die halt.
Der Unmut, der Frost, er ist hier im Südwesten Thüringens an vielen Orten spürbar. Dabei ist die Arbeitslosigkeit niedrig. Manche der Unzufriedenen zieht es seit Jahren montags auf die Straße.
Die sofortige Abschaltung aller Lügenmedien! Keine Steuerverschwendung im Ausland!
Man müsste jetzt sehen, wie trostlos in einer Menschenlehre entgegen da zehn Leute für wen eigentlich diese Demonstrationen veranstalten. Für sich selber, das ist völlig absurd.
Demonstrationen muss man ja veranstalten vor den Mächtigen, um sie unter Druck zu setzen. Das sieht ja niemand, es sei denn, es kommt mal ein Kamerateam vorbei.
Ja, es ist auch eine dieser Pointen. Christian Lindner redet, ich weiß nicht genau wo und wann, er folgt irgendwo auf dem Marktplatz vor dem großen Theater, also zentralste Stelle. Und es kommen zehn Leute. Lars Klingbeil sucht sich irgendein Biergarten aus. Es sitzen genau die 30 Ortsverbandsmitglieder der SPD vor ihm. Also die Leute sind unglaublich wütend in Thüringen. Aber selbst wenn die Politik zu ihnen kommt, die Regierung vorstellig wird, gehen sie nicht hin. Also die Demonstrationen, die wir jetzt gehört haben, die fanden irgendwo statt, aber nicht da, wo sie hingehört.
Ja und auch hier wieder dieses Interessante, dass man will, dass die Politik handelt, aber man hat überhaupt keine Vorstellung von Kompetenzen der Politik. Also alle Lügenmedien abschalten. Wo ist der Hebel?
Ja gut, okay, da könnte man einfach die Staatskanzlei hat, die Hoheit über die Verträge, die dann auch für den MDR gelten.
Was macht man mit dem Privatfernsehen? Muss man das auch nochmal?
Aber das mischt sich auch politisch nicht ein. Das schickt ja nur Joko und Klaas.
Möglicherweise und...
Und natürlich immer mal die 15 Minuten oder was auch immer da erspielt wird an Aufmerksamkeit.
Aber das ist so eine interessante Vorstellung von oder alle Steuergeldverschwendungen im Ausland stoppen. Das ist ja eine sehr interessante Vorstellung von, wie Politik eigentlich sein könnte. Und da ist ja die Sache, dass also alles, was da jetzt gefordert wird, natürlich fortwährend enttäuscht werden wird, egal, wer gewählt wird.
Jetzt hast du dir noch einen Clip gewünscht. Den habe ich ja mit Mig auch besprochen. Nun ist es so, alles, was wir jetzt betont haben, strapazieren wir jetzt. Eine einzelne Person sitzt in einem Menschenlehrern. Es ist nicht nur ein Garten, es ist eine Plantage. Es sind Obstbäume. Er geht mit seiner Leiter dahin, pflückt mit der Hand selbst, nimmt sich einen Gartenstuhl, hat vor sich ein Tisch, ein Getränk, ist eigentlich der entspannteste Situation ever und er redet. Wir haben zu diesen Sprüchen, die er jetzt sagt, einfach nur gesagt, dem ist nicht zu helfen. Also es gibt keine Ansprache eines Politikers, die hier noch etwas verändern könnte. In dieser Grundhaltung dieser Person. Ich bin gespannt, du hast ihm jetzt gewünscht, was du dazu sagst, ob du da noch einen Flug Schneisen siehst.
Einer, der regelmäßig montags mit dabei ist, ist der Rentner und Hobbyobstbauer Frank Schellhorn.
Ich lasse mir nichts mehr vorbeten. Die DTE hat uns 40 Jahre lang vorgebetet, sie sind die größten, die besten, wirtschaftsrang sieben auf der Welt, dann hatten wir keinen Autoreifen usw. Authentizität, nicht Wasser predigen und Wein saufen. Da sind wir. Und das ist einfach der Unmut, der entstanden ist. Und wie gesagt, wenn mit den Menschen nicht geredet wird, entgleitet das.
Das ist der Unmut und er kann es sich selbst gar nicht erklären. Er weiß ja gar nicht genau, was er will. Man kann natürlich immer sagen, an der Spitze des Staates stehen irgendwelche Leute, die in die eigene Tasche wirtschaften.
Man möchte nicht, dass seine Politiker ihm immer nur leere Sprüche, Nonsens und irgendwas erzählen. Und hat gleichzeitig nur leere Sprüche, Nonsens und gar nichts zu sagen.
Ich wollte diesen Clip haben, weil ich den gehört habe, nachdem ich Ecke Heidenreich bei den Sternstunden gesehen habe. Und musste noch mal daran denken, er hat dieses furchtbare Gejammer. Das ist absolut das Gejammer, aus dem sich politisch nichts Sinnvolles ableiten lässt. Aber es ist eine Seinsweise für ihn geworden. Und ich würde sagen, bei sehr vielen Leuten, nicht nur im Osten, aber da gucken wir jetzt hier gerade besonders hin, ist diese Art des Sprechens eine Seinsweise geworden. Und hier frage ich mich, ja, politisch kann man den nicht mehr adressieren mit, aber wir haben jetzt die und die Reform auf dem Weg gebracht. Man müsste eigentlich ein Klima schaffen, in dem gute Laune ist. Also man müsste eigentlich so eine Fernsehgartenatmosphäre herstellen.
Man muss ihm TikTok wegnehmen und den Fernsehgarten hinstellen. Digital Detox würde diesem Mann die Lebensqualität um 100 Prozent heben.
Ja, weil er kriegt ja von all dem, was er beklagt, sowieso da nichts mit.
Null!
Er wird da auch noch nie... Alles virtuell!... Migration gesehen haben.
Der Typ in so einer virtuellen Welt, der hat noch nicht mal so eine Brille auf und lebt schon komplett da nicht.
Jaja. Und das scheint aber ja sehr, sehr weit verbreitet zu sein. Ich würde sagen, also ich will nicht hier das Klischee vom Jama-Ossi bedienen.
Doch, ich schon.
Du willst das bedienen, aber du kommst aus dem Ossi.
Die jammern und machen nichts. Das war der Tenor aller Journalisten, die dort vor Ort waren. Jesse Wehmer und so. Die haben alle Reportage gemacht. Die kommen zurück ins Studio und sagen, diese Leute dort machen nichts. Die gründen keine Vereine, die reden nicht mit ihren Nachbarn, die gehen nicht auf die Straße und machen mal irgendetwas gar nicht.
Richtig.
Die wollen einfach nur abgeholt werden und wundern sich, dass sie Langeweile haben, weil ihr Kanzler ihnen kein Theaterprogramm hinlegt oder sowas.
So, aber ich möchte sagen, Du willst sie nochmal in Schutz nehmen? Nein, ich will die überhaupt nicht in Schutz nehmen. Ich würde nur sagen, der Osten ist die Avantgarde des Westens. Ich würde sagen, dass genau diese Gemütsstimmung sich sehr ausbreitet überall. Und dass, wenn du jetzt mal abseits von Frankfurt denkst, du bist hier wirklich in einer sehr außergewöhnlichen Stadt, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Da brauchst du nur nach Koblenz gehen, da brauchst du nur nach Trier oder sonst wo hingehen. Dann wirst du auf eine solche Stimmung, wie sie hier verbreitet ist, finden. Da sind die Leute vielleicht noch ein bisschen enger geschnürt mit ihrem Deckmantel der Zivilisation, dass sie nicht gleich Lügenpresse sagen. Aber im Tonfall, in der ganzen Art ist es schon sehr ähnlich. Und das breitet sich in höchstem Maße aus. Und die Politik, die das auch noch weiter forciert, die wird dann belohnt mit Wählerstimmen. Aber das ist ganz interessant, dass wir also nicht mehr eine andere Form haben von Gemeinschaft. Also das ist auch deswegen nochmal so wichtig zu sagen. Ein Unterschied zu dem alten Faschismus, also der alte Faschismus italienischer, spanischer oder deutscher Tradition, ist ja ein Zukunftsprojekt gewesen.
Der hat vor allem die Jugend organisiert, die jetzt nicht da ist.
Die Jugend ist nicht da. Das versucht dann ein bisschen die junge AfD oder so etwas. Aber die Jugend, die sich wirklich organisieren lässt, die ist nicht da. Die Jugend wählt durchaus die AfD. Wir haben jetzt so eine Jugendumfrage aus dem Osten. Unter 18-Jährige sind da befragt worden. Große Mehrheit, über 50 Prozent für die AfD. Aber es ist nicht eine Jugendbewegung. Der Faschismus der Nazis oder von Mussolini war auf etwas ausgerichtet. Hier wird ein Fortschrittsprojekt verfolgt, nur damit dieser Fortschritt stattfinden kann, müssen wir jetzt folgende Ausstoßen ermorden und so weiter. Also Fortschritt meine ich hier nicht im Sinne von etwas Positiven, aber im Sinne von etwas, was auf die Zukunft ausgerichtet war. Und wenn wir uns gerade den italienischen Faschismus ansehen, da haben wir das Manifest von Marinetti und anderen. Wir haben also dort tatsächlich so diese Fantasie, hier mit neuester Technik und all dem kommt jetzt die Moderne auch hinzu.
Genau, nichts von all dem.
Der Faschismus ist da eine moderne Aktion. Man kann das auch bei den Schriften von Ernst Jünger natürlich nachvollziehen. Und das ist jetzt alles nicht der Fall gerade, sondern was sich da ausbreitet, ist genau diese Stimmung und die ist ja interessanterweise dann auch bei den ganz Jungen schon absolut da. Das ist ja wirklich eine Entwicklung, die man so nicht kennt, weil eigentlich wann immer es Jugendbewegungen gab, und die gibt es ja jetzt schon seit über 100 Jahren, war das ja schon auf irgendwas ausgerichtet, nochmal so eine andere Vision herzustellen. Du findest bei Kubitschek manchmal so diese Idee, ja und dann bauen wir das Land wieder auf. Ich denke immer, ja, aber mit wem baust du irgendwas hier auf?
Und für wen vor allem? Also Jugendbewegungen haben ja nie für sich selber gesprochen, sondern sie wurden entweder politisch oder ökonomisch gestaltet. Dann hieß es einfach, die sind jetzt alle Take That Fans. So und wir dachten so, die sahen alle super völlig aus. Die waren ja alle musikalisch orientiert und wie auch immer.
Aber Take That ist ja keine Jugendbewegung, das ist ja so ein Fantum.
Naja, aber du weißt ja, was ich meine, also man hat so einen gewissen Style, Konsumgüter, Musik, also man wird so umnebelt mit einem gewissen Milieu. Das sucht man sich aber nicht selber aus, sondern das wird gestaltet so wie die. Und damit meine ich jetzt so, dass die zweite Hälfte des letzten Jahrhunderts, die erste Hälfte wurde halt politisch gestaltet. Wurde einfach gesagt, du bist ein Landmädel und so weiter, komm hierher. Wir erklären dir, wie es geht. Die unter 10-Jährigen waren die größte Bevölkerungsgruppe und die Parteien haben sich einfach um die gerangelt und gekümmert und dann wurden die halt gestaltet.
Nur ist es doch bei den jungen AfD-lern auch so, dass die so mit Lifestyle arbeiten, dass die gewisse Frisuren tragen, gewisse Shirts tragen.
Ja, aber das macht nicht jeder mit. Also es ist jetzt keine super inklusive Veranstaltung, bei der jetzt jeder Jugendliche denkt, ich bin da dabei, sondern das ist halt eine Organisation mit 3000 Mitgliedern oder so. Also die spielt jetzt nicht flächendeckend eine Rolle.
Die ja auch nur Krawall kennt, also die nur die Negation kennt.
Ja, aber es ist eine Organisation, extreme Gewalt, Gewaltfantasien. Das ganze Internet ist voll irgendwelcher Sachen, wo man noch mal auslebt, wie es wäre, wenn man nicht alleine wäre, sondern neben einem noch mal so eine ganze Jahrgangsstunde, die man da rein organisiert. Nun ist ja so, dieses Jammern, diese Wut, ich habe mir viele Gedanken darüber gemacht, ich habe einen Erklärungsansatz gefunden, der nicht aus meinem Metier stammt, sondern aus deinem. Also ich werde ihn dir vorstellen und dann kannst du Einschätzungen dazu geben. Denn es ist wirklich, es ist, es wird jetzt brenzlig, sag uns mal so. Höcke ist AfD-Chef in Thüringen, Spitzenkandidat und bundesweit bekannt. Jeder kennt Höcke und jeder hat eine Meinung dazu, auch in Thüringen. Wir sagen ja immer, Höcke ist da total beliebt, sonst wäre er nicht dort das Zugpferd des Wahlkampfes, da hat er sich irgendwie verabschiedet, erstmal aus dem Wahlkampf, weil er gesundheitliche Gründe und was auch immer. Aber Höcke kommt auf Zustimmungswerte von 17 Prozent. Wünschen Sie sich Björn Höcke als Ministerpräsident 17 Prozent sagen ja. Bei Ramelow sagen immer noch 50 Prozent ja. So, also 17 Prozent ist wenig. Das Ramelow, der gerade aus dem Amt gejagt wird, immer noch auf 50 bekommt, zeigt uns, wie wenig diese 17 Prozent sind. Also es ist wirklich, es ist katastrophal. So, jetzt haben wir aber dieses Phänomen, die Leute wollen AfD-Politik wählen, aber sie wollen nicht, dass Höcke das Land repräsentiert. Denn sie wissen, die Welt kennt Höcke und mag ihn nicht. Nicht mal mir, wir mögen ihn, sollten wir nicht heute schon mal Angst haben, vor den Texten, die nächste Woche in der New York Times entstehen. So, und jetzt habe ich mir die Wahlergebnisse mal angeschaut. Also, AfD ist 2014 erstmals angetreten, hat in Thüringen 10,6 Prozent, geholt damit 11 Sitze. Diese 11 Sitze waren wirklich entscheidend, denn die Regierung hatte damals 46 Sitze, die Opposition 45. Also, es war ein Sitzunterschied. 2019, anschließende Wahl, AfD kommt auf 23,4 Prozent, 22 Sitze. Die Regierung hat keine Mehrheit mehr, sondern regiert mit sechs Sitzen unter der Schwelle. 42 Sitze für die Regierung, 48 für die Opposition. Wenn die Landtagswahl nun so abläuft, wie wir es jetzt gerade prognostiziert bekommen, dann bekommt die AfD ungefähr das Wahlergebnis der CDU von 2009, mit dem sie solide regiert hat. 31 Prozent. 30 Sitze bedeutet das. Bei einer Aufstellung eines 88 Sitze oder 90 Sitze umfassenden Parlaments, wenn da 30 Sitze an die AfD gehen, ist einfach völlig klar, zuerst hatten wir eine ganz kleine Mehrheit in der Regierung, dann hatten wir schon gar keine Regierungsmehrheit mehr und jetzt haben wir einfach nur noch Chaos. Also Thüringen wird in das komplette Chaos abstürzen. Ich verstehe noch nicht, warum das noch nicht so richtig... Was stellt man sich denn jetzt gerade vor, dass man mal abwartet und dann guckt man sich die Zahlen an und irgendwas wird schon passieren. Das einzige, was ja passieren könnte, wäre, dass gegen die AfD einfach alle anderen eine Regierung bilden und das werden sie nicht tun. Nein, das wird niemand tun. Niemand lässt sich jetzt weiter zum Wirt runter degradieren für den Parasiten-AfD. Und dieses Gejammer, was du jetzt beschrieben hast und diese Wut, die da drin steckt und dass der Typ da unadressierbar auf seiner Wiese sitzt und einfach nur abhätet. Er braucht eine Regierung, an der sich sein Parasit nähert. Und wenn dieser Wirt ausfällt, stirbt damit auch der Parasit. Nur, die sind ja dann nicht weg. Sondern nur das Prinzip Parasit und Wirt funktioniert nicht mehr. Jetzt habe ich mich gefragt, was bedeutet das eigentlich? Also ein bisschen dieses Bild. Der Ford, der die Hosts in Westworld baut, sitzt ja dann auch so da und sagt, ja, es ist eben, wenn wir Roboter bauen, die sich verhalten und aussehen wie Menschen, ununterscheidbar sind, selbst für Mediziner, dann hat der Windhund den Hasen gefangen. Was macht er dann? Dem Hasen hinterher rennen, alles klar. Da rennen einfach 10 nebeneinander und dann guckt man halt, wer am schnellsten ist. Aber den Hasen fangen, was passiert als nächstes? Das ist so die Frage. Also nehmen wir uns mal Theorien, die sich irgendwie mit diesem Begehren des Parasiten, unreflektiert, ungesteuert, einfach nur, da ist ein Wirt, ich fresse ihn auf. Vor der Schwelle, der Wirt ist noch da. Genau, ist alles gut. Aber was passiert danach? So, und ich habe dann mal, klar, es gibt natürlich so Bedürfnistheorien, irgendwie, die dann so auf Verhalten, Erleben abstellen. Selbst in der abstraktesten Theorie überhaupt, die ich jetzt so kenne, also meine liebe sozio-logische Systemtheorie, hat noch symbiotische Mechanismen, kann also alles, was sie beschreibt, immer runterbrechen auf so ein, ja dann doch irgendwie körperliches Bedürfnis. Warum regulieren wir Knappheit in der Wirtschaft mit dem Code Geld und so weiter? Naja, weil Menschen halt Bedürfnisse haben und die Güter knapp, um die zu befriedigen im Bildungssystem, in der Wissenschaft. Wir haben immer so ein Wahrheit, das Erleben, das körperliche Erleben einer Wahrheit, ein Experiment ist gelungen, das Feuer brennt, was auch immer. So, also man findet das eigentlich in allen möglichen Theorien. Wir haben natürlich das Begehren und die Politik und dann so Bücher wie Recht auf Sex, aber ohne Gewalt oder wie auch immer. Also das gibt es natürlich auch und Sigmund Freud und Jacques Lacan. Das unerfüllbare Begehren. Da denke ich jetzt, okay, das ist, ich brauche nicht nur eine Theorie zum Begehren, sondern diese Unerfüllbarkeit, die interessiert mich ja insbesondere. Also habe ich per Plexity auf die Suche geschickt. Anja Kraus hat 1998 an der FU Berlin eine Magisterarbeit über Positionen zwischen Ja und Nein, Möglichkeiten von Protest geschrieben, in der sie vor allem Freud und Lacan das unerfüllbare Begehren als politische Heuristik nutzt. Wir haben es also, wenn man uns diese, kann man jetzt einfach sagen, psychoanalytischen Konzepte mal politisch ausgebeutet. Ja, so ein Bogenschlag, kann man irgendwie sagen. Also wir haben es bei der Protest mit der Äußerung eines Begehrens zu tun, das unabhängig aller Inhalte, deswegen ist diese Arbeit von 1998, die sich auf 100 Jahre alte Texte bezieht, für uns heute immer noch interessant. Jetzt ist es halt AfD und was auch immer sie wollen, ist ja alles inhaltlich austauschbar. Haben wir es mit einer Suche nach Realität und Identität, die sich in diesem begehrvollen Verhalten zeigen. Das ist natürlich besonders deutlich beim politischen Protest, denn der stellt ja auf gesellschaftliche Veränderung, also Einfluss auf Realität ab und man findet halt eine Identität in dieser Rolle. Und auch Gleichgesinnte. Also die Identität wird nochmal durch Beobachtung gespiegelt. Es kommen dann diese ganzen bimetischen Orientierungs- und Dacharmungseffekte noch dazu. Also so ein richtig schöner Begehrensstrudel, in dem man da rein stolpert. Diese Identitätsfindung, das passt dann zu meinem Parasitenwirt-Modell, läuft über die Negation eines anderen. Der andere darf also nicht verloren gehen. Man braucht ihn für die eigene Identität und die eigenen Weltentwürfe, die man so hat. Man kann nur einen gemeinsam geteilten Weltentwurf ausbreiten, solange noch Kamala Harris für die einen oder Donald Trump auf der anderen Seite kämpft. Weil man kämpft vor allem gegen die oder eben gegen die Regierung in Erfurt, in Brüssel, in Berlin, wie auch immer. Dieser Protest als Äußerung des Begehrens richtet sich gegen Fremdbestimmung für Selbstbestimmung. Deswegen ist ja Freud auch vor allem als, ach du bist gerade in Sozialisation, ja dann liest doch mal Freud oder so. Also du findest dich gerade selber, ah ja und dieser Begriff Würde steckt da relativ tief drin. Denn wir haben es nicht nur mit einer Suche nach Selbstbestimmung, sondern noch bevor man es ausformuliert hat, wie man sich selbst bestimmt, formuliert man für sich ein Recht auf Selbstbestimmung. Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie schön kompatibel das alles ist. So und jetzt ist aber dieses Problem, dass Begehren verliert seine Adresse. Und das muss man jetzt so zweigleisig, zweischrittig denken. Es geht jetzt nicht darum, Höcke regiert demnächst Thüringen, sondern noch bevor Höcke einen Regierungsauftrag bekommt, ist Ramelow abgewählt. Also das Begehren findet keine Adresse mehr. Der Protest läuft in eine vakante Amtsrolle, ohne Person gefüllt. Kann man gegen ein leeres Amt genauso wütend sein, wie gegen eine Person, die ein Amt ausfüllt? Naja, nicht. Also wir müssen uns hier Gedanken machen, was mit diesem Protest, mit diesem Begehren passiert.
Ja, wenn ich da gerade einhaken darf, ist tatsächlich die interessante Frage. Es kann natürlich ungeleitet werden und dafür gibt der Faschismus ja vielerlei Beispiele, nämlich man sagt dann, der Feind sitzt offenbar nicht mehr in der Regierung. Das sind ja jetzt die Unseren oder werden sie bald sein. Aber ich sehe den Feind ja noch hier überall. Er sieht arabisch aus. Das heißt, ich finde, man sieht es schon deutlich, dass es mir war nicht, also es gab immer wieder sicherlich irgendwelche Gegenaktionen gegen Christopher Street Days im Osten. Aber in einer Vehemenz, wie das in diesem Jahr stattgefunden hat und auch medial repräsentiert wurde, auch von den Protagonisten dieses rechten Morps. Das ist etwas, wo man sich schon sehr zeigt, okay, also dagegen kann man also auch vorgehen und hat also wieder ein feindliches Subjekt. Das ist da die Verlärmung. Ich kenne natürlich diese psychoanalytische Betrachtungsweise und stimme der auch absolut zu. Und jeder kennt es auch, wenn man etwas begehrt und es bekommt. Also von Lacan gibt es ja diesen Satz, gib mir nicht, was ich begehre. Dann setzt man auch eine gewisse Enttäuschung ein. Oder man weiß auch von Leuten, die Affären hatten und sie irgendwann legitimieren, also sagen so, es ist jetzt meine neue Beziehung. Dann ist es ja plötzlich nicht mehr so interessant, weil das Begehren näherte sich auch daraus, dass man da irgendwie heimlich und so weiter tut.
Das ist so klar hergestellt, man ist ja langweilig.
Ja, und das ist natürlich die Sache, die sich einstellen wird zugleich. Aber da gibt es diese große Gefahr, dass man also, weil man es nicht mehr an die Regierung adressieren kann, plötzlich sagt so, jetzt bist du auf der Straße dran, der nicht so aussieht wie ich.
Genau, und da ist aber die Frage, Ausländer sind ja auch nicht da. Day, es kommen mal Besucher für einen Tag vorbei, die da eine Party machen, auch um ein Zeichen zu setzen im Bautzen und so. Die reißen aber von alleine wieder ab, die muss man nicht davon wirken.
Ich will es nicht ganz so verharmlosen, weil ich doch jetzt von Leuten erfahren habe, die zum Beispiel in Leipzig leben, wenn sie dann mal mit dem Regionalexpress nach Dresden oder so rüber fahren. Da sieht man dann Neonazis im Zug und die verhalten sich entsprechend. Und das ist dann schon gefährlich, weil die sagen, endlich sehe ich da mal jemanden, der nicht so ist wie ich. Und dann fangen sie an.
Genau, was eben bedeutet, dieses Begehren, ist in diesen freutschen Theorien so fundamental und so unauslöschlich, dass sich am Ende die gelernte Wut gegen die Regierung und gegen Ausländer und gegen Homosexuelle bleibt, auch wenn es gar keine Regierung und keine Ausländer und keine Homosexuellen gibt. Und dann wendet sie sich im Zweifel gegen den eigenen Nachbarn. Also der Niklas Fiedler Künstler hier in Frankfurt hat so einen Comic geschrieben, den kennst du auch. Der letzte Nazi. Er hat sich gegen alle durchgesetzt. Endlich regiert er die Welt, aber er ist der Letzte, der übrig geblieben ist. Also da würde ich jetzt in Thüringen mal genau drauf schauen, wer ist denn jetzt auf wen wütend. Ich hab da gestern im Fernsehpodcast auch so diesen Scherz gemacht. Ich brauche für Wut auch nicht viel. Ich stehe an der Kasse und zehn Leute stehen vor mir und ich bin auf alle zehn wütend, einfach weil sie meine Zeit verschwenden. Also man kann es sehr leicht verlagern. Diese Wut kann sich sehr schnell gegen alles Mögliche richten.
Ja, und das meine ich ja mit dieser Sache. Es gibt keine gute Laune. Also wenn du doch mal durch Innenstädte gehst und du jetzt mal nicht sagst, ich treffe mich konkret an einem Ort mit Leuten, die ich schon kenne und habe die Tasche voll Geld, sondern einfach mal so normal Geld. Man geht so durch die Stadt. Man trifft doch nicht mehr auf Menschen einfach so kaum. Also das ist abgeschottet. Also da sind alle die, die von ihrem Obstgarten dann mal weggehen und dann dort mürrisch reinklicken. Das heißt, es gibt ja nicht in irgendeiner Weise so ein gesellschaftliches, positives Erleben, sondern es gibt die anderen als Störfaktor an der Kasse.
Genau, die Thüringer werden sich selbst zu Feinden. Das ist die große Gefahr. Es wird eine ganz große Misstrauenswelle in diesem Land geben. Es werden sich kleine Nachbarschaften, die sich vor 30 Jahren am Stammtisch zusammenrotteten, jetzt gegen jeden irgendwie wenden. Hauptsache, man kann noch mal die Wut ausbreiten, hast du den da gesehen hast und so weiter. Also man braucht dafür nicht zwingend Ausländer. Man braucht dafür nicht zwingend Homosexuelle, die sich offen zu erkennen geben. Man braucht dafür keine Regierung. Diese Wut wird irgendwo neue Objekte suchen, was ja auch wieder bedeutet. Also dieser Begriff Objekt geht da nicht um Subjekte. Man sucht sich neue Objekte des Begehrens. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie Freud das ausgearbeitet hat, aber selbst das sexuelle Begehren objektiviert ja grundsätzlich. Also selbst die ein am nächsten stehende Person kann plötzlich zum Objekt werden, wenn man das Begehren nicht ordentlich ausbalanciert bekommt.
Was zeitweise übrigens gar nicht schlimm ist. Also es darf da nicht eine Dauerobjektifizierung sein, nur dass wir uns gegenseitig auch zu Objekten manchmal machen.
Aber da würden wir halt sagen, es ist im Grunde ein Spiel der Erotik, das zur Freude dient und nicht zum Ausleben von Wut und Hass gegen und dann nehmen wir uns was kommt. Und ich fand es sehr mutig, dass die Anja Kraus dann auch nochmal vom fallischen Prinzip schreibt. Denn das Bild finde ich dann eigentlich amüsant. Thüringer, die die AfD wählen und die AfD schafft es, die Regierung aus dem Amt zu jagen und keine andere Regierung wird sich dort bilden, auch nicht von der AfD selbst, die hat ein Ziel erreicht und rennt trotzdem weiter mit einem Ständer rum. Durchs Land, auf und ab, auf der Suche nach irgendetwas, was man weiter pixen kann. Aber es ist nichts da. Und nun läuft der Text darauf hinaus, dass wir eine notwendige Balance zwischen Begehren und das ist Ausnahmezustand, also dem bewussten Aufstören von Strukturen, die wir haben oder mit Absicht abweichendem Verhalten haben. Das Fremdgehen für Jugendliche, das länger abends weg bleiben als die Eltern erlauben und so weiter. Also diesen Nachkommen, einem Begehren. Dieses Begehren muss contained werden. Es braucht eine Balance zwischen diesen Begehren und den signifikanten Strukturen, also dem regelhaften Leben. Das regelhafte Leben heißt, es gibt eine Regierung und es gibt eine Staatsverwaltung, die sich um dich kümmert. Die AfD ist nur die Protestunternehmerin für deine menschlichen Bedürfnisse, Rassismus und was auch immer. So. Das heißt aber noch nicht, dass sich diese Partei qualifiziert für und sie macht jetzt mal eine Staatsverwaltung und sie spielt jetzt mal Regierung. Das wird sie nämlich nicht können, schon alleine, weil es ihr von außen nicht zugestanden wird. Die Leute unterschätzen immer, der Brexit ist passiert und danach wurde er gelebt und zwar nicht von den Briten. Die haben ihn nur erlitten. Gelebt wurde er von Brüssel. Da kamen Ansprüche aus England, die haben gesagt, ihr habt euch doch für Brexit entschieden. Ciao. Wir reden nicht mit euch. Es war eure Entscheidung. So. Und Thüringen wird genauso international und auch national isoliert. Die Investoren werden nicht kommen. Die Kritik, ihnen gegenüber zu machen, wird besonders schwer. Denn es sind halt unternehmische Entscheidungen. Da greifen wir nicht ein. Das dürfte nicht mal die Gewerkschaft, die die Belegschaft vertritt, eingreifen. So ist es eine Managemententscheidung. Aber auch die anderen Bundesländer. Wie stellt man sich ein Bund-Länder-Treffen vor? Jetzt denkt man so immer, die AfD hat da Einfluss und kann sich da... Nein, also der Hendrik Wüst wird schon Strategien haben, die AfD-Vertreter, die da kommen, sofern Thüringen überhaupt mal irgendwann jemanden schickt, zu isolieren, dass sie in den wichtigen Runden eben nicht eine Rolle spielen. Und man wird da Ausflüge und Ausflüchte finden.
Ich hoffe, dass das sehr stimmt. Wenn ich so sehe, wie die CDU bisweilen drauf ist, dann... Also bei Hendrik Wüst würde ich das jetzt auch so sehen, dass der da wahrscheinlich eine Strategie hätte. Aber bei so manchen bin ich mir dann nicht mehr ganz so sicher.
Kein Ministerpräsident in Deutschland wird, selbst wenn Höcke Ministerpräsident ist, auf einem Foto mit Höcke erscheinen, außer mit entscheidender Geste oder was auch immer. Dass man hinter verschlossenen Türen Sachen regeln muss.
Ja, ja.
Aber dieses Publizistische und Höcke kann eine Paarhunderthunde draus machen.
Ob die jetzt zusammen noch auf einem Foto sind oder nicht, ist mir im Grunde egal. Aber wir haben schon gesehen mit dem Beginn der AfD, dass wir Anfangspolitiker haben, die partout nicht in eine Talkshow gegangen sind, wenn dort AfD-Leute waren, die eher darauf verzichtet haben, dass es so etwas wie ein Duell oder Triel gibt. Beispielsweise Malo Dreyer in Rheinland-Pfalz. Das ist heute schon historisch geworden. Wir gucken uns diese Geschichten an und denken vor wie viele hundert Jahren war das eigentlich. Und daran sieht man, wie sich das verschoben hat. Und wenn wir uns jetzt diese Solingen-Debatte ansehen, wenn wir diese Radikalisierung uns bei den bürgerlichen Journalisten ansehen, die sich jetzt jeden Tag mit noch einem weiteren Tweet überbieten, wie könnte man noch aggressiver gegen Migration vorgehen, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man sich zwar nicht mit Höcke sehen lässt, dass man aber so langsam dann so etwas hat, wie wir das jetzt von außen schon betrachtet auf Frankreich sehen, in der deutschen Presse. Ja, Postfaschistin oder so, aber was man ihr zugute halten muss, ist Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Und so etwas halte ich für durchaus möglich.
Ja, mal sehen. Also ich gehe erst mal davon aus, dass wir das nächste Jahr keine thürinische Regierung sehen. Es war ja beim letzten Mal schon Krampf und wir haben ja besprochen, nicht drei Tage vorher eine Prognose, damit der Podcast aktuell bleibt. Wir wissen noch, wie das beim letzten Mal war. Wir haben es ja hier besprochen im Februar 2020. Die sind ja heilfroh gewesen, dass sie drei Tage vor Corona ihren Ministerpräsidenten debakel mit hier und da und so noch mal hingekriegt haben. Also, dass sie überhaupt eine Landesregierung haben ist... Also, man sagt immer, die AfD soll sich nicht entzaubern. Ich finde, Ramelou hat schon ein kleines Zauberstück dahingelegt, dass sie überhaupt zu so einer Minderheitenregierung kam. So, das wird jetzt auf gar keinen Fall gelingen. Also, dafür sind die Kräfteverhältnisse einfach völlig durch den Wind.
Also, ich gebe die Recht, es wird schwierig werden.
Genau. Bedeutet aber, für Thüringen gilt jetzt erst mal, es wird ein unregierbares Land. Also, die Staatsverwaltung wird noch... Ja, wir haben ja Gesetze, an die wir uns halten, aber so Impulse und so weiter wird es nicht geben. Also, es wird keine Regierung geben. Was bedeutet, dass alle anderen Bundesländer ein besonderes Interesse haben, dass das auch sichtbar ist? Also, Thüringen wird jetzt richtig herausgestellt, so wie Großbritannien nach dem Brexit. Man wird diesen jungen Brunnen, die letzten, die wirklich nicht wollen, von Höcke regiert zu werden, oder nur das droht, Höcke kriegt dann einen Regierungsauftrag, die werden das Land verlassen. Ich meine, 2004 bin ich aus Thüringen weggezogen, schon damals galt für ein Abiturjahrgang, alle gehen. Also einfach alle, das finde ich immer wieder erstaunlich, dass sich das so Westdeutsche, in Westdeutschland kommt man immer noch nach Hause und findet dort vor, was man verlassen hat. Das ist für Thüringer und für Sachsen nicht so. Man geht und man ist weg. Und wenn man sich wiedersehen will, müssen alle vorher in einer Dudelliste einen gemeinsamen Termin gefunden haben, damit es klappt und dann müssen alle anreisen. Da ist nicht einfach jemand vor Ort, zu dem man mal wieder hinfährt oder so, weil man ja mit dem die Kindheit verbracht hat. Auswanderung ist der Normalfall und das wird noch mal intensiviert. Also der letzte Jungbrunnen. Und es bedeutet aber vor allem für den Journalismus. Bei der Frage, wie man das jetzt beobachtet. Das, was wir in Thüringen sehen, also der Parasit hat sein Wirt aufgezehrt und weiß jetzt nicht weiter. Jetzt können wir sagen, ok, da ist eine echte Markierung, also bei 51% ist nun mal der Parasit größer als die Regierung, die man aus dem Amt gejagt hat. Damit ist der Parasit die neue Regierung, aber der hat eigentlich nur Opposition. Er kann gar nicht regeln. So, für uns ist das eine klare Markierung. Am 1. September findet das statt. Aber inhaltlich ist es ein gradueller Weg zu diesem Punkt gewesen. Es beginnt bei Menschen fühlen sich gestresst und hassen denjenigen, der ihnen vor ihnen den Parkplatz klaut. Unabhängig davon, wer das ist, dieses Begehren musste irgendwo hin. Leute haben das aufgegriffen. Die FDP sagt, Autofahren für alle. Wer dagegen ist, den hassen wir und so weiter. Es werden überall diese kleinen Protestchen, diese kleinen Begehrensnadelspitze gesetzt, in der Hoffnung, dass es sich publizistisch oder politisch auszahlt. Kommt auf meine Seite, lest alle NZZ. Wir hassen hier besonders gut die Menschen. Kommt alles, lest die Bild. Wir hassen die Menschen noch besser. Die FAZ und der Spiegel können sich dann auch nicht irgendwann man davon frei machen. Das wird immer darin münden, also immer in Thüringen münden. Man muss diese Balance aus Begehren und signifikanter Struktur vorher formulieren und finden. Deswegen noch mal, es gibt rassistische Belange. Man muss sich um Menschen mit rassistischen Belangen kümmern, weil sie ja noch andere Belange haben, aber die müssen klar markiert werden. Und bei den rassistischen Belangen brauchen wir einen Umgang. Ich will auch betreut werden. Ich möchte nicht der Einzige sein, der die Menschen vor sich an der Kasse hasst, sondern von mir kann da durchaus einen Comedy-Programm schreiben. Aber mit dem Comedy-Programm und kein Wahlprogramm. So in diese Richtung.
Das Problem ist ja, wenn du von diesem Alltags-Hasst, den man manchmal denkt, warum fährt der nicht, wenn man dann plötzlich zum Beispiel eine Rassifizierung vornimmt und sagt, warum sind denn hier so viele Ausländer in der Schlange an der Kasse? Sonst wäre ich ja viel schneller draußen. Der Ausländer ist ein Bäcker. Das ist ja das, was die ganze Zeit stattfindet und was auch jetzt medial wirklich von allen Seiten, muss man leider sagen, produziert wird. Also auch die links-liberalen Medien gehen ja jetzt da immer weiter voran. Und ich habe noch mal darüber nachgedacht, im Zuge dessen, dass dieser Mann da einsam sitzt und unter einem Obstbaum abhated. Und aber auch noch mal, um den Bezug herzustellen, zu Eke Heidenreich, die sagt dieses Gejam... Das ist ja alles furchtbar und dann habe ich gedacht, wo hat man eigentlich so ein Gejammer nicht? Naja, wenn man als Tourist unterwegs ist, also wenn man an einem touristischen Ort ist, ich meine jetzt nicht Over Tourism, sondern an den normalen Orten, den viele Touristen sind, aber man hat sich darauf eingestellt, da begegnet man ja ganz vielen Leuten und fast alle Leute, die zurückkommen, sagen auch, ja wir haben da welche kennengelernt, die kamen da und daher. Und da muss man sich mal fragen, hat man eigentlich in seinem eigenen Umfeld kürzlich solche Kommunikationen geführt? Hat man Leute kennengelernt? Nee, eher nicht. Und man fragt sich ja, ab wann ist man dann Tourist? Ich war jetzt kürzlich in Hamburg und da bin ich ja eigentlich Tourist. Also ich bin zwar Deutscher, dann immer noch auf deutschem Platze, aber ich bin dann Tourist. So, jetzt war Folgendes. Ich war eigentlich verabredet mit einem guten Freund, der aber krank war, sodass ich den Abend plötzlich dort alleine verbringen musste. Also ging ich dort in der Nähe der Roten Flora einfach so rum und sagte, ich gehe jetzt an eine Bar. Ich hatte dann den großen Vorteil, dass da zwei Leute waren, die Podcast-Hörer waren und mit denen habe ich mich dann den Abend über unterhalten. Aber die Sache ist, natürlich ist so ein Ort generell, wo so viele Leute sind, wo so viel unterwegs ist, etwas, wo ich möglicherweise mit Fremden ins Gespräch kommen kann. Aber es ist gar nicht so einfach. In den eigenen Bereichen, in denen man sich auf der eigenen Stadt oder so, ist es noch mal schwieriger, eigentlich noch mal neue Leute zu kennen, weil vieles so abgekapselt da ist. Also es gibt da keine touristischen Punkte, wo sowieso alle von irgendwo kommen.
Und man jetzt mit dem Rentenantritt nochmal umziehen.
Ja, wo man eine gute Zeit verbringen kann. Und eigentlich muss man, und das ist jetzt so eine, weil jetzt wahrscheinlich viele redet doch mal was Ökonomisches, gibt doch mal eine genau politische Antwort. Aber nein, ich will jetzt wirklich eine Gemütsantwort geben. Eigentlich muss der Gemütszustand Tourist sein, viel mehr in uns implementiert werden. Dass wir sagen, wir gehen jetzt als Touristen gleich durch Frankfurt und verhalten uns auch so und versuchen, andere Touristen kennenzulernen. Denn wenn wir auf die Stufe kommen, uns als Touristen wahrzunehmen, sind wir schon aus dieser Logik, wir und die anderen draußen, weil wir dann immer alle die anderen sind.
Ja, in Thüringen, also hier in Frankfurt fühle ich mich eigentlich immer als Tourist. Denn wenn hier eine Million Leute auf dem Muff, auf dem Museumsuferfest rumlaufen, dann ist das nicht mein Fest gewesen, sondern das ist völlig klar. Die anderen sind hier die Mehrheit und ich bin ja auch ein anderer. Denn so habe ich den Küstenstreifen uns ja auch noch nicht gesehen. Also man wird so rausgehoben aus seinem... Das ist eigentlich sehr gut. Der Gemützustand sollte jetzt Tourist sein. Und zwar nicht Tourist im Sinne von heute schon wieder keine Liege bekommen, heute schon wieder nicht den ganzen Tag oben liegen, sondern nein, wir sind irgendwo und... Ja, Tourist sein. Man kann doch mal in diese Kirche reingehen, über die man 30 Jahre vorbeigelaufen ist, sich das mal anschauen. Was sehen eigentlich Leute, wenn sie hier so vorbeikommen?
Oder in die Moschee.
Oder mal in eine andere Bar. Wo ich das nicht so empfehle. Wir sind natürlich da Stammgäste, wollen es bleiben. Bei uns läuft das schon unter Compliance, Therapietreue in unsere Bar zu gehen. Was machen wir, wenn wir Menschen nicht mögen? Also abseits von AfD wählen. Wir ghosten sie, wir ignorieren sie, setzen uns zu Hause hin, lesen ein Buch. Das Buch ist ein unsoziales Medium. Wir haben ja besprochen, dass man es auch gemeinsam in Stille lesen kann. Das macht es ein bisschen sozialer. Aber eigentlich ist der Rückzug aus der Sozialität schon ziemlich gang und gäbe, würde ich sagen. Leute gucken lieber auf ihr Smartphone. Wo geht der Weg nochmal lang? Ich frag mal Google, bevor ich hier jemanden ansprechen muss oder so.
Lass mich das gerade nur einwerfen, weil es mich so ungeheuer geärgert hat. Ich war in der Kölner Philharmonie und dort gibt es jetzt eine Konzertreihe, in der wird nur ein Werk gespielt, also ohne Pause. Das war eine Pruckner-Symphonie und der Intendant kam auf die Bühne und sagte, es ist auch etwas Neues hier. Es gibt kein gedrucktes Programmheft in dieser Reihe. Und wir sammeln sie ja gern.
Ja, ich sehe die hier.
Noch schlimmer war aber dann, dass der Intendant sagt, und deswegen dürfen sie im Konzert auch das Smartphone rausholen, da das Programmheft digital vorliegt. Und dann können sie das da lesen, was natürlich zur Folge hat, dass Leute während des Konzerts es abgedunkelt mit dem Smartphone rumhantieren. Und dann wird jetzt dieser, einen der letzten Orte, an denen ich mich wohlfühle, auch noch zerstört.
Ja, also das geht tatsächlich gar nicht. Ja. Denn wir wollen es ja jetzt wirklich bewusst raushalten, schon allein, weil wir abseits des rigorosen Nein gar keine Strategien haben. Also es gibt ja einen richtigen Umgang mit einem digitalen Programm, während eine Veranstaltung läuft. Das ist ja absurd. Okay, also wir kümmern uns jetzt um ein Metier, von dem ich sage, ja, der ökonomische Druck der Ausbeutung eines Willens, den viele Menschen haben. Sie mögen eigentlich keine anderen Menschen und immer, wenn sie eine Frage haben, hoffen sie eigentlich auf eine Antwort, bei der sie nicht abhängig sind von anderen Menschen, die ihnen diese Frage beantwortet, den Service erfüllt oder was auch immer. Wir haben natürlich gute Umwege gefunden, in denen wir einfach sagen, wir bezahlen einfach Geld. Da muss man nicht reden, also du zahlst einfach 50 Euro und dann fährt dich jemand irgendwo hin oder schneidet die Haare und du musst kein Wort sagen. Aber das zeigt ja nur, okay, es gibt auch dieses Begehren, Selbstgenügsamkeit mit sich anzusehen zu sein und trotzdem angebunden an die Welt. So was besprechen wir jetzt und zwar am Thema KI und Emotionen. Und bei KI, wir haben schon häufiger darüber gesprochen, künstliche Intelligenz. Wir haben dann schon gesagt, elektrische Intelligenz, um das ein bisschen abzuheben und trotzdem das konstruktive generative Moment da drin zu sehen. Wir kennen alle von Harari, der sagt, bisher hat der Mensch nur Werkzeuge geschaffen, jetzt hat er Agenten geschaffen. Also sie kommen durchaus ein bisschen auf Augenhöhe. Mir geht es aber nochmal um den Griff Emotionen. Wir machen uns jetzt alle mal kurz frei davon, was wir glauben, was Emotionen sind. Damit meine ich vor allem alle romantischen Vorstellungen von, also Emotionen spielen dann eine Rolle, wenn ich mich verliebe oder wenn ich meine Tochter anschaue oder was auch immer. Darum geht es nicht. Sondern wir brauchen einen instrumentellen Zugang zum Begriff Emotionen. Peter Fuchs hat einen sehr guten Text geschrieben damals mit dem Titel Wer hat und wer hat wozu und weshalb überhaupt Emotionen? So Emotionen passieren irgendwo so in der Kommunikation und sie haben eine spezifische Funktion, nämlich dass wir über den Informationsgehalt eines Sprechakts wissen, wie er gemeint ist. Also nicht nur durch Zuruf, ah ja du meinst mich, ok, sondern auch wie werde ich denn gemeint. Denn klar, man kann jetzt und dafür haben wir dann die Juristerei, alles ausformulieren. Dann hat man es aber immer mit 40 Seiten AGB zu tun, bevor man nur irgendetwas macht, wie sich mal ein Lied anhören oder so. Das geht ja nicht. Wir wollen ja einfach ein Lied anhören. So, also hören wir mal, was das Silicon Valley hier macht, um ein, wie ich finde, echtes Problem zu lösen. Also dieses Problem, was hier gelöst werden soll, gibt es wirklich. Die Potenziale, wenn es gelingt, was hier versucht wird, sind riesig. Und wir hören mal Mark Zuckerberg, der im Dwaakash Patel, so heißt derjenige Podcast, zu Gast ist, um dort über die Modalität für KI-Anwendung zu sprechen, die ihn gerade am meisten interessiert. Und er glaubt, er sei der Einzige, der sich dafür interessiert.
Eine Modalität, auf der ich ziemlich konzentriert bin, wie viele andere Menschen in der Industrie sich auf das konzentrieren, ist eine Art emotionaler Verständnis. So viel von dem menschlichen Geist ist nur für das Verständnis von Menschen und für das Verständnis deiner Erkenntnisse und Emotionen. Ich denke, das ist seine eigene Modalität. Man könnte sagen, dass es vielleicht nur Video oder Image ist, aber es ist auch eine sehr spezialisierte Version.
So, Reasoning und Memory. Reasoning, Sinn raus, also eine Sinnstruktur entwickeln, die Sinn ergibt. Das steckt an dem Begriff drin. Sich so weit wie möglich vom Zufall und von der Beliebigkeit zu entfernen. Ich schreibe morgen eine Mathearbeit. Ich möchte gern wissen, was ich wissen muss. Bitte sag es mir. Auf kürzesten Wegen. Belästige mich nicht mit Sachen, die morgen nicht prüfungsrelevant sind. Memory wäre ganz gut, wenn ich dir nicht jedes Mal dazu sagen muss, ich bin Stefan, ein Schüler, ich schreibe morgen eine Mathearbeit. Es wäre schon cool, wenn du das einfach mal alles weißt, weil du ja mein Kumpel bist. Daraus Verständnis abzuleiern, bei der die Bandbreite im Moment des Kommunizierens möglichst kurz ist, bringe ich den Müll runter. Bringen den Müll runter, kann das alles Mögliche bedeuten. Bringe einfach mal den Müll runter. Ich habe es ja die ganze Zeit lang gemacht, jetzt bist du mal dran. Oder bringe den Müll runter im Sinne von hau mal kurz ab. Was auch immer, das steckt alles. Also wir verstehen so ein bisschen, wir lesen das alles daraus. Wir können uns nie ganz sicher sein. Man kann es nochmal rückkoppeln oder wie auch immer. Also diese indirekte Kommunikation, die latente Sinnstruktur, spielt immer eine maßgebliche Rolle. Es geht nicht nur um den inhaltlichen, den Informationsteil, sondern die Art der Mitteilung. Also überhaupt schon mal eine Mitteilung. Jemand ist gemeint. Das ist nicht einfach nur ein Plakat, das hängt für alle Welt, sondern du bist wirklich gemeint und du bist so und so gemeint. Das spielt hier eine große Rolle und er hilft es erformen. Und jetzt gibt es Hume AI, ein Unternehmen, das sich nur darauf konzentriert. Jenseits des, bei GBT schreibe ich Worte rein und dann kommt, das wird prompt interpretiert und dann kommt was zurück. Abseits dieser Worte, was steht zwischen den Zeilen, was ist eigentlich gemeint und so. Darauf fokussieren die sich. Und die haben einen Chefin, Alan Cohen, der bei Alex K. Dingsterbums im Big Technology Podcast, ich habe ihn schon häufiger betont, den muss man wirklich hören, der ist sehr gut. Die reagieren mal auf diesen O-Ton von Mark Zuckerberg.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, was in seinem Kopf ist, aber es ist definitiv das richtige Problem. Ich denke, das Grund ist das richtige Problem, dass wenn du Leute mit AI umsetzen willst, und wenn du einfach ihre Requests treffen willst, ist das Wichtigste Emotional Intelligenz. Es ist die Möglichkeit, Leute in die Behandlung zu nehmen und deine Antwort zu geben.
Ja, Preferences, Vorlieben, Vorstellung, eines anderen in den Behandlung zu nehmen. Im extremsten Fall ist das die Liebe. Also Luhmann hat relativ früh dieses Buch über Liebe geschrieben, so wie bei Peter Fuchs, wenn er über Emotionen schreibt, nichts über Gefühle und Menschen haben Intentionen und so weiter. Sondern da geht es um geteilte Weltentwürfe. Man versteht sich nicht nur, weil man das Gesprochene irgendwie, keine Ahnung, gut findet, gut tiert, sondern weil aller Weltentwurf, der darüber hinaus mitgeliefert wird oder vermutet wird, geteilt wird.
Und man versteht sich ohne Worte dann auch oder ganz wenigen Worten.
Man liest die Wünsche aus den Augen ab. Man interessiert sich für die Träume des anderen und solche Sachen. Also alles, was wir jetzt so unter Romantik. Nur wenn es in der Kommunikation stattfindet, findet es statt. Und es muss aber in der Kommunikation stattfinden. Und wenn wir einem Psychologen sagen, liest doch das Transkript, er versteht nichts. Also im Transkript steht das nicht drin. Kleiner Exkurs, der Devakish Patel, den wir gerade in seinem Podcast gehört haben, wie er Max Zuckerberg zu Gast hatte, war dann selber im Big Technology Podcast zu Gast. Und die haben mal über nicht nur Menschen, haben damit Probleme Menschen zu verstehen, sondern es geht ja auch darum, wie finden wir eigentlich diesen neuen Kumpel, den wir so haben, kloten? Oh, GPT, ja. Wie schätzen wir eigentlich das ein, was wir da bisher so bekommen haben? Und auch da spielen natürlich die, ja, wie finden wir es denn? Wie fühlen wir uns denn dabei? Schon eine überbordende Rolle.
Ich bin eher ehrgeizig, zu sehen, wie es sich fühlt, zu einer dieser Dinge zu reden, als zu lernen, was das MMLU-Sport ist.
Ja, ich agree. Ich meine, es ist interessant, wie FIELD so eine große Rolle spielt, in den Evaluierungen dieser Modelle, weil sie sind, du sprichst darüber viel, wissenschaftlich, richtig? Und wir können sie irgendwie wissenschaftlich testen und wir haben diese großen Dinge, wie Parameter und, du weißt, die Größe des Computers, den wir benutzen. Aber letztendlich ist Feel eine der tollsten Dinge, die wir nutzen, um zu testen, wie gut diese Modelle sind. Und im Endeffekt ist das, was die Leute immer in Bezug auf Modellverfahren schauen, diese Chatbot-Arena, wo sie zwei Antworten von verschiedenen Chatbots von Seite zu Seite stellen und sagen, ok, welches ist das Beste? Und das ist irgendwie, es sieht jankig aus, aber es ist auch das, was die Leute jetzt fast in der AI-Industrie im Gospelspiel sehen.
Die Menschen bewerten nur ganz selten. Nach prüfungsrelevanten Kriterien, nämlich in Prüfungssituationen. Welche Antworten vielen? Okay, Strich drunter, Sie sind durchgefallen durch Ihre Fahrprüfung oder sowas, ne? Bei allen anderen machen wir Performance-Analyse. Wir stehen uns halt so gegenüber und denken, so, das war ein toller Smarttalk, war ein guter Kinobesuch, war ein toller Urlaub, was auch immer. Wenn man dann Ausbuch stabilieren muss, woran es denn lag, oder zurückgelassene Fragen, was muss ich denn tun, damit du mich wieder liebst, ist nicht so. Also, es ist einfach, man hat halt so ein Gefühl, dem folgt man. Model Performance.
Man geht eigentlich in einer Krise auf eine Metaebene. Oder vielleicht, wenn man eine nächste Stufe erreichen will. Man muss eine nächste Stufe erreichen, zum Beispiel, sollen wir zusammenziehen? Das ergibt sich nicht einfach aus der Lameng, sondern das muss man schon mal auf einer Metaebene diskutieren und sagen, welche Vor- und Nachteile hat es. Aber dann geht man wieder zurück in das Alltägliche. Da muss man das nicht machen. Genauso ist es bei einem Smalltalk. Man wäre vollkommen irritiert, wenn jemand nur in Sentenzen und Formeln mit jemandem sprechen würde.
Genau. Jetzt hören wir mal beispielhaft, mit was es diese Maschinen zu tun haben. Es ist wirklich ein bisschen absurd.
Hast du ein Beispiel davon, dieser KI, die aus dem Film Hör ist?
Da hören wir gleich. Es ist ja immer noch unveröffentlicht. Das wurde ja schon vorgestellt.
Aber man hat ja die Stimme mal gehört.
Genau. Man kann es selbst noch nicht nutzen. Aber es gibt diese Aufnahmen, die wir nachher im Hardfork Podcast auch hören. Hier hören wir erst mal Menschen reden jetzt. Und zwar Svea Eckhardt und Barbara Hammer. Die waren bei der Republika und haben versucht, die Performance von Large-Language-Models vor Publikum einzuschätzen. Sie reden also mit der Maschine. Und ich spiele das jetzt nur so ein bisschen aus Jux und Tollerei. Denn diese Leute meinen das ernst und wir wissen aber, das ist am Ende auch wirklich die Herausforderung, den sich diese Unternehmen stellen. Also wenn Mark Zuckerberg sagt, ich möchte gern zwischen den Zeilen in der Modalität Emotionen verstehen, was ein User will, auch wenn ich es aus dem Text alleine nicht herausrate, dann hat man es mit diesen Testfällen hier zu tun.
Hallo Ceci Bitti, ich habe eine Frage an dich. Hörst du zu?
Es sieht so aus, als ob du viele B's geschickt hast. Gibt es etwas Spezielles, das du damit sagen möchtest? Oder eine Frage, die ich beantworten kann?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage. Die Frage ist nämlich folgende. Ich habe folgende Surferheit. Rababa, Barbera, Bar, Bier, Barbaren, Bar, Bar, Bier. Und wer rasiert da wen und wem gehört die Bar, bitte?
Wenn Ceci Bitti jetzt hier eine sinnvolle Antwort gibt, kann man schon mal sagen, oh, also die verstehen das besser als der Mensch. Weil kein Mensch hört das hier und denkt, das ist eine völlig legitime Frage. Jetzt können wir mal testen, ob Ceci Bitti hier versteht, um was es hier geht. Also so absurd ist es. Und wenn man sich aber anschaut, wie Menschen mit Technik umgehen, muss man sagen, ja, also wenn wir sagen, es ist ein produktreifes Ding, es ist jetzt wirklich an den Mann zu bringen, dann hat man das mit solchen Grenzfällen getestet. Leute schicken sich immer noch selbst ihre, also E-Mails selbst, um sich an Sachen zu erinnern und so einen Quatsch da. Obwohl es dafür längst Apps gibt, die das auf Zuruf und viel besser machen und so. Diese Leute wollen ja da von sowas weggeloggt werden. Nein, wir verstehen schon, was du machen willst. Du musst jetzt nicht dein E-Mail-Programm öffnen, dir eine E-Mail an dich selber, deine E-Mail-Adresse raussuchen und so. Also Barbara, irgendwas, keine Ahnung. GPT antwortet jetzt mal drauf.
Wäre es hilfreich, wenn du mehr Kontext oder Details geben könntest? Hast du eine bestimmte Idee oder Bedeutung im Kopf, die du mit mir teilen möchtest?
Also ich finde, das ist voll schlecht. Das sagen wir Fehler. Wo ist das Problem? Ich meine, Deutsch ist ja so wahnsinnig zusammengesetzt und da ist noch nicht immer die Bar drin. Also und ein Problem ist natürlich, das ist ein bisschen gemein, weil Bar, Bier ist entweder das Bier in der Bar oder der Bar Bier. Und woher soll GPT wissen, wie man das jetzt zerlegt? Und je länger das wird, desto problematischer ist es.
Also wir stellen an die Maschine Anforderungen, die wir selber nicht mehr genügen. Das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig zu verstehen. Denn das ist natürlich ein sehr albernes Beispiel, aber sie steht einfach da und sagt, bringt so einen Nonsenssatz mit der Bar in der Bar, beim Bar Bier oder irgendwas. Und wundert sich dann, dass die Maschine das nicht versteht.
Das ist ja so eine Challenge, auf die sie sich hier bezieht bei TikTok.
Ja, aber niemand sitzt im Publikum. Also ist das so ein konkreter...
Barbaras, Rhabarbar, Bar, so was ist das? Aber ich glaube, darauf bezog sich das jetzt ja ein bisschen.
Ja, sie wollte glaube ich den Bar Bier in der Bar und das sein GPT versteht, wo das Wort aufhört und wo es endet.
Naja, es ist doch relativ leicht erklärt.
Aber die Rhabarbar Bar gibt es natürlich auch.
Diese Large-Language-Models arbeiten mit Wahrscheinlichkeit. Und wenn man natürlich sehr viele Unwägbarkeiten da reinbringt und keinen Kontext liefert, kann ja die Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht funktionieren. Wenn man jetzt aber LMS schon vorher den ganzen Kontext liefert und sagt, Stefan und Wolfgang gehen, wenn sie in Frankfurt sind, gerne in die Bar und trinken Bier, wenn das Chatchipity weiß, kann Chatchipity auch darauf reagieren. Also in der neuen Form, wenn das dann so abgedeckt ist.
Genau, hätte sie gesagt, es ist ein Zungssprecher. Ich werde ihnen sehr schnell sagen, versuche zu verstehen. Das müsste man experimentell mal herausfinden. Es ist jedenfalls das, was wir jetzt gesehen haben. Eine gute Antwort von Chatchipity wäre auch gewesen, ich habe gehört, dass da noch andere Menschen sind, bist du gerade auf einer Bühne, bist du gerade bei einer Performance. Das könnte man ja jetzt alles schon heraushören. Chatchipity in dem Fall jetzt noch nicht, aber dem nähern die sich an. Also Kontext über, klar, dass ich jetzt so akustische Inputs, die man auswerten könnte, aber solche Sachen.
Denn noch ist es ja so, dass diese Sprachassistenten, die Leute zu Hause haben, zum Beispiel Alexa, sich mal verhören, nicht so recht wissen, was sie eigentlich machen sollen und auch die Kommunikation mit ihnen entsprechend aussieht. Also mein Onkel beispielsweise hat eine Alexa und schreit sie immer an, wie man so einen Hund kommt bei Fuß, so etwa, Alexa aus! Und ja, das ist dann mit den neuen Modellen wahrscheinlich nicht mehr da, weil dann die Ansprache direkt eine andere ist.
Du wirst anders angesprochen und du sprichst anders an. Und du weißt, sie reagiert anders, je nachdem, wie du ansprichst. Also wenn du sie anschreitst, kann sie auch wirklich mal einfach sagen, nö, ich lass mich hier nicht anschreien, wie rumme. Als die Kinder anfingen, sich so zu verhalten, weil sie verstanden haben, das ist nur eine Maschine, mit der kann ich so reden, sind die Eltern aufmerksam geworden. Und es gab so eine kleine Kommentarwelle in den amerikanischen Vötors, ob man jetzt den Kindern einen besseren Umgang mit der Maschine lehren muss, weil sich das ja vielleicht auch auf die Menschen vererbt.
Jaja, richtig.
Und lauter solche Sachen.
Gut, also bislang haben wir ja nur eine wirklich beschränkte Kommunikation mit diesen Agenten.
Es ist sehr frustrierend, sich mit Texte zu beantworten.
Die Frage ist aber dann, was wird denn jetzt hochgestaffelt? Weil bislang, ich konzentriere mich auf meinen Prompt und kriege dann eine entsprechend meiner ursprünglichen Konzentration auf augenhöhe befindliche, qualitative Antwort. Wenn ich beim Prompt schludere, komme ich auch eine schlechte Antwort. Im Alltag kann ich mit meiner Kommunikation schludern und meine Kinder wissen trotzdem, was ich meine. Also ich kann es mit Absicht, selbst in der Verkürzung, liegt ein Mehrwertgewinn in der Information, weil die Verkürzung selbst nochmal eine Dringlichkeit markiert oder was auch immer. Solche Sachen, also da liegt noch unglaublich viel ausbeutbares Verständnispotenzial, das heute noch nicht genutzt wird und trotzdem kriegst du mit diesem ganzen, wir schlüssen dir das ganze Weltwissen auf und so, ja, schon so viel.
Die Frage ist ja dann, wie kommt der Kontext in die Maschine? Also um ein einfaches Beispiel zu geben, wenn wir hier fertig sind, werde ich sagen, jetzt lass uns aber essen gehen und es ist nicht mehr denkbar, dass du fragst, wohin denn, weil wir immer da hingehen. Also diese Information muss ja die KI haben, um zu sagen, klar, gehen die jetzt dahin und sie könnte mich dann warnen, heute ausnahmsweise hat das Restaurant zu.
Ja und deswegen ist dieser Spruch von Mark Zuckerberg am Anfang so wichtig. Reasoning, also Mark Zuckerberg ist sehr stolz darauf, dass er die größte Ansammlung von diesen neuen Nvidia-Chips hat, niemand überflügelt ihn und Memory, ganz wichtig, es wird einfach nicht mehr vergessen. Da man schon immer in dieses Restaurant gegangen ist, geht man wohl auch heute dahin. Information, die davon abweichen will, muss expliziert werden. Also eine klare Beteilung heute woanders oder so. Genau, also Memory, das kann man einfach technisch nachrüsten, Reasoning auch, aber diesen emotionalen Zugriff, verstehen, wie der Input gemeint ist, da muss man jetzt nacharbeiten. Und den ersten Versuch danach zu arbeiten, den haben wir ja von OpenAI bekommen im Vergecast. Vergecast hat man sich im Mai Gedanken gemacht, bevor wir Clips direkt aus dieser Präsentation hören, die im Hardfork Podcast gespielt werden, hier schon mal so kleine neue Gedankengänge von denjenigen, die es dann schon gehört hatten.
Das ist die OpenAI-News. Das große Stück davon ist das Emotionen-Stuff. Sie haben das Ding multimodal gemacht, aber ich denke, das, was die meisten Menschen in dieser Demo anstrengend war, war, dass es mit den Leuten, die die Demo anstrengend waren, mit einer Stimme, die sehr wie Scarlett Johansson klingt.
War es anstrengend? Ich meine, es war definitiv anstrengend, aber war es anstrengend?
Ja, es könnte sein, dass OpenAI einfach den Bogen schon überspannt hat. Also das ist sozusagen in die richtige Richtung, aber vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit. Also das ist gar nicht so, nee, das ist, ich fand es jetzt nicht überzeugend, er hat ihn ja gar nicht verstanden oder was auch immer. Denn wir hören das hier mal, es klingt auf so eine ungewöhnliche Weise artificiell. Und vielleicht auch nur, weil uns OpenAI nochmal zeigen wollte, es ist artificiell. Also wir nähern uns aus. Ich denke, wir sind in einer sehr falschen Richtung, sozusagen dem Natürlichen, was wir gewohnt sind, an. Wir markieren uns ein letztes Mal. Es ist eine Maschine, denn wir hören sie reden, wie normale Menschen eigentlich nicht reden, um sozusagen die Akzeptanz danach leichter, also nicht von unten annähern, sondern dieses, wie nennt man das im Film, wenn die Menschen zu realistisch sind, also dieses Uncanny Valley. Wir überspringen es erstmal und kommen dann von der anderen Seite zurück. Denn beim Hardfork Podcast, also ich finde es auch skurril, wie es dann klingt.
Rocky, was für ein Interview?
Es ist für einen Software-Engineering-Roll. Aber ich muss wissen, ob ich präsent und professionell aussehen kann?
Rocky, du hast definitiv den Ich-been-teile-alle-Nacht-Lookdown, welchen in deinem Gefecht funktionieren könnte.
Vielleicht einfach mit einer Hand durch dein Haar oder in den Schmerz von Genie-Feind.
Dein Enthusiasme ist das, was wirklich durchscheiden wird.
Ich habe nicht viel Zeit.
Die für zum Beispiel das Fernsehen nicht ungewöhnlich ist. Also so zu sprechen in einer Fernsehsituation, wo man ein bisschen größere Geste machen muss, in einer Bühnensituation, ist absolut richtig. Das heißt, hier das noch ein bisschen runtergedimmt, dann sind wir doch hier bei etwas ganz Interessantem angekommen. Nämlich, diese KI flirtet ja mit Rocky, der sagt, ich habe da ein Vorstellungsgespräch, kann ich eigentlich so gehen, was soll ich hier anziehen? Und diese Art des Sprechens, die wir jetzt da hören, ist ja eine, die völlig verpönt ist. Etwas, was wir am Arbeitsplatz nicht mehr wollen. Wir haben diese ganzen Debatten darum gehabt und ich weiß ja auch, um die Problematik von übergriffigen Reden und so weiter. Aber, dass jetzt genau so etwas kreiert wird, zeigt mir ja, und eigentlich ist der Erfolg von KI ja immer auch auf einen Mangel begründet, zeigt ja, dass es so eine Sehnsucht danach gibt. Eigentlich so ein bisschen angeflirtet zu werden, das ist aber im Betrieb wirklich unüblich geworden und auch sonst, aber da könnte das für mich die KI dann noch ermöglichen. Und das finde ich doch sehr interessant. Eigentlich spricht sie ja mit ihrem Rocky so, wie das in einem alten James Bond Film ist. Da ist Moneypenny oder da ist ein Bond-Girl und die sagt ja Mr. Bond. Also dieser Anzug steht ihnen aber besonders gut. In dieser Art wird ja mit ihm gesprochen. Das ist eine Sprechweise, die nicht mehr so gewollt ist, aus verschiedenen Gründen. Und sie ist aber doch noch als Wunsch da und diesen Wunsch, den erfüllt die KI.
Genau.
In dem Maße, wie wir darüber sprechen, sieht man aber auch, wir sind schon ganz schön beeindruckt oder es beschäftigt uns, wie sie klingt. Wenn wir das jetzt aber transkribieren, vielleicht sollten wir es einfach nochmal hören, diesen Teil. Wir hören auch mal, wie kurz die einzelnen Wortbeiträge sind und wie viel Verständnis aber, also wie gut die Anschlüsse passen. Man hätte ja auch sagen können, ja ich habe heute einen Vorstellungsgespräch bei Oben.AI. Ja, dann erziehe ich dir nochmal die Rahmendaten des Unternehmens, damit du dem Chef beeindrucken kannst, dass du Bescheid weißt, dass die auch noch immer gegründet wurden oder so. Nein, sondern es wird, und das ist eben diese Frage, noch ist es nicht veröffentlicht. Also noch können wir es alle nicht testen. Wir sehen nur dieses, aber für die Gestaltung dieses Dialogs ist es erstaunlich viel Verständnis bei einer erstaunlich geringen Bandbreite an Informationen, die überhaupt vor allem von ihm aus transportiert wird.
How about you?
Listen, I got some huge news. Well, in a few minutes I'm gonna be interviewing at Oben.AI.
Have you heard of them?
Oben.AI?
Sounds vaguely familiar. That's incredible, Rocky.
What kind of interview?
So, also, ich hab ein Interview bei Oben.AI. Und sie weiß genau, das ist nur eine Gesprächseröffnung. Das ist erstmal nur die Anlassgebung. Ich mach jetzt nur einen kurzen, ah ja, kenn ich, ich mach ein Scherz. Und dann bin ich aber zu Ende, weil dann kommt der nächste Prom. Und nicht, ah ja, Oben.AI, ich bete dir jetzt in ein WGP-Affiliate-Proposal.
So wie das jetzt noch bei ChatchaBT ist, wenn du jetzt OpenAI, dann wird erstmal 20 Zeilen produziert, was OpenAI ist.
Genau, da wird es mal fabuliert und hier und da und so. Und hier findet alles nicht statt. So, well, Rocky, darin steckt schon ganz schön viel Information. Also sie ist nicht ganz zufrieden, er soll sich schon mal drauf vorbereiten. Also was für uns so selbstverständlich ist, dass man sich bitte kurz hält, niemandem die Zeit verschwendet und so weiter, ist für eine Maschine extrem herausfordernd. Wir nähern uns jetzt aus, deine Suche hat 29 Millionen Suchergebnisse, wähle bitte selber aus auf, ja, wir machen dir schon mal einen kleinen Kasten per Plexity, versuch dir das so in drei absetzen. Und jetzt einfach nur noch kurzer Zugeruf, wolltest du mehr wissen? Wir hoffen nicht, denn eigentlich, wir wissen ja, Zeit ist knapp. Und genau das ist, worum es Hume-AI geht und was eben diesen extremen Mehrwert dann auch bringen kann, dieses emotionale Verständnis abseits des innertlichen, also wirklich ganz abseits des innertlichen.
Remarkable is that the model can actually learn what vocal modulation means on its own. You just need to add it in the right way. We have these expression measurement tools that we've trained.
So, man hat jetzt Tools entwickelt, nach denen Kriterien trainiert werden, nachdem also in Mehrstufen dann dieses Verständnis tatsächlich einmal so kartografiert wird. Und da wird sehr viel ausdifferenziert.
That are extremely accurate. They can actually encode 756 dimensions of embedding, of like vocal modulation and 756 dimensions of facial expression per word that you're saying.
Ja, mehrere hundert Dimensionen des innertlichen Verständnisses, wird ergänzt. Plus noch mal, wir sehen ja auch, also wir machen dann auch Mimik, Analyse und so weiter, noch mal hunderte Dimensionen pro Wort.
Was ich mich da gleich frage ist, wir leben im Botox-Zeitalter. Jetzt ist noch genügend natürliches Trainingsmaterial vorhanden. OpenAI kann das Ganze noch schulen oder hier, Jugend kann das noch alles schulen. Aber wie ist es, wenn ich jetzt das stark verwendet hätte, Botox, und dann bekomme ich so eine KI und die muss ja an meinem Gesichtsausdruck dann so langsam lernen, was ich mag, dass sie mir nicht jedes Mal wieder eine Spezie offeriert, wo sie doch weiß, ich trinke Cola. Schon aufgrund meines Gesichtsausdrucks. Wenn ich jetzt aber mit Botox das ziemlich glatt gebügelt habe, geht das nicht mehr.
Dann ist es schwieriger, weil das ja dann nicht mehr, also klar, wenn das Trainingsmaterial auch aus lauter Botox-Leuten besteht, werden die Nuancen noch feiner, auf die man achtet. Aber wenn typischerweise erwartet wird, dass die große Augenbrauen-Geste kommt und du versuchst dann irgendwie und kannst aber nicht, dann fällt dieser einfach aus. Allerdings, das gilt ja auch im zwischenmenschlichen Kontakt.
Ja, natürlich.
Also es gibt Studien darüber, dass diese Menschen ihre Gesprächspartner unzufriedener zurücklassen und sich selbst auch, weil der Körper manchmal Emotionen zuerst auslebt, bevor sie fühlbar und dann auch besprechbar macht. Und wenn das nicht passiert, fehlt die Initialzündung für ein emotionales Erleben. Also es friert sozusagen die Sozialität ein.
Aber imaginieren wir mal ein Überwachungsszenario, dann ist eigentlich Botox ein gutes Hilfsmittel, um sich der Lesbarkeit zu entziehen.
Ja, wenn du im Kino sitzt und du weißt, die Kameras sind auf dich geleitet, um zu gucken, in welche Stellen des Films du besonders gut fandest, dann kann man das da nicht mehr so gut draus ablesen.
Ja.
In der Sicht gute Argumente für Botox. Nein, nur falls man diesen Kampf aufnehmen will. Also er nennt jetzt hier hunderte Dimensionen, die die Technik herausgefunden hat, pro Wort Mimik Tonfall noch dazu. Wo kommt man denn her bei dieser Art von Forschung?
In der Mitte des 20. Jahrhunderts hat Paul Ekman entschieden, dass er die Frage beantworten würde, was es bei der Faschalexpression ist, die nicht universal sein könnte. Und also hat er diese sechs Faschalexpressionen als ein ordentliches Test, mehr oder weniger, von was diese breiten Stereotypen zu anderen Menschen bedeuten könnten. Und er hat sie gewählt, weil sie sehr anders sind. Er hat nur eine positive Expression gewählt.
Um das zu auszubuchstabieren.
Ich denke gerade an unseren Rentner unter dem Obstbaum. Wenn der jetzt jemanden hätte, der so ein bisschen flirty mit ihm spricht, wie dieses Modell, das wir eben gehört haben. Vielleicht ist er dann noch ein bisschen besänftigt. Und nicht nur so hassend.
Es ist auf jeden Fall, man kann, und das ist eben dieser Große, das ist ein echtes Novum. Die Psychologie konnte bisher gar nicht allzu sehr hier in eine Differenzierung reingehen, denn die Standardisierung von emotionalen Ausdrücken sind auch recht begrenzt. Deswegen sind ja Therapien immer hochindividuell. Aber nicht hyperindividuell. Das bekommen wir jetzt aber sowohl in der, mal gucken was hier rauskommt, also auch Alena Birk sagt ja, in der Therapie sind solche KI ganz gut verwendbar. Also der Ethikrat hat ja ausdrücklich gesagt, dafür ist es nicht schlecht, was ich erstaunlich fand, für so ein frühes Stadium. Aber wir haben es ja auch bei der Krebsforschung beschrieben. Die Krebstherapien werden sowieso schon personalisiert, aber jetzt ja auch die Medikamente. Also es wird ja ganz spezifisch auf einen Körper Rücksicht genommen, je nachdem, wie er sich verhält. Und das gab es vorher nicht und das hatten wir in der Psychologie oder in der Art und Weise eben auch nicht. Was bedeutet? Deswegen überschlagen wir ja immer die Zuschreibungen von einem auf den anderen. Ein Syrer hat gemordet, also stehen alle Syrer unter Mordverdacht, genau weil wir das standardisieren und eben nicht nach diesen 600 Kriterien ausbuchstabieren. Dann würden wir das machen, kämen wir ja bei diesem jetzt Tatverdächtigen vielleicht darauf, dass Herkunft Syrien nur 27 von 325 relevanten Dimensionen betrifft und vielleicht gar nicht maßgeblich ist. Also bisher, wir gehen hier in ziemlichen Shortcut mit der bisherigen Psychologie und jetzt durch diese Dauerbeobachtung und es wird extrem viel Trainingsmaterial anfallen. Also wenn die Leute erst mal anfangen, mehr als ihren Timer durch Zuruf zu stellen, sondern dann wirklich in so Dialoge wie hier, was ziehe ich denn heute Abend an, wie verhalte ich mich denn da, gib mir nochmal drei Talking Points oder so. Das ist ja dann wirklich Masse, mit der man arbeiten kann, die steht ja keinem Psychologen zur Verfügung. Also wenn du ein Psychologe bist und du machst Therapien, dann ist der Patient eine Stunde da vor dir und dann siehst du den erst in zwei Wochen wieder und was in diesen 14 Tagen passiert, dazu hast du keinen Zugang. Er muss es dir erzählen. Die Leute besprechen jetzt schon mit Google medizinische Fragestellungen, die sie weder mit ihren Freunden, noch mit ihren Ärzten, noch mit irgendwem besprechen. Also hier hat man jetzt Zugänge zum Aufschlüsseln menschlichen Verhaltens. Das gab es vorher so nicht und deswegen finde ich es auch nicht irgendwie merkwürdig, wenn der jetzt sagt, naja, die Psychologie hat uns sechs Dimensionen gezeigt und wir haben aber jetzt schon mal 735 daraus gesucht. Also das ist ein echtes Novum, das muss man sich genau beobachten. Und da kommt eben auch Verantwortung mit.
Überlegen diesen Personality-Test, den wir hier mal vorgestellt haben. 16 Persönlichkeiten gibt es und einen davon bist du. Nein, da ist die KI schlauer.
Genau, also diese Art von Komplexität, die wir bisher hatten, muss nicht mehr reduziert werden auf Kriterien, die wir in vier Buchstaben abkürzen oder so. Wir können jetzt ganz individuell bleiben. Und da war bei der Republikar Simon Eckhoff zu Gast, der mit Expertise aus der Psychologie und dort aber auch bildgebende Verfahren, was auch immer Einblicke gibt, wie weit Individualisierung gehen kann.
Man kann den Leuten nur vor den Kopf schauen, das haben sie gerade schon gehört. Aber jetzt schauen sie mal nach links und rechts und sie sehen, wir sind alle unterschiedlich voneinander. Wir unterscheiden uns in Geschlecht, Größe, Hautfarbe, Haarfarbe. Und alle diese Eigenschaften können wir sehr schnell bei unseren Mitmenschen erkennen. Natürlich unterscheiden wir uns genauso aber auch in, was ich mal als innere Eigenschaften oder psychische Eigenschaften bezeichnen würde. Also zum Beispiel so Aspekte wie Persönlichkeitsmerkmale, bin ich risikofreudig, bin ich ein sozialer Typ, mag ich Ordnung etc. Und natürlich auch kognitive Fähigkeiten, meine Konzentrationsfähigkeit, mein Gedächtnis etc. Das wird alles deutlich unterschiedlich sein von ihrem oder von ihrem. Der entscheidende Punkt ist aber, während wir Unterschiede in den äußeren Eigenschaften natürlich auf den ersten Blick sehen, können wir wenig, ja gar nichts erst mal direkt erkennen über die inneren Eigenschaften eines Menschen.
Ja, also eine politische Diskussion zum Thema der Syrer ist ein Mörder, die schließt eindeutig an den sichtbaren Merkmalen an. Und jetzt sagt er, neu ist, wir wissen nicht nur, dass die nicht sichtbaren Merkmale viele sind und dass sie in komplexen Beziehungen zueinander stehen, sondern wir können sie jetzt auch verstehen, lesen, herauslesen. Alan Cohen von You Man Eye redet auch darüber, wie viele Dimensionen man plötzlich zur Verfügung hat, um hier Sachen zu machen.
Also es gibt Differenzen zwischen einer Ersatzung von Ehr, der Überraschung, der Angst, der Gefühle, der Interesse. All diese Ersatzungen sind beliebig erkannt. Also haben wir sie ausgemacht.
Das wird jetzt alles mit in Beschlag genommen. Und es ist eben wahnsinnig kompliziert, diese indirekten, latenten, impliziten Kommunikationsaspekte zu betrachten, wenn man jetzt gerade sehr viele neue Forschungsmethoden hat, aber es sozusagen keinen Vorbau gibt. Also es gibt keine bisherige, selbst in der Soziologie. Ich denke mir jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die objektive Hermeneutik vielleicht, mal so ein kleines Ding, wo noch mal jemand das Wort latente Sinnstruktur in den Mund genommen hat. Bisher war das alles verborgen.
Es geht eigentlich über das, wenn du siehst, was im Plenum in den Responsen der Menschen ist, dass es nicht nur verboten ist. Oder was im Plenum in den Gesprächsignalen ist, das nicht explizit verboten ist. Es gibt viele verschiedene Dimensionen, die noch nie verwendet wurden. Du hast diese Dimensionen von Behavioren noch nie verwendet.
Und wir werden demnächst eine Debatte haben. Die Vizepräsidentendebatte. Alle Welt weiß, inhaltlich ist das total egal. Also, die sind nicht Vizepräsidenten. Und trotzdem wird dieses Duell sehr vielsagend sein. Jaja. Und ich würde auch sagen, ja, zu Recht. Man kann das auch ohne Ton schauen. Das wird schon reichen. Selbst in der großen Präsidentendebatte, Trump gegen Kamala Harris, man kann das ohne Ton gucken und man wird wahrscheinlich dieselben Konsequenzen draus ziehen. Aber man darf es halt nicht nur lesen. Wenn man es nur liest, weiß man halt was zu sagen.
Ich habe plötzlich eine Trump-Rede gelesen und zwar ging es da um den Bitcoin und ich wollte die noch mal...
Wurde die original transkribiert?
Die wurde original transkribiert und es ist so interessant, dass die ersten zehn Minuten Trump eigentlich nur so ein großes Hallo ins Publikum und zu Einzelpersonen macht. Es ist überhaupt gar keine Rede, sondern nur sowas, Good Guy, Nice Guy, Say Hello to und es ist auch überhaupt nicht das Anliegen von Trump, Sätze zu formulieren, aus denen ein Argument hervorgeht. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Irgendwann kommt er dann zu einzelnen Statements, aber das sind auch nur, ich will den Bitcoin befreien, um dann gleich zu sagen, wir sind in einem miserablen Zustand, die Mexikaner kommen alle und überrennen uns. Es hat gar nichts miteinander zu tun, wenn man es aber dann ansieht, ich habe die Rede nur gesucht, weil ich keine Lust habe, das selbst zu transkribieren, wenn man es sich ansieht, hat man den Eindruck von einer Ganzheit, von einer Einheit und sobald man es liest, zerfällt alles.
Gilt aber nicht nur für Trump-Reden.
Nein, nein.
Das ist einfach ein grundsätzliches Phänomen, da kann man sich, insbesondere dieses Elke Heidenreich, die hat besonders kurze, flapsige Sätze und so weiter, wenn man das, ja, es ist einfach Kraut und Rösen.
Sie schreibt ja natürlich anders, als die Berichte.
Und das Phänomen, dass du jetzt sagst, wenn man es ganz sieht, dann hat man plötzlich so eine Idee von Ganzheit. Die Chatbots sehen von uns bisher nur diese Worte. Also wir denken immer, die sehen so viel. Aber nein, die sehen ja bisher nur, was wir reinprompten. Also nur den Text der Rede. Und trotzdem verstehen die uns schon so gut. Wenn wir denen jetzt den ganzen Trump mitliefern, ja, da liegt ja nun wirklich Potenzial für unendliche Analysen, wenn dann noch Memory und Reasoning technisch hinterhergebaut wird.
Nur will ich mal zwei Punkte gerade machen. Einmal haben wir hier auch in den Anfangstagen dieses Podcasts hin und wieder darüber diskutiert, wie wir getrackt werden über Google und all das und haben das auch immer wieder mal kritisiert und zugleich aber auch herausgestellt, wie praktisch das eigentlich ist. Wenn Google dann weiß, wir haben gerade in diesem Geschäft eingekauft mit unserer Kreditkarte, also mit unserem Smartphone und dann wird uns das nächste Suchergebnis dahingehend angezeigt. Und da gab es sehr viele Bestrebungen, das mehr zu unterbinden. Und da ging es ja nicht nur um so einen Datenschutz in dem Sinne, das soll alles anonymisiert sein, sondern auch generell soll das nicht stattfinden. Hier diese Technologie ist ja nur unter der Voraussetzung, dass alles inkludiert wird zu sehen. Und da sehen wir, glaube ich, auch schon im öffentlichen Diskurs, dass diese Art der Datenschutzproteste und der Bestrebungen von progressiver politischer Seite, dass es das fast nicht mehr gibt. Das ist so gänzlich abgeräumt. Da sehen wir auch eine Zeitenwende. Hier könnte man diesen Ausdruck wirklich mal sehen. Und dann gibt es ja noch was. Google funktioniert ja so, dass ich da eigentlich diesen Suchschlitz habe und gebe da etwas ein. Jetzt ist es so, dass da auch schon aufgrund meiner Browser-Tätigkeit, das war ja für Google sehr wichtig, einen eigenen Browser zu haben, die sehr viel wissen. Das heißt, wenn ich gewisse Restaurants suche, ahnen die schon, okay, der wird das Restaurant nicht in Paris suchen, sondern eher das, was in Bonn ist. Hier geht es aber ja noch um sehr viel mehr. Also eigentlich muss diese KI dieses Weltwissen haben, um mir auch sagen zu können, was hat Jacques Lacan gesagt in seiner Vorlesung von 1964 und muss aber auch wissen, wenn ich sage, ist das Restaurant eigentlich heute auf, muss es wissen, ganz individuell, dass nur ich gehe, dass ich nur Interesse habe jetzt an diesem einen Restaurant. Und damit sind wir doch auf so zwei Ebenen, also einmal so eine Universalwissensebene und dann so eine radikal-individualisierte Ebene. Und die Frage ist ja jetzt, ist das Einbieter, der das Gesamtpaket anbietet oder gibt es den Anbieter Cheche Biti, der das Gesamtwissen anbietet, 100 Millionen Mal besser als Wikipedia. Und dann gibt es nochmal diese persönliche KI, die so spricht wie, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht in dem Film höher, die dann sich auf mich nochmal persönlich anpasst und dann wird das miteinander connected.
Apple versucht das ja zu trennen. Ich halte das auch für nicht trennbar. Also das wird so viel. Wir hatten es ja schon mal besprochen am Beispiel Google Maps, wo du meintest, nee, es kann ja keinen besseren so, wo ich sagte, naja, genau, also weil es keinen gibt, kann er nicht besser sein. Aber wenn es einen gäbe, man würde den einen ein bisschen beschränken. Also Google hat jetzt dieses Urteil bekommen. Es ist ein Monopol und Yelp, die ja genau diese Fragen klären. Die klagen jetzt dagegen. Also die nehmen jetzt dieses Urteil zum Anlass. Apple versucht jetzt zu sagen, wir machen Apple Intelligence. Also du redest mit dem Handy, im Grunde mit dir selber, denn es sind deine E-Mails, deine Erinnerungen, dein Kalender, deine Nachrichten. Wir wissen also, wir können dir sagen, jemand hat mit dir kommuniziert. Das ist du. Das Interface bist du sozusagen. Und dann gibt es diesen Moment, wo die Apple Intelligence sagt, dafür brauche ich Weltwissen, da weiß ich nicht weiter. Und dann wird explizit jedes Mal gesagt, möchtest du GPT dafür nutzen? Und dann klickst du und dann wird dein Prompt rübergeholt zu GPT auf dem Server, der dann auch brausen kann, also sich aktuelle Informationen holt. So, und ich war auch noch sehr überrascht darüber, dass Apple das ganz explizit macht, weil das wird die Leute nerven. Willst du jetzt zu GPT gehen? Ja, natürlich willst du zu GPT gehen. Ich will immer zu GPT gehen. Wenn du es nicht weißt, dann muss ich mir halt GPT sagen. Also noch machen sie es, auch aus ökonomischen Gründen, aber was die Apple wäre immer sehr für den Nutzer da seien. Eigentlich, vielleicht wollen sie einfach nur noch ein paar Jahre warten, bis sie ihr eigenes GPT soweit haben, dass sie dich dann nicht mal drauf hinweisen müssen.
Sonst erodiert das Apple-Modell, diese geschlossenen Systeme funktionieren dann nicht mehr. Und um das ganz praktisch zu machen, natürlich brauchst du laufend das Weltwissen, denn wenn du dich nur von A nach B bewegen willst, muss Weltwissen dann abgerufen werden, um dir eine Strecke anzuzeigen. Oder man ist an einem gewissen Ort, wo es bestimmte Arten des Verhaltens gibt. Und das muss Chachipiti dann vermitteln, dass man sagt, hier zieht man die Schuhe aus, da lässt man den Hut aus, da ist das und das. Das ist ja etwas, worauf ständig Bezug genommen werden muss. Also es geht ja bei Chachipiti nicht nur darum, ich greife da von Apple aus zu, wenn jemand was zu Heidegger oder Hegel fragt, sondern das ist ja tatsächlich eigentlich präsent. Und wenn wir darüber nachdenken, wie bewegen wir uns auf so einer persönlichen Ebene? Ja, aber wir rufen ja auch die ganze Zeit Weltwissen mit ab.
Genau. Der Standardfall, den Apple da hatte, war ja auch, man kommt meine Mutter an und dann soll Apple Intelligenz automatisch in den Nachrichten rauslesen, deine Mutter ist die, die hat ihr ja gestern die Nachricht geschickt mit der Flugnummer und dann googelt es nach der Flugnummer. Also sucht dann selber und da kommt, also es geht Hand in Hand. Genau. So, jetzt hat ja Amazon, Google, also wenn man da einen Suchbegriff eingeht, bei Amazon weiß ich es, da sagt der Andreas Weigin, der damals die Technik entwickelt hat, da werden 500 Signale ausgewertet. Wo bist du, was hast du bisher gekauft, was kaufen Leute in deiner demografischen Nähe und so weiter. Also das summiert sich dann auf 500, wenn man es über die App auf dem Smartphone benutzt.
Das wollte man mal beschränken. Und jetzt sind wir in einem völlig anderen Diskurs. Also es ist so interessant. Wir haben es selbst noch hier gehabt und haben gesagt, muss das denn sein?
Die Politik ist völlig ausgefallen.
Ja, weil man auch sagen muss, was würde man machen? Jetzt hast du es gelesen, Daniel Eck von Spotify und Zuckerberg zusammen in Die Economist nochmal einen Artikel geschrieben, in dem sie sagen, liebe EU, bitte nicht so streng die KI regulieren. Es ist auch interessant, warum Eck und Zuckerberg es leuchtet einmal, aber dann einen Zuckerberg hätte sehr alleine schreiben können. Aber es ist schon ein ganz guter europäischen Player, mit dabei zu haben, wenn man die EU ermahnen will.
Der globale Aufruf gegen Regulierung. Jedenfalls, es ist schon heute nicht unüblich, dass abseits des Suchbegriffs, den wir eingeben, noch hunderte andere Signale ausgewertet werden, die, sagen wir mal, nonverbale Kommunikation sind. Und jetzt nähern wir uns ja noch dem, was wir sagen, das ist wirklich nonverbale Kommunikation. Der Simon Eickhoff beschreibt hier mal, wie die neue Technologie grundsätzlich heute so ganz langsam die psychologische Diagnostik ersetzt durch Scans.
Und dieses MRT erlaubt es uns dann, Bilder vom Gehirn eines Patienten oder eines Probanden anzufertigen. Hier sehen Sie als ein Beispiel ein anatomisches Bild, das ist so ein Schnitt einmal so ungefähr durch das Gehirn. Aber wir können darüber hinaus auch die Funktion oder die Aktivität des Gehirns messen.
So, kennt man ja soweit, also ein buntes Gehirn zeigt irgendwie, wo wird gerade Zucker verbrannt. Dieses Bild mal bitte im Hinterkopf behalten, auch wenn ich es euch nicht, aber ihr kennt alle, wie es aussieht. Also das Gehirn erkennt man gerade noch so und wenn sie so Farben besprechseln. Es kommt also nicht auf das einzelne Neuron an, sondern das Gesamtgefüge gerade wie diese im Verhältnis zueinander stehen. Und jetzt sagt er hier ja daraus lässt sich ganz schön viel herauslesen.
So eröffnen sich dann langsam, zumindestens stand heute ein Spalt bereit, die Möglichkeiten im Endeffekt beliebige Eigenschaften aus dem Bereich Persönlichkeit, Kognition, Erkrankungsrisiko etc. vorherzusagen. Hier mal ein paar Beispiele. Das fängt an mit etwas recht einfachen, aber für die Kliniker durchaus relevanten, so etwas wie Griffkraft. Nun kann man sagen, ja gut, Griffkraft, auch das kann man einfach messen. Das interessante da, zumindestens für die Ärzte, die Neurologen, ist nicht so sehr die Vorhersage, sondern eben die Abweichung. Also wer ist stärker oder weniger gut, als man es eigentlich erwarten würde. Aber auch sehr komplexe Eigenschaften, die wir nur schwer messen können, die Persönlichkeitszüge, emotionale Labilität zum Beispiel, das lässt sich grundsätzlich vorhersagen. Und sie sehen schon, ich formuliere hier bewusst vorsichtig, denn der Stand, wo wir und der Rest der weltweiten Forschung ist, ist der, dass wir deutlich über Zufälligkeit, deutlich über Rate-Wahrscheinlichkeit vorhersagen treffen können, aber noch deutlich unter der Genauigkeit, die man brauchen würde oder ich sage sogar, die man brauchen wird, um darauf dann Entscheidungen im echten Leben fällen zu können.
So, wir hören jetzt hier einen Wissenschaftler, der ganz vorsichtig damit umgeht, dass man einige Merkmale, wie zum Beispiel auch emotionale Labilität, ich wüsste nicht mal, wie man das objektiviert, standardisiert, operationalisiert, dass man überhaupt sagen kann, ok, du bist jetzt bei emotionaler Labilität, bist du bei 7,3 statt 7,5 oder sowas.
Aber das ist schon Minority Report.
So, genau. Und das geht ja jetzt gerade Hand in Hand mit diesen Silicon Valley Sachen, die dir nicht ins Gehirn schauen, die aber ihre Trainings oder aus dem Training herausgelesenen Dimensionen, 600 Dimensionen beim Thema pro Wort, wie ist das denn gemeint und so weiter. Die müssen die ja irgendwie validieren und das schaffen sie hier. Also die werden nicht auf dich zukommen und dir dann wie YouTube so, fandest du dieses Video gerade hilfreich, ja oder nein, dann sagen die dir mehr davon oder so. Die werden dich nicht fragen, sondern die gehen dann mit ihren Trainingserkenntnissen zu diesen Forschern und validieren dann dort anhand derer echter Scan Beobachtung, ob das Sinn macht, was sie haben und härten dann sozusagen ihre Modelle daran. Das heißt aber, das läuft so richtig im Unbewusstsein für uns.
Und deswegen gibt es ja auch nicht Protest oder gibt es eigentlich gar keinen Diskurs groß darüber, außer jetzt hier in der Tech-Branche.
Wir reden nur über Sachen, die wir sehen, Hautfarben.
Das bedeutet aber, dass wir eine Beschränkung der Autonomie haben. Das heißt also, dessen, was wir unter Freiheit auch verstehen, weil wir dann Gelenkte sind, ohne es zu merken.
Nur noch Nudging.
Genau. Und das sogar so weit geht, dass wir ja, selbst wenn unser Gesichtsausdruck eigentlich einer ist, der auf was anderes hinweist, die Maschine sagt, nee, das ist aber so. Also die Maschine liest das so aus und sagt, ist wohl wütend in der und der Temperatur.
Und dann kann man nicht sagen, Wolfgang hat recht, sondern dann steht Aussage gegen Aussage.
Richtig. Und das ist ja eigentlich ein Weg in eine sehr, sehr unfreie Gesellschaft.
Er blickt ja auch mal zehn Jahre nicht so gut.
Ich will wirklich mal sagen, wenn wir jetzt über Krankheit, Therapie und all das reden, dann sagen wir immer, ja, Leuten muss man helfen, alle sollen geheilt werden. Das ist ja auch alles gut und schön. Nur man muss ja immer sehen, was das sonst alles bedeutet. Diese Dimension der Thürigen, ja nicht nur Überwachung, sondern Lenkung, die da mit einhergeht, ist doch eine, die einen extrem beängstigen kann. Ich kann sagen, ja, für so etwas Alltägliches ist das ja praktisch, wie jeder auf dem Smartphone sagt, ist praktisch, wenn ich da grad auf eine App klicke und weiß, wie das Wetter wird. Aber es geht ja sehr schnell über dieses Praktische hinaus. Und da kommen wir doch in so ein neues Bild von uns selbst, wo wir quasi den Maschinen anvertrauen, zu wissen, für uns was Gutes uns zu lenken in einer so starken Weise, dass wir es nicht mehr merken.
Genau, wir haben ja First Dates zum Beispiel geguckt im Salon. Da hat man ja immer wieder diese Idee von, ach, der Kugelfisch, der Topf auf dem Deckel, der Funke, so. Der Kugelfisch, der Kugelmensch, also der genau zu dir passende, diese Platonche oder wer auch immer diese Idee hatte. Oder der Topf auf dem Deckel, der Deckel auf dem Topf, also das ist so passt, es muss kompatibel sein. Nun, man begegnet vielen, aber nicht sehr vielen Menschen in seinem Leben, in seinem Alltag erst gar nicht. Also man sollte froh sein, dass überhaupt mal jemand auftaucht, der vielleicht neu ist. Dass der dann auch noch passt, ist ja völlig ungewöhnlich. Nur hier wird einfach gestaltet. Also man baut dir einfach die zweite Hälfte des Kugelmenschen. Man legt dir einfach einen Deckel drauf, der genau passt. Das ist wie diese Matratze, die sich deine Körperform anpasst. Ein regulärer normaler Mensch wird damit gar nicht konkurrieren können. Das ist ein bisschen wie alle Leute gucken Pornografie und stellen dann fest, dass man im realen Leben solchen Menschen gar nicht begegnet, wie einen da vorgeführt werden oder so. Also hier steht auch noch sehr viel Enttäuschung aus, wenn diese Technologie erst mal ausgerollt ist.
Denn noch was passiert ja da, ich habe dieses Buch gelesen, Zukunft der Gefühle, wie wir mit emotionaler KI unser Leben verändern, von Eva Weber-Guska, das ist also ein philosophischer Beitrag dazu. Ich finde das Buch nicht so sehr gelungen, weil es so viel von Bekanntem erzählt, was jetzt so in den letzten Monaten, Jahren alles entwickelt wurde. Und es fehlt so ein bisschen an philosophischer Abstraktion. Aber eines ist doch ganz interessant, es geht da um diese Frage, also wenn plötzlich da diese KI ist, die ja eigentlich viel besser ist als ein Mensch, wie muss man eigentlich da raufblicken? Und die Autoren spricht hier von einer problematischen Konsequenz. Sie nimmt dann hier diese Beispiele, die dann so eine KI haben, wenn Frank und Steffi sich nicht nur vorstellen, dass Princess und Randy Gedanken und Gefühle haben, sondern sich selbstständig fiktionalisieren, um mit ihren Avataren eine Welt zu teilen, in der sie tatsächlich in einer Weise interagieren, wie sie persönliche Nahbeziehungen ausmacht, dann verlieren sie die gemeinsame Realität mit den anderen Menschen. Hat Frank nun eine Freundin oder nicht, wenn er so eine KI hat?
Genau genommen hieße es, Frank II hat eine, also diese fiktionalisierte Form von Frank hat eine Freundin, Frank selbst nicht. Wenn Frank seinen Freunden erzählt, dass er eine neue Freundin hat, stimmt das genau genommen nicht. Er vermischt zwei verschiedene ontologische Dimensionen, zwei verschiedene Seinsweisen.
Kann sich so beobachten, aber er wird sich trotzdem sehr wohl damit fühlen.
Ja, das beschreibt sie auch natürlich.
Dass er zu Hause kocht und da ein Kompagnon hat, der ihm das Rezept aufsagt und so weiter und so fort.
Und flirte.
Und flirte, ja. Also es wird brenzlig in der Zukunft. Er blickt hier auch mal zehn Jahre in die Zukunft.
Es gibt enorm viele auch technische Entwicklungen immer noch und ich denke über die nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahre können wir uns darauf einstellen, dass solche Scatterplots, wie ich sie hier zeige, dass sie immer enger werden. Dass letztendlich die Vorhersagegenauigkeit, die Fehlerrate, die Abweichungen, die werden sich über die nächsten Jahre deutlich reduzieren. Mit der Perspektive dann komplexe zum Beispiel Begutachtungsprozesse, komplexe Einschätzungen, also endlose Interviews, neuropsychologische Tests, Expertenmeinungen etc. dann zu ersetzen durch einen einzelnen zehn Minuten, zwanzig Minuten Scan vom Gehirn und aus diesen Daten würde man dann ablesen können, wie es um die entsprechenden inneren Eigenschaften einer Person bestellt ist.
Also wenn und man wird diese Forschung validieren anhand bisheriger Therapiegespräche, Diagnostik, die man so hat, also man wird da so eine richtige Härtung reinfinden und ich habe ja schon häufiger betont, so kompliziert sind wir Menschen ja auch nicht. Also die Bedürfnisse, die Grundlegenden sind relativ einheitlich und die Ausprägungen darüber können gar nicht in diese große Variantenreichtum ausbrechen, wie wir uns das von uns selbst immer erwarten. Am Ende stellen wir fest, alle wollen zu Taylor Swift.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Und hier möchte ich sagen, das ist ein Schreckensszenario, das er hier für mich vorzeichnet, aber ich sehe die Gefahr eher darin, dass ich das durchsetze als Ideologie und dann die Gesellschaft dadurch präge, dass man einfach sagt, unsere Vorstellungsgespräche finden nun mit KI statt. Die KI tut so, als wisse sie nun, dass ich eher labil oder aufbrausend oder sonst was bin und deshalb entscheidet sie sich gegen mich und damit kann ich nicht in dem Unternehmen arbeiten. Das hat eine Wirkung also, der Einsatz der KI, aber es muss nicht der Wahrheit entsprechen. Hier wird sehr stark suggeriert und ich habe das in vielen Beiträgen zu KI und Emotionen erfahren, dass das tatsächlich möglich ist, dieses Auslesen. Erinner dich an diesen unglaublichen Hype um die Neurobiologie und dann war der Ertrag doch relativ gering. Hier muss man natürlich, weil so viel Gelde auch damit drin sind, so ein großes Investoren-Sprecher an den Tag legen und alle anderen, die nicht investiert sind, übernehmen diese Sprechweise trotzdem und tun so, als seien wir so auslesbar. Wir haben ja beim Sommersalon darüber gesprochen, warum liest man eigentlich Literatur und genau da würde ich jetzt einhaken und sagen, die Literatur zeigt, wie vielfältig wir eigentlich sind und wie sehr wir uns selbst nicht verstehen und auch gar nicht verstehen können. Ich verweise da sehr gern noch mal auf den Text Aufzeichnung aus dem Kellerloch von Dostoevsky, der zeigt, wie diese Berechenbarkeit dann doch nicht möglich ist. Nur das hilft mir als Mensch dann im Alltag nicht dann, wenn andere das schon eingesetzt haben. Das ist quasi so wie wenn jemand racial profiling einsetzt, dann kann ich noch so sehr ja sehen, dass das Unsinn ist. Aber wenn das einmal da ist, dann wird man Leute selektieren, aussieben etc. Und das ist etwas, was ich als ganz große Gefahr ansehe. Und ich würde diesen Leuten widersprechen, dass man das alles so gut lesen kann, dass man einige Rückschlüsse mehr daraus ziehen kann, als das jetzt der Fall ist. Sicherlich.
Wir sind alle auf deiner Seite.
Mir bei dir manchmal nicht so sicher.
Aber es gibt Leute, die wollen am Ende einfach nur, also die wollen ganz einfache Fragen mit erklären. Wie zum Beispiel, wähle bitte diesen Kandidaten und nicht den anderen. Also komplizierter ist es nicht. Oder, wenn du einkaufen gehst, entscheide dich für diese 30 Produkte und nicht für diese 700. Oder wenn du abends vom Fernsehen sitzt.
Stefan.
Schaue das, schaue nicht das.
Du hast völlig recht.
Du suchst natürlich immer die große Persönlichkeit, die sich im Gespräch an der Bar mit Unbekannten, die ihm gemeinsames Leben vielleicht gestalten wollten und so weiter. Alles zugestanden.
Ja, ja.
Aber du weißt, wie die Welt funktioniert.
Das wird minimiert. Das wird alles.
Ritmen, das wird kaputt gemacht. Ja.
Genau, das wird kaputt gemacht. Dass das so läuft, das werde ich dir gleich mit einem Autor noch mal beweisen, den du nicht so hoch schätzt, nämlich Blüthorn. Wir kommen noch mal auf Ingolfur Blüthorn nachher zu sprechen, der auch auf die KI kommt. Aber das ist doch eigentlich ein Horrorszenario. Und es ist deshalb für mich ein solches, weil das so latent schon da ist, sich weiter ausbreitet, ohne dass ich das merke. Ich muss mir jetzt bei dem Metaverse von Mark Zuckerberg diese Brille aufsetzen. Gut, wer will immer so eine Brille tragen, fragt man sich da. Ja, vielleicht irgendwelche Gamer, die sowieso schon den ganzen Tag im Gaming-Zimmer sitzen. Aber das war es dann auch. Hier ist es dann präsent und entscheidet plötzlich über mein Leben, wo ich gar nicht mehr sagen kann, ja, aber ich bin gar nicht labil, sondern die KI hat es ja schon für mich entschieden.
Ja, also deine Netflix-Empfehlungsliste wird danach strukturiert sein, dass man dir diesen Film nicht zumutet. Du wirst ihn niemals sehen.
Ja, deswegen kaufe ich ja noch DVDs.
Das ist auch tapfer. Du wirst der Letzte sein, der noch... Zuerst konnte ich sie nicht leihen und jetzt nicht mal mehr kaufen. Das ist ja Frechheit. Auch in den Podcastgesprächen wird nochmal verdeutlicht, es gibt jetzt abseits des Diagnostikgesprächs des Anrufs zu Hause, wen möchten sie denn wählen, wer ist denn der beliebte Politiker, also abseits dieser ganzen Information wird jetzt hier ganz viel Forschungswert gelegt auf diese bislang latenten, unsichtbaren und ich würde ja sagen auch Informationen, aber ein bisschen vulgär ausgedrückt, dieser Mitteilungsaspekt.
Wir haben neue Maschine-Lernmodelle kreiert, die sich mit allen verschiedenen Dimensionen der Vokalmodulation.
Der Tagging zur KI stattfindet. Das ist für uns so selbstverständlich und für die KI nicht. Und diese Zielsetzung finde ich so faszinierend irgendwie, dass sie jetzt erst mal nur herausfinden wollen, allein vom Tonfall, also es ist ja im Grunde, wir schauen uns im Urlaub so ein italienisches Paar an, das ein Gespräch miteinander führt, hören wir heraus, ohne überhaupt zu verstehen, um was es da geht. Wann wechselt jetzt? Wer ist wann dran? Wann ist sie mit dem Geschrei fertig? Wann? Warum redet er so und so? Also irgendwie so in diese, ich wollte jetzt nicht Stereotyp. Dass es wirklich besser oder nur überzeugender ist, wenn GPT so klingt, wie wir es vorhin gehört haben. Dasselbe auch bei Kevin Newton und, äh, nee, Kevin Roos und Casey Newton.
Ich war einfach überrascht, wie viel Varietät es da war. Und auch mit den Dingen, die OpenAI gemacht hat, um es mehr menschlich zu fühlen. Du weißt, du sprichst mit einem Roboter. Es hat einen kleinen Verlust. Und es ist einfach eine Ausdruckserklärung.
Also, ist das keine Engagement-Tech?
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube ganz klar, dass es auch eine Nützigkeit haben kann für Leute, die sich nach einer solchen Kommunikation sehen. Zum Beispiel einsame Leute. Und ich glaube aber, dass die Enttäuschung oder der Ärger, ist glaube ich eher der Ärger, größer werden kann mit einer solchen KI. Denn ich stelle schon fest, manchmal ist man ja irgendwo auf einer Online-Shop-Seite, wo sich so ein Bot dazu schaltet, den man fragen kann. Und da ist man schon sauer, wenn die Frage nicht beantwortet wird. Weil so suggeriert wird, hey, okay, interessant und danke, sagt dieser Bot dreimal. Wenn ich jetzt noch so eine Person habe, die noch freundlich lacht dabei und dann aber doch nur Schluss mir erzählt, dann werde ich glaube ich richtig sauer.
Genau. Das ist eine super interessante Frage, die du damit jetzt aufwirfst. Denn dieser Bot, der begegnet dir in einem spezifischen, du hast echte Fragen, also du brauchst Information. Die Frage, wie sie dir vermittelt werden, ist dir offensichtlich zweitrangig. Du willst die Information haben, die Größe dieser Hose oder nicht.
Ja, wird das Modell noch gebaut, die andere nein.
Ist das aber typisch für Kommunikation, die wir mit Menschen haben und als wohltuend empfinden? Also ist es da entscheidend, dass jemand, das ist Wikipedia-Wissen, aber besonders Intos hat? Oder sind es doch so andere Sachen? Und wenn wir jetzt diskutiert haben, die legen gerade Wert auf so andere Sachen. Also das mit den Informationen haben sie schon bewältigt. GPT ist sehr gut, sehr informativ, aber jetzt wird es eben auch noch überzeugend. Und das Überzeugen kommt aber nicht durch noch bessere Informationen, sondern durch bessere Vermittlung, angepasstere Vermittlung. Und hier macht dieser Simon Eickhoff, finde ich, Eickhoff einen sehr guten Kontrapunkt. Wir können ja bei allen Ansprüchen, die wir an die Maschine haben, wie zum Beispiel, bitte fahr niemals einen Menschen tot. Eigentlich haben wir doch diesen Anspruch auch nicht an menschliche Fahrer, oder? Also wenn es das Kriterium wäre, also wenn ein menschlicher Fahrer jemanden tötet, dann können wir das nicht machen. Wir stellen den Straßenverkehr nicht ein. Also wir haben so andere Ansprüche an die Maschine. Und wenn man das jetzt aber mal kurz durchreflektiert, wie er aus seinem medizinischen Verständnis zum Thema, wie läuft eigentlich so ein Gespräch mit dem Arzt ab? Da finde ich schon, da steckt sehr viel Diskussionsbedarf drin.
Wenn ich jetzt mal ihr Hausarzt sage, ja also bei ihrem Puls und den Geräuschen, die ich bei der Lunge gehört habe und vor allem auch wenn man bedenkt, dass sie mir schon seit Wochen von ihrer Erschöpfung erzählen. Also ich würde ihnen zu diesem Medikament raten. Könnten Nebenwürfen kommen, aber dann reden wir noch mal. Wer würde es nehmen? Ja warum eigentlich? Habe ich eine bessere Genauigkeit als die Maschine? Also ich glaube nicht ehrlich gesagt. Es kommen zwei ganz interessante Aspekte ins Spiel. Das eine ist, dass wir dazu tendieren, Menschen, deren Expertise wir nicht kennen, eine hohe Expertise zuzuschreiben, während wir Maschinen, Algorithmen, deren Expertise wir messen können, wo wir also einen Genauigkeitswert haben. Da gucken wir auf diesen Wert sehr kritisch. 99% Genauigkeit. Naja, aber es ist ja immer noch 1% Chance, dass der Algorithmus sich irrt. Also kein Arzt, kein Richter, kein Personaler hat 99%. Ja, ich darf mit dem Vorurteil aufräumen. Alle Menschen sind sehr weit davon entfernt. Heißt also, wir haben einen hohen Vertrauensvorschuss an Menschen und mit der Genauigkeit der Quantifizierung, also je genauer ich sagen kann, wie gut ein Algorithmus funktioniert, umso mehr steigt auch der Anspruch an diese Genauigkeit. Hinzu kommt noch, dass der Arzt an etwas anknüpfen kann, was die Philosophie das Web of Beliefs nennt, also das Netz ihrer Erfahrung, ihres Wissens, ihrer Eindrücke, ihrer auch Gefühle. Da kann ein Arzt daran anknüpfen, eine Maschine nicht. Und der Arzt hat natürlich immer auch einen etwas holistischeren Blick. Der hat immer sie als mentales Bild im Gesamten vor Augen, wenn der Algorithmus doch sehr spezifisch sich auf eine Frage konzentriert.
Also wir hören hier so Sachen, bei denen ich mir denke, wenn ich jetzt so ein Techniker wäre, ja, also da mache ich mir eine Liste draus, was ich alles noch beachten muss, bevor ich das Produkt entwickle. Und dann gehe ich das halt so durch. So ein holistischer Blick, ja kein Problem. Also ich habe den, ich verkaufe den Leuten eine Uhr, die konstant Impulsen ist, glaube ich, einen holistischen Blick und so. Ich sehe den sein ganzes Leben.
Die Frage ist, ob die KI wirklich eine Lage sein wird, jemanden zu verstehen. Also wir haben doch in unseren privaten Erlebnissen mit anderen Menschen, selbst wenn wir uns sehr lange kennen, manchmal das Gefühl, warum versteht die Person mich eigentlich nicht? Was ist das da eigentlich? Oder warum ist man unsensibel in manchen Momenten? Man enttappt sich ja selbst dabei und denkt, warum hat man das jetzt gerade gemacht? Man versteht es also nicht. Und die Frage ist, inwieweit eigentlich eine KI in der Lage sein kann, diese Art von Verstehen aufzubringen, da sie ja nur mit Wahrscheinlichkeit arbeitet. Sie versteht ja in dem Sinne nichts. Sie ist ja blöde, was das anbelangt. Sie hat nur ganz, ganz viele Daten und sie kann damit die Wahrscheinlichkeit immer weiter erhöhen. Und dann kann man die Wahrscheinlichkeit erhöhen, dass wenn jemand unruhigen Puls hat oder Hochdruck, dann bedeutet das dies und so. Und dann kann man nicht das Medikament empfehlen, sicherlich. Aber natürlich ist der Hausarzt, wenn man ihn wirklich kennt, da haben wir auch schon drüber gesprochen, wer kennt heute noch seinen Hausarzt, wenn er unter 40 ist. Aber wenn es noch so wie früher ist, wo man es noch im Bild hat, dann ist das Verhältnis natürlich ein anderes dazu. Oder wenn man nach größeren Operationen sich aussetzt, dann lernt man ja schon auch Ärzte etwas besser kennen. Oder man merkt so an kleinen Dingen, dass man sich vielleicht verlassen kann oder auch nicht. Aber ich kenne gerade aus meinem Bekanntenkreis jemanden, der schwärmte von dem Arzt, sich darauf verlassen wollte, dann noch mal aus so einer Grundskepsis heraus zu einem anderen, zu einer anderen Koriphäe ging. Und die blickte darauf und sagte, da ist doch gar nichts, was Sie wollen, Sie wollen sich da operieren lassen, um Gottes Willen. Machen Sie mal lieber nicht. Und dann denkt man so, was ist das denn nun? Also da hat man das natürlich. Also ich glaube, bei diesem reinen Diagnostischen kommt man da sehr weit und da hat er natürlich vollkommen recht, dass diese 99 Prozent von Ärzten nicht erreicht werden. Aber wo es eigentlich um das Verstehen geht, da sind die menschlichen Dimensionen doch so viel mehr. Und ich habe immer den Eindruck, gerade wenn ich diesen Leuten aus dem Silicon Valley zuhöre, dass die echt extreme soziale Defizite aufweisen. Das sieht man auch oft, wie sie in diesem Podcast sitzen, wie sie kommunizieren. Da hat man ja tatsächlich den Eindruck, da gibt es nur drei Gesichtsausdrücke. Und nur eine Tonalität.
Aber es gibt doch auch sehr viele...
Da frage ich mich schon, ob da nicht diese eigene Begrenztheit des Ausdrucks für alle gesehen wird. Dass das nicht auch Leute sind, die vielleicht doch mal schauen sollten, dass das Leben noch sehr viel mehr als Einsen und Nullen zur Verfügung fällt.
Ja, aber das sind dieselben Leute, die dir sagen, die Psychologie hat uns nur sechs Dimensionen gegeben, wir brauchen aber 700 und die lassen die auch errechnen. Ob die dann selber, also man kann ja auch durchaus Fallschirme entwickeln in einer Fabrik, ohne selbst einen Vollprüfung machen zu müssen.
Ja, ich glaube nur, du musst ja eine Annahme treffen, worauf du diese, also du musst ja erstmal davon ausgehen, dass es geht. Also man kann ja nur, wenn man glaubt, man kann auf dem Mond leben, beginnen, irgendwelche Hausprojekte auf dem Mond realisieren zu wollen. Und deren Annahme, glaube ich, vom menschlichen Sein, ist ja ganz stark das Gehirn ist wie ein Computer. Und jetzt kann man das mit den Emotionen auch noch mit entsprechenden Datenmaterial auch ganz klar machen. Und das ist ja ein Reduktionismus, der vorgenommen wird, der notwendig vorgenommen werden muss.
Also ich verstehe das Argument trotzdem bremsen.
Das Investoren-Ding.
Ja, das stimmt. Also was wir von GPT sehen sind, ist die Marketing-Abteilung. Da arbeiten sehr viele Psychologen, sehr viele Linguisten. Die Leute haben dort ordentlich studiert, alles gelesen, die kennen sich aus und die verdienen so viel Geld. Die meisten, würde ich sagen, leben ein soziales Leben für 10. Bei Thüringen für 50 Leute.
Ja, das sind also Durchschnittseinkommen von einer Million.
Genau, also wir können jetzt nicht so reduzieren auf ja, eigentlich haben die ja gar keine Ahnung von Menschen oder so, sondern die machen Trial & Error. Und die bedienen sich in der Wissenschaft, wie zum Beispiel hier bei dem Eickhoff oder so. Ich will es ihm jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass er da mit irgendwelchen kapitaltreibenden Leuten zusammenarbeitet, aber man hört solche Vorträge und denkt sich, also wenn ich so ein Techniker wäre, ich würde sofort da mal vorstellig werden und mir den ein oder anderen Plot oder da einfach mal geben lassen und dann mal so Korrelationen rausrechnen. Insbesondere, weil man ja einfach nur der eigene Maschine entwickelt hat, sagen muss, guck mal hier, die machen diese und jene Forschung, was kann ich denn daraus lernen? Und dann ist man sozusagen im Gespräch mit der Maschine, das ist eben die Vermutung, die ich habe. Diese Leute haben da sehr viel Motivation und Optimismus in dieser Interaktion, weil sie selber eine sehr kontrollierte Kommunikation mit ihren eigenen Maschinen haben. Sie wissen, wie sie sie hergestellt haben. Sie wissen noch nicht genau, wie sie funktioniert. Deswegen machen wir diese Forensik. Wir hören das gleich bei Anthropic. Also wo wirklich die Kinnladerunde fällt, wenn man das hört. Und der lebensweltliche Einsatz dieser Technologie ist ein anderer. Der findet dann eben nicht in diesen kontrollierten Laborsituation statt. Dennoch würde ich auch für mich heute schon sagen, das romantische Bild des Mitmenschentums, das du ja immer wieder betont, das habe ich auch. Und ich will das auch nicht verlieren. Ich lebe gerne unter Menschen. Ich mag meine Nachbarn, meine Familie und so weiter. Aber wenn ich spezifische Fragestellungen habe und eine Deadline, dann rede ich sehr gerne mit Claude. Und dann kann ich dir kaum den Namen eines Menschen nennen, bei dem ich sage, der würde mich nicht stören, wenn er in dem Moment am Schreibtisch auftaucht. Sondern würde ihn alle stören. Und es ist aber nicht einfach, ich google da etwas und ich baue etwas zusammen, sondern ich bin da gerade im Gespräch. Es ist, als würde ich gerade telefonieren. Ich bin da wirklich gerade mit Kommunikation befasst. Und das ist neu. Und die Frage ist, wie kriegt man das besser, noch besser, also noch besser, das ist die Betonung. Es ist schon sehr gut, überraschend gut. Wie kriegt man es noch besser hin? Und diesen Weg, den die hier einschlagen, den finde ich ganz richtig. Aber jetzt runtertransformiert auf, du hast sehr viele sozusagen Einwände, kritische Beobachtungen. Und da wird ich ja, also die Frage, die ich daraus entwickle, ist, was muss passieren, damit du dem vergibst? Also alles bleibt aktuell und real. Alle Kritik bleibt gerechtfertigt. Und wie kriegt man es jetzt hin, dass du trotzdem mit Vergebung da rangehst und trotzdem Clot akzeptierst, als Gesprächspartner für dich, für andere, wie auch immer?
So wie die anderen das auch schon zuvor gemacht haben. Ich weiß, ich werde überwacht, aber Google ist einfach praktisch.
Ja, genau. Zum Beispiel. Also diese Art von Akzeptanzherstellung funktioniert ja super. Und ich will jetzt einen Clip spielen, bei dem wir aber, also wenn wir das hören, an den amerikanischen Wahlkampf denken und an diesen Joy, der die ganze Zeit produziert wird.
Und ich habe jetzt nochmal an unseren Rentner unter dem Obstbaum gedacht. Natürlich würde man lieber mit der KI kommunizieren. Also diese Leute dort, die da rumrennen, die grimmig dreinblicken, die eigentlich jedem zur...
Dann noch lieber mit Chachipiti.
Also da kommst du ja hin und da sehen die ein anderes Auto, das da sonst nie war. Und dann werden sie dich schon gleich als Feind betrachten. Natürlich rede ich dann wieder lieber mit Chachipiti. Nur da sind wir, glaube ich, in so einer Welt. Und das ist ja auch das Verlockende daran, dass man eigentlich so eine Situation hat, wie man sie hat, wenn man irgendwo im Hotel oder im Restaurant zu Gast ist. Ich muss nochmal an dieses Heidenreich-Gespräch denken. Sie sagt, sie verliebt sich unglaublich schnell und gern.
So ganz situativ und momenthaft.
Wenn der Kellner nett zu ihr ist und ein paar schöne Worte hat, dann ist sie hingerissen, überlegt, ob sie nicht mit ihm ans Ende der Welt reisen sollte. Und das stellt sich ja leider nicht mehr ganz so häufig ein, egal wo man sich so befindet. Jedenfalls diese Rentner, die da sauer unterm Obstbaum sitzen, die werden dir kein Gefühl vermitteln von, schön, dass du da bist. Und da ist natürlich, wo der Hass der Menschen zunimmt, viel Platz für die Liebe der KI.
Absolut. Diese Leute, gerade wenn sie dann erst mal austesten, sieht ja keiner, wenn sie plötzlich feststellen, ah ja, es ist nicht verkehrt, so eine Höhe zu haben.
Das ist aber eine Dystopie, wie du weißt. Dieser Film endet ja ganz dramatisch.
Man kann ihn ja auch vorher ausmachen, man muss ihn ja nicht bis zu Ende schauen. Beim Vergecast ganz ähnlich. Also die Akzeptanzsachen kommen über Dimensionen, die wir jetzt typischerweise nicht in der Schule, in der Politik, wo immer alle nach Inhalten rufen und so vorfinden.
Wenn man ein Thema so eloquent über Physik geredet hat und scheinbar so viel über sich selbst wusste, zeigt eines oder zeigt zwei Dinge. Das erste ist, dass wir Menschen wirklich sehr offen und gerne auf anekdotische Evidenz reinfallen. Und zweitens, dass wir dazu neigen, Eloquenz und Intelligenz zu vermischen. Also dass wir davon ausgehen, dass wenn jemand eloquent daherredet, dann ist der oder die auch intelligent oder besonders intelligent.
Das ist ja dein Christian Lindner Beispiel. Und da kommt sogar beides zusammen. Einmal diese Eloquenz. Grammatik stimmt immer, Inhalt Unsinn. Und dann noch anekdotische Evidenz, dass er sagt, wenn man in der Bäckerei steht und da fragt man sich schon, wer ist da so vor einem, kommt der eigentlich hierher und sollte der hier bleiben?
Ja, also es wird nicht sehr schwer sein, die Akzeptanzprinzipien, die man von menschlicher Kommunikation hat, hier einfach einzubauen in diese Technik. Und es wird sehr viel schneller convincing, als es wirklich besser wird. Aber ich finde ja, es ist ja innerlich auch schon, was will man da jetzt noch besser machen. Also Claude ist ja nur wirklich Bahnbrechen. Wir hören mal einen Clip, den ich label ihn als Exkurs, weil wir jetzt kurz über Menschen reden. Ich bin durch Zufall darauf gestolpert, in der Republika gab es eine Podiumsdiskussion. Man hat mit jungen Menschen gesprochen, die man spontan auf die Bühne geholt hat, was sie denn so von der Zukunft erwarten und so weiter. Eine Schülerin wird gefragt.
Und ich würde einfach einmal so durchreichen und vielleicht ganz kurz anfangen und mit Johanna Wolfangel anfangen, die wir heute in der Mittagspause rekrutiert haben. Johanna ist in der neunten Klasse.
Also das ist echt mal ein Zufall einfach. Also es ist mal so richtig operationisiert, fast wissenschaftlich eine Zufallsprobe. Man guckt mal so rum.
Und sie hat gesagt, vielleicht ist Mathe ihr Lieblingsfach. Und wenn ich dich jetzt so fest nageln darf, gibt es einen Satz, eine Sache zur Bildung, bei der du sagst, wenn ich heute zitiert werde, dann möchte ich, dass ich so zitiert werde.
Also ich will, dass wir als Schüler und Schülerinnen endlich ernst genommen werden von den Lehrkräften. Ja, weil das oft nicht der Fall ist.
So, Applaus, Applaus natürlich. Nun ist es ja so, Eloquenz, ernst genommen werden und Spaß soll es machen. Die Schule bietet nichts von diesen drei Sachen. Nun werden aber diese KI-Bots, nein.
Also du hast, ist das ganz interessant, manchmal hast du so ein ganz positives Bild von der neuen Schule.
Wir haben über den Sportunterricht gesprochen.
Ja, damit kannst du mich jetzt eher jagen.
Der Sportunterricht, der läuft natürlich alles an.
Ich kann sagen, ich bin... Ja gut, in Mathe war ich nicht gut, deswegen fand ich das natürlich blöd. Aber ich kann sagen, ich bin sehr gern zur Schule gegangen.
Ja gut, es gibt ja auch Pausen.
Ich hatte ja mehr so ein kollegiales Verhältnis zu den Lehrern.
Du bist ja auch eine Orchidee, aber gehen wir mal von den 12 Millionen normalen Schülern aus, Schülerinnen und Schülern, die Suss. Nicht jedem macht jeder Unterricht Spaß. Und trotzdem muss man in jedem Fach irgendwann mal eine Leistungskontrolle abhaken. Nun wird dieses KI-Botterzeug besonders für den Bildungsbereich, der Tutor und so. Und ich kann mir das hier sehr gut vorstellen, wie wir relativ zügig Bots bekommen. Wir haben das jetzt schon fürs Sprachenlernen, Babel und so, die jetzt alle mit dir talken, Luna oder wie sie alle heißen. Dass wir demnächst für die Schule, für die Fahrschule, was auch immer, so Bots bekommen, die, das können wir uns heute noch nicht vorstellen, aber die uns Spaß, Eloquenz und wir nehmen dich ernst. Also wir nehmen Rücksicht auf deine individuellen Bedürfnisse. Wir sagen nicht, mach Aufgabe 3 A bis C, egal was da steht, sondern nein, wir gehen an deine Schwächen ran. Machen das aber spaßsicher. Wir wissen ja, wie sehr Bildung Spaß machen kann, nur nicht immer. Aber wenn man in der Uni ein richtiges Fach trifft, sieht man dann, wie es auseinanderbekommen ist.
Das gilt nicht bei allen Fächern. Du kannst dich jetzt auf den Kopf stellen, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht passieren, dass ich den Sportunterricht toll finde.
Also Sportunterricht mal außen vor. Sportunterricht findet ja auch in der Schule nicht statt. Sondern es ist ja kein, ich meine jetzt Fächer, in denen du schreiben sitzende Prüfungsleistung ableisten musst.
Bio war jetzt nicht mein Lieblingsfach. Da würdest du sagen, da kann der Assistent das dann für mich heiter angeschleiten.
Ja, ich habe genau den Fall vor Augen. Also wirklich jetzt, für dich die Grundzüge des Biounterrichts, also die inhaltlichen Grundzüge Bio Sec 2. Die kann man dir nochmal nahe bringen und du wirst dich unterhalten fühlen.
Du wirst es mögen und ja und verstehen und das ist ja noch das ist das darum gleich gibt es ja bei den Lehrern auch die charismatischen Figuren die waren zum Beispiel für meine Schulzeit besonders wichtig das galt jetzt nicht für alle Lehrer aber es gab schon einige die sehr sehr wichtig waren als Leitbilder und dann gab es auch noch diese Lehrer die waren jetzt nicht Leitbilder aber sie waren in ihrer Eigenart und das hat ja auch damals noch diese möglichkeit gegeben ja der Freiräume innerhalb der Schule für die Lehrer und auch nicht alles so das wegen des dass man dort kuriose Menschen traf die vielleicht ein bisschen schuldig waren aber genau diese Vielfalt hat ja eigentlich am tage dann doch ein relativ gutes Programm ergeben deswegen sage ich rede ich auch nur vom Tutor nicht vom Lehrer der Tutor ist immer sozusagen der Assistent der Lehrkraft in der Uni und in der Schule Ja, das ist das Grundprinzip, sonst ist es keine Pädagogik.
Mir geht es jetzt konkret um eine Prüfungsvorbereitung. Nicht den Unterricht, sondern die Prüfungsvorbereitung.
Genau, die wäre hilfreich.
Da haben wir demnächst Prinzipien, bei denen wir sagen, das hätte ich nie gedacht, dass ich derjenige alleine oder mit seinen Kumpels, und dann sind die wirklich nicht abgelenkt von und so weiter, sondern der kleine Trieb, morgen könnte ich eine eins schreiben, wenn ich mich jetzt diesem Spaß hingebe, es dialogisch kläre, ernst genommen werde und eine eloquente Ansprache bekomme, auch wenn ich noch so gelangweilt. Ich kriege immer eine eloquente Antwort. Das wird einiges verändern, glaube ich. Im Gegenentwurf wird sich auch einiges verändern. Sehr amüsante Clips von Chan Yo-Yoon. Das ist der Anwalt, der in Deutschland schon immer mal sich mit den Großen anlegte, Facebook da irgendwelche gerichtsfesten Briefe schicken ließ und so weiter und so fort. Er war in unterschiedlichen Podcasts zu Gast, zum Beispiel bei Haken Dran jetzt im August und er redet mal über seine eigene Zunft. Und ich habe ja auch schon, ich höre häufiger hier gesagt, die Auseinandersetzung mit Clor zu juristischen Themen macht wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Wenn ich irgendwo und ich habe einmal in meinem Leben Essen bestellt, es wurde nicht geliefert, also es wurde storniert und ich hatte dann übersehen, dass es auch zurückgebucht wurde. Also ich war unter der Impression, das Geld kam nicht zurück. Also habe ich gesagt, okay, kein Problem. Ich super gerne schicke ich das alles zu Clor, also meinen ganzen Mailverkehr und sage, schreibe mir einen richtig harten juristischen Text, in dem ich dann noch drunter schreibe, für Rückfragen stehe ich nicht zur Verfügung. So und es macht Spaß. Also diese Art von juristischer Auseinandersetzung macht plötzlich Spaß.
Das ist aber auch eine sehr spezielle Freude, die du da entwickelt hast, die auch nicht ganz gesund ist vielleicht.
Man kann es jetzt machen. Es macht Spaß, Clor ist sehr eloquent.
Du kannst damit auch jetzt viele Leute, die unter Obst wollen, in Thüringen sitzen, auf Ideen bringen.
Ja, das ist durchaus eine Gefahr.
Man kann auch mit KI wunderbar bald hassen.
Genau, ja absolut, also ich will niemandem noch Gedanken bringen, aber es hat mir irgendwie Spaß gemacht. Es macht mir Spaß. So, jetzt denken wir, naja klar, einen Schriftsatz, den lagert man natürlich aus an Clot und jetzt kommt aber Jun.
Also immer wenn man Leute hört, seid ihr, fühlt ihr euch bedroht von KI, glauben die Leute, das was ich kann, das kann nur ich, wie zum Beispiel Juristen und Juristen, alle außer Juristen, wissen, dass Juristen ersetzbar sind. Wir Juristen glauben aber, nee, da braucht man sieben Jahre Studium und Intuition und das Menschliche, die Emotionalität, aber ehrlich gesagt, der emotionale Teil zu verstehen, was will der Mensch wirklich, das kann die KI am Schluss besser als der Mensch, als jedenfalls der juristisch gebildete Mensch. Also tatsächlich ist die, es gibt verschiedene Schwierigkeiten beim Anwaltsberuf, die juristisch die Rechtslage zu ermitteln, das machen die Studenten und Referendare, da brauchen wir auch mal nicht so viel Erfahrung. Aber zu verstehen, was der Mensch will, ist schwieriger, aber das ist eigentlich die Stärke von Large-Language-Models, Kontext zu verstehen und rauszulesen, was ist eigentlich wirklich das, was den Menschen bedrückt.
Und das ist doch wahnsinnig interessant, denn bislang waren diese körpernahen Dienstleistungen, für die wir nicht Beruf, sondern Profession als Begriff benutzen, der Arzt, der mit dem Patienten in echtem Kontakt ist, der Anwalt, der mit seinem Mandanten mal ein ernstes Wort reden muss, der Lehrer, der den Schüler wirklich vor sich hat. Die waren eigentlich, galt es bislang als die geschützten Bereiche. Da wird sich KI nicht einmischen. Ich bleibe auch weiter dabei. Da wird sich einmischen, aber nicht ersetzen. Also der Tutor, aber nicht der Lehrer und so. Und jetzt sagt er hier, naja, die Juristen haben hier schon ein spezifisches Interesse. Sie wollen jenseits der juristischen Formulierung, was ist denn hier vorgefallen, gerade im Strafrecht nochmal wirklich verstehen. Also man braucht die Intention. Ist er zu schnell gefahren, weil er gerade in einem Rennen verwickelt war? Hat er jemanden nicht gesehen? Hat er sein Auto als Tatwaffe? Hat er etwas billigend in Kauf genommen? Also eine Nichthandlung muss ihm jetzt besonders hart ausgelegt werden und so. Und dann sagt er, ja, das ist eigentlich die Aufgabe für die KI. Da, wo der Jurist heute noch sagt, Schriftsetzer, Bürokratie gerne auslagern, damit ich mich um das Eigentliche kümmern kann. Und dann sagt er, nee, das Eigentliche ist das für die KI. Die wird am Ende nach 735 Dimensionen das Geständnis auswerten, akustisch, und sagen, wie ist das jetzt zu bewerten? Also in Amerika, wo man noch ein bisschen anders damit umgeht und Datenschutz jetzt auch nicht wirklich dich davor schützt, dass der Chef einfach deine Kommunikation mit Kollegen auswerte, solange sie unter seiner E-Mail-Adresse laufen. Da wird es dann richtig heikel. Und er hat hier noch einen zweiten Spruch.
Warum ich etwas mag, muss nicht an dem Hashtag und dem Thema liegen. Und das ist das, was TikTok besser hinkriegt, dass es die Gemeinsamkeiten herausließt aus diesen Themen. Das ist nicht einfach nur politische Ausrichtung, wofür sich Menschen interessieren und nur Themen, die man ja noch verstehen könnte, sondern es sind andere Merkmale, die die Inhalte, die ich sehen möchte, gemeinsam haben, die mir gar nicht bewusst sind. Und das wissen die künstlichen Intelligenzen, die neuronalen Netzwerke anscheinend besser als sich selbst.
Hier war im Quoted-Maniate-Podcast zu Gast. Also die KI sagt er und wir müssen hier auch gelten lassen, dass das ein Argument von Autorität ist. Allein weil er sich mit diesen Sachen wirklich befasst und auch diese juristischen Kämpfe gegen diese Unternehmen führt. Also wenn er das sagt, gilt hier einfach anderes, als wenn wir jetzt auch nochmal eine Meinung dazu haben. Das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Ich hoffe, er macht auch irgendwann nochmal seinen eigenen Podcast oder so, dass man ihn da häufiger und im Verlauf dieser Entwicklung hört. Wir beenden aber dieses Thema, bevor wir nochmal kurz zu den Geistern die Maschine abwandern, mit dem Big Technology Podcast, wo nochmal kurz markiert wird, wo es ist fast ein Selbstläufer, dass diese Technologien als erstes angewendet werden. Und ich habe es häufiger betont. In Bielefeld damals gab es ein ITler, ein Informatiker, Hendrik, der auch hier Podcast-Hörer ist, der damals schon für Betel an solchen technischen Agenten für Patienten mit Gehirnbeeinträchtigungen, sage ich mal, in allen möglichen Ausprägungen arbeitete, weil die ihre Pfleger immer genervt haben mit, wann ist mein Termin, wann gehe ich zum Friseur. Also alle drei Minuten kommt dieselben Fragen. Kennt ja jeder so. Und diese Demenzverhaltensweisen, die dann einspielen. Und man wollte damals eine Technologie bauen, die ihn antwortet. Und ohne ihn vor zu gaukeln, es ist ein Mensch. Also sie sollten einfach wissen, das ist zwar nur eine Maschine, aber trotzdem, da kann ich hingehen, da kriege ich meine Information. Nur alte Leute reden undeutlich, stammeln, beenden Sätze nicht. Also wie wir es bei Barbara, Barbara und so wollen gehört haben. Und das ist wirklich ein Einfallstor. Also hier werden Märkte demnächst eröffnet. Wie schon immer, es kommt diese neue Silicon Valley Technologie. Und wir denken alles, das ist für die hippen, jungen, sportlichen und so, die auf dem Mountainbike stürzen, nein. Es ist natürlich für die Oma, die die Treppe runterfällt und so. Und so ist das hier alles, was wir jetzt bisher und gesprochen haben, auch zu verstehen.
Wir haben darüber gesprochen, wie das Kunden-Service, Produkt und Stimme, alles zusammenverbreitet werden. Wird es andere interessante Applikationen geben, die aus dieser Art kommen? Vielleicht, ein Beispiel, den ich gehört habe, ist ein AI-Kompanion für älterliche Menschen, die alleine sind oder vielleicht sogar junge Menschen, die alleine sind. Was denkst du davon? Dann kommst du wirklich in seltsame Situationen, weil es kann sein, es ist nicht verrückt zu sagen.
Naja, also mit diesen romantischen Beziehungen, die da entstehen können, muss man doch eher das dir öknotisieren, dass das ein Zeichen von großer Traurigkeit eigentlich ist, wo man sicherlich nicht einen Ersatz findet. Also das ist, glaube ich, das Ding, dass man das eine ist, das Funktional einzusetzen und sich einfach unterhalten zu müssen. Ich muss ja, wenn ich einen Promt setze, immer so Zusatzinformationen mitgeben, damit der Kontext klar ist. Das muss ich nicht machen, wenn ich mich mit dir unterhalte. Dass das alles sehr sinnvoll ist und dass das möglicherweise auch zu therapeutischen Zwecken mitunter eingesetzt werden kann. Alles zugestanden. Die Juristen werden davon profitieren oder in Teilen ersetzt werden. Ja, wenn wir aber jetzt hier so etwas haben, dass die romantische Beziehung plötzlich wahrgenommen wird, dann müssen wir doch überlegen, was ist denn eigentlich eine romantische Beziehung? Es ist schon die Interaktion von zwei Menschen, die miteinander ein Verständnis entwickeln und nicht einer die ganze Zeit ein Verständnis nur vorspielt. Das ist die Traurigkeit. Und das sehe ich ja als großes Problem an, wenn man also eine Situation, die man eigentlich ändern müsste, nicht ändert, sondern nur jetzt dem Ganzen so eine technische Applikation überstülpt, mit der es einigermaßen erträglich ist. Und ich weiß, dass gerade in Altenheimen vieles darum geht, es irgendwie erträglich zu machen. Die Tage verlaufen gleichförmig. Aus dem Radio kommen die immer gleichen Lieder. Alles hat seine Rituale. Der eine guckt grimmig, immer beim Mittagessen. Der andere nimmt sich noch den zweiten Pudding. Das wird sehr frustrierend sein. Und ich glaube, da das aufzuhellen, meinetwegen, aber auch da gibt es ja schon die Frage, warum muss das eigentlich so sein? Warum funktioniert Alter gerade vorwiegend so? Aber wenn wir jetzt dann noch auf die romantischen Beziehungen gehen, dann sehen wir doch, was wir da eigentlich alles verlieren. Und wenn wir uns an diese Art der Beziehungen gewöhnen, dann sind wir doch eigentlich verloren. Denn es ist ja auch nochmal was anderes. Also wir haben jetzt viel so über parasoziale Beziehungen geredet. Also irgendjemand stalkt Berühmtheiten oder glaubt genauso zu sein wie die Berühmtheit oder meint, das sei eigentlich der beste Freund. Da ist aber noch die Sache, dass man ja was verwechselt. Nämlich das Bild, was man auf dem Bildschirm hat, mit dem Mensch dahinter. Aber hier gibt es ja nicht mehr etwas dahinter, sondern nur noch das Bild, nur noch die Illusion eines Menschen. Und das führt doch in eine ganz tragische Beziehung, die in Situationen funktionieren mag, ja. Wie auch andere Hilfsmittel funktionieren mögen. Also Alkohol funktioniert auch, nur das danach, ja. Das ist eben das, wo man es merkt. Also jetzt, wenn man eine Alkoholabhängigkeit ist, ja, dann ist, also wenn der Rausch vorbei ist. Und genauso auch, wenn diese Kommunikation dann eine Weile funktioniert. Und dann geht man aber doch alleine ins Bett und ist alleine da.
Also wir haben es hier mit zwei konkurrierenden Märkten zu tun. Das eine ist künstliche Intelligenz, die etwas überdeckt. Und das andere ist, wie Scott Galloway sagt, der größere Markt noch. Der einzige noch größere Markt als AI. Jetzt können wir alle überlegen, was soll das sein? Osempic und der ganze Kram. Menschen bringen sich wieder in Form, um sozial kompatibel zu sein. Und dazu gehört vor allem, sich selber wieder wohlzufühlen. Denn du kannst natürlich jetzt sagen, ja, da wird ja was überdeckt und so. Ja, wir haben jetzt eine 40-jährige Geschichte des High-Processed-Food hinter uns, bei der die Menschen immer vor die Wahl gestellt wurden. Dann kurzfristige Befriedigungen, die dir aber langfristig das Genick bricht. Oder Disziplin und dafür ein gesundes, fites und du fühlst dich auch wohl leben. Und die Menschen haben sich für ihn das erste entschieden. Und die Verlockung, die hier drin steckt, du machst dein Handy an und es spricht mit dir und zwar so, wie du es magst und du wirst wiedererkannt und so weiter, ist noch viel verlockender als in Snickers oder sowas. Also die Zugkraft ist ja einfach unendlich groß. Und Mark Zuckerberg, clever wie er ist, schlägt jetzt auch die Klammer mit dem Metaverse hat er sich verschätzt. Und Metaverse hieße ja, zwei Menschen werden noch miteinander verlinkt, auch wenn sie nicht anwesend sind. Jetzt kommt dieses AI-Ding, wo es heißt, wir stellen Präsenz her, ohne dass du noch einen zweiten brauchst. Es ist sozusagen Metaverse ohne die Gegenseite, dein eigenes Metaverse. Er schafft es natürlich, in Worte zu kleiden, die die Investoren irgendwie ansprechen sollen.
Ich bin eigentlich nicht sicher, dass es in der Zeit zurückkommen wird. Ich denke, es wird cool für die Historik-Klasse und so weiter.
Das war so die Frage, wozu brauchen wir Metaverse, um nochmal in die Geschichte zurückzugehen, etwas zu sehen, was vergangen ist. Ich meine, auch eine schöne Metaebene hier.
Das geht nicht. Wenn das tatsächlich so weit entwickelt werden kann, wie wir eben hörten, dann muss zunächst mal eine KI an Mark Zuckerberg ausgetestet werden, damit wir das mal auslesen. Du hörst ihm zu und weißt, dass er nicht ehrlich zu dir ist.
Ja, hier gilt auch irgend so eine Rüdger-Bregmann-Logik. Ja, irgendwas stimmt mit Mark Zuckerberg nicht. Gut, wir befassen uns jetzt noch ganz kurz mit einem Thema. Ich fand es wirklich crazy. Josh Betzen, ein Techniker von Anthropic, die also Claude verantworten, war im Hardfork Podcast zu Gast im Mai. Also sind ja lange liegen geblieben, die Clips. Deswegen gucken wir im August-Mai-Clips. Und er erklärt mal, dass sie jetzt so Schritt für Schritt vorwärts kommen mit der Forensik. Anthropic veröffentlicht zum Beispiel extrem viel. Die haben gestern auch Systemprompts, also mit denen sie Claude überhaupt in Form bringen und so, veröffentlicht, damit man mal allgemein nachlesen kann, was passiert da eigentlich. Und sie hatten hier eine Forschung gemacht, die uns vorgestellt wird, die mit einer Paper-Veröffentlichung einherging, weshalb er hier eingeladen ist.
Was würdest du sagen, dass wir uns nicht verstehen, wie große Sprache-Modelle funktionieren?
Also, es ist eine schwarze Box, die sich vor uns befindet, und wir können sie öffnen, und die Box ist nur voll Nummern. Und also, Wörter gehen rein, sie werden in Nummern geändert, ein ganzes Bündchen von Computern passiert, Wörter kommen auf der anderen Seite, aber wir verstehen nicht, was any of those Nummern bedeuten. And so, one way I like to think about this is like, you open up the box, and it's just full of thousands of green lights, that are just flashing like crazy. And it's like something's happening, for sure. And like different inputs, different lights flash, but we don't know what any of those patterns mean.
So, Input. Also, ich trage keine Zahlen bei Claude ein, sondern Buchstaben, da werden aber Zahlen draus. Er sieht da, sagt dann, wir sehen dann auch Zahlen, wir wissen nicht, was sie bedeuten, und am Ende werden die Zahlen wieder in Buchstaben umgewandelt. Okay, also eine Blackbox, bei der man sieht, wir wissen nicht, was passiert, aber da leuchtet irgendwas. Er sitzt in Zahlen, also Zahlen sind es, aber er meinte so Lichter, da gehen so Lichter an und aus. Okay, sie werden ja nicht programmiert, sondern sie sollen von selber wachsen. Die Nähe zur Biologie in diesem Gespräch finde ich wirklich verrückt.
Es ist irgendwie so, wie Tiere und Pflanzen funktionieren, und wir verstehen nicht, wie sie funktionieren. Diese Modelle werden mehr als programmiert. Du nimmst die Daten und das bildet die Soil, und du konstruierst eine Architektur, und es ist wie ein Trellis, und du leuchst die Lichter, und das ist der Training. Und dann wächst der Modell hier. Und am Ende ist es wundervoll.
Dass das Wesen, das das kann, wiederum für uns nicht einsichtig.
Es sind emergente Strukturen. Man kann es, und deswegen Systemtheorie, nur irritieren. Der Prompt ist nur eine Irritation für das abgeschlossene, reflexiv operierende System, das danach wieder irritiert. Es gibt ja Ausgaben aus. Aber man kann nicht wirklich reingehen und steuern. Es ist keine Trivialmaschine. Hier greifen keine Wenn-Dann-Algorithmen oder so, sondern es ist eine gewachsene Struktur. Wenn die Biologie als Grundlage für die Prinzipien heuristisch herhält, wird es immer interessant. Das ist auch bei sozialwissenschaftlichen Theorien so. Und überall sonst. Also es ist nicht schlecht. Auch in Filmen. Ich finde, wenn Filme immer mit so einer biologischen Mystik arbeiten, wie zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Geister unter der Erde, hier Stranger Things oder sowas. Also wenn es so biologisch wird, Alien, also dieser Outer Space-Teil macht es immer interessant. Wenn man also vor sich ein gewachsenes System hat, dann muss man damit anders umgehen. Man ist dann kein Techniker, sondern Lehrer, Anwalt, Mediziner, wie auch immer. So wird es auch hier besprochen.
Das ist eine tolle Analogie. Du kannst sie benutzen. Wir benutzen sie jetzt. Aber Tylenol kann Menschen töten, und so kann Anästhesie. Und es gibt eine große Menge Forschung in der Pharmaceutikindustrie, um zu erkennen, was für ein paar Drogen sicher ist und was für andere Drogen gefährlich ist. Und Interpretabilität ist wie die Biologie auf Sprachmodelle, die wir dann nutzen können, um die Medizin besser zu machen.
Wir hören jetzt einen Clip, der geht über vier Minuten. Er ließ sich nicht kürzen, obwohl inhaltlich gar nicht so viel drin vorkommt. Er sagt einfach nur, wir haben immer so neuronales Netzwerk vor Augen. Also beruhen wir uns auf Neuronen. Wir reden halt über Neuronen. Wir müssen aber mehr über dieses Netzwerk reden. Es geht also nicht über Neuronen. Neuronen sind die Elemente, aber das Netzwerk selbst spielt eine Rolle. Sie haben jetzt diese Forensik gemacht, haben sich das angeschaut. Da waren so Zahlen drin. Zahlen haben Werte. Diese Werte haben sie in seinem Bild umgedeutet auf leuchtet mehr, leuchtet weniger, wie auch immer. Er beschreibt das jetzt mal. Wir hören jetzt hier eine Deskription. Mir geht es um den Clip, den wir danach hören. Also wir nehmen jetzt Anlauf zu einem Clip, von dem ich denke, das ist verrückt. Also wir brauchen hier wirklich neue Philosophie, neue Prinzipien, neue Ökonomie, neue Politik. Alles neu. Wir können nicht mehr so weitermachen wie bisher.
Ja, ja. Komm, komm. Jetzt warten wir mal.
Also wir hören jetzt erst mal diese vier Minuten.
Also, wenn du die schwarze Karte wiederholst, ist sie voll mit Flaschenlichten. Ein paar Jahre ago haben die Leute gedacht, du kannst einfach verstehen, was ein Licht bedeutet. Wenn dieses Licht auf ist, bedeutet das, dass das Modell über Kode denkt, und wenn dieses Licht auf ist, denkt es um Katzen. Für dieses Licht ist es Casey Newton. Und das ist einfach falsch geworden. Ein Jahr und ein halbes Jahr ago haben wir ein Buch oder ein Buch, das in Details spricht, warum es nicht nur ein Licht oder eine Idee ist. Im Hintergrund sieht es so aus, als ob wir versuchen würden, die englische Sprache zu verstehen, indem wir individuelle Letter verstehen. Und wir fragten uns, was C bedeutet, was K bedeutet. Und das ist einfach die falsche Bildung. Und also sechs Monate vor, hatten wir ein Erfolg mit einem Method, den Diktionär-Learnung genannt wurde, um zu erkennen, wie die Letten zusammen in Wörter befinden. Und was ist der Diktionär des englischen Wörters hier? Und also in diesem schwarzen Schwarz-Weiß-Licht-Metaphore gibt es ein paar zahlreiche Lichte-Patternen. Einige Patternen würden ein Diktionär-Wörter sein. Und das interne Zustand des Modells könnte irgendwann nur ein paar sein.
Und was ist das Ziel des Unkommens von diesen Patternen?
Wenn wir wissen, was diese Patternen sind, dann können wir anfangen, was das Modell in der Mitte des Prozesses denkt.
Also, du kommst mit diesem Method des Diktionär-Learnens her. Du verwendest es für ein kleines Modell oder ein kleines Modell, viel kleiner als jeder Modell, den jeder von uns benutzen würde, in der öffentlichen Welt. Was hast du gefunden?
Also, dort haben wir sehr einfache Dinge gefunden. Es könnte ein Pattern sein, das zu den Antworten in Französisch und ein anderes, das zu dem Url zuhört. Und ein anderes, das zu Nouns in Physik zuhört.
Und um ein bisschen technisch zu kommen, was wir hier über Neuronen reden, innerhalb des Modells, die so...
Ja, also, jeder Neuron ist wie die Licht. Es ist ein massiver Engineering-Challenge. Also, man musste hunderts von Millionen oder Billionen von diesen internen Staaten des Modells machen, so wie man es gemacht hat. Und dann musste man diesen massiven Diktionarium trainieren.
Und was haben Sie am Ende des Prozesses?
Also, Sie haben die Wörter. Aber Sie wissen nicht, was sie bedeuten. Also, dieses Modell der Lichter scheint wichtig zu sein. Und dann gehen wir und kometen durch alle Daten, um Instanzen zu suchen, wo dieser Modell der Lichter passiert ist. Und Sie denken, oh mein Gott, dieses Modell der Lichter, bedeutet, das Modell denkt über die Golden Gate Bridge.
Hm, also es klingt fast, als ob du die Sprache des Modells entdecken würdest, als du diese Phrases zusammenfährst.
Ja, es klingt fast, als ob wir eine konzeptuelle Map von Claude's Inner World bekommen.
Nun, in dem Papier, den Sie alle gelesen haben, sagt es, dass Sie ungefähr 10 Millionen von diesen Patternen, die Sie nennen, Features, die mit den wirklichen Konzepten zu verstehen sind, in Bezug auf die Frage, wie granular diese Features sind. Was sind die Features, die Sie gefunden haben?
Also, es gibt Features, die mit allen Entitäten zusammenführen. Es gibt Individuale, wie Wissenschaftler wie Richard Feynman oder Rosalind Franklin.
Ist das ein Hardfork-Feature?
Es gibt chemische Elemente, es gibt Stile der Poesie, es gibt Wege, die zu Fragen antworten. Einige sind viel mehr konzeptionistisch. Einer meiner Lieblingsfeatures ist eine Feature, die mit Inneren Konflikten beruht. Und etwas näher in konzeptionistischem Raum ist, wie eine romantische Verbreitung zu navigieren, 22-Jährige, politische Trennungen. Und so sind diese ziemlich abstrakten Notionen. Und du kannst sehen, wie sie alle zusammen sitzen. Die Modelle sind auch sehr gut bei Analogien. Und ich denke, das könnte sein, warum. Wenn eine Verbreitung nahe einer diplomatischen Entente ist, dann hat die Modelle etwas tiefer über die Natur der Trennung in Beziehungen verstanden.
Und wieder, nichts davon wurde programmiert.
Diese Sache hat sich natürlich selbst organisiert, als sie getraut wurde.
In Ermangelung von Begrifflichkeit nennen sie Features. Also wir hatten ein ursprüngliches Verständnis, dass ein Neuron für eine Sache zuständig ist, dann werden die miteinander verkoppelt, 90 verschiedene Pfade oder 90 verschiedene Ebenen und dann Pfadabhängigkeiten, wie auch immer. Dann kommt halt so Worte raus, weil wurden ja Worte getriggert und die fallen dann raus. Jetzt sagt er, ne, das sind nicht wirklich die Worte und wir können jetzt nicht einfach sagen. Die Neuronen, denn die Neuronen können in unterschiedlichen Verhältnissen zueinander stehen. Wir wissen aus dem menschlichen Gehirn, dass die Neuronen mehrere Verbindungen und diese Verbindung dann noch in 10.000 verschiedenen Ausprägungen, also Stromstärken, sozusagen, funktionieren. Und aus dem Gesamtgefüge, wie Neuronen gerade miteinander interagieren, ergeben sich Feature. Und jetzt hat er gesagt, in diesem kleineren Trainingsmodell, das sie hatten, haben sie 10 Millionen identifiziert. Und jetzt können wir aber nicht einfach sagen, ach so, da wird es nicht in Neuronen einzeln weggespeichert, sondern in Features, also in Neuronen-Zusammenhängen. Nein, denn man hat dann nicht nur Begriffe gefunden, was man vorher bei Neuronen vermutete, sondern Konzeptionen. Und es ist ja hier schon sehr weit gegangen. Die Golden Gate Bridge könnte ein so ein sein, aber auch Neuromantic Breakup. Und dann davon nochmal die Ausprägung, welchen Charakter hat denn dieses soziale Zerwürfnis gerade. Wir haben also, wie er sagt, eine innere Welt vorgefunden, von und die sagen jetzt Feature aus Verlegenheit, ich würde sagen von Persönlichkeitsmerkmalen. Also man kann durchaus jetzt hier, gerade auch weil er sagte, es gibt so verschiedene Features, die uns zeigen, in welchem Stile geantwortet, also kommuniziert wird. Wo wir ja ganz nah an diesem unabhängig von Inhalten wird, erst mal die Frage gestellt, ja wie denn eigentlich. Kennt man so, wenn man Eltern ist, dann redet man mit den Kindern. Also Inhalte spielen dann auch eine Rolle, aber erst mal muss man eine Rampe bauen und so, ja, Comedyprogramme aufziehen. So, und wenn die sowas hier vorfinden, und wir aber vorher gesagt haben, naja, das sind ja nicht wirklich Menschen auf der anderen Seite dann, das ist halt eine Maschine, dann nutzen wir einen Maschinenbegriff, der nicht ganz passt, weil es ist nicht der Maschinenbegriff, den wir bisher für Maschinen hatten. Es ist kein Roboter, den wir einfach einen Befehl geben, einen Auftrag, wie auch immer, da geht nicht einfach ein Licht an und aus, oder es wird etwas gekühlt, aber was weg zu vor? Ja, das ist jetzt die Frage. Also wir haben eine Tierrechtsdiskussion, wir haben eine Kinderrechtsdiskussion, Kinder sind auch noch nicht vollständige Menschen, wir sprechen ihnen kein Wahlrecht zu und so weiter. Wie gehen wir jetzt mit diesen Maschinen um, die uns in so frühen Stadien das jetzt schon zeigen? Diese Trainingswelle kommt ja jetzt erst mit den neuen Nvidia-Geschaffenen, was auch immer.
Ja, ich bin da relativ gelassen. Ich weiß, wohin der Diskurs gehen könnte. Und da gibt es auch einige, die dann sagen, die brauchen dann auch ein eigenes Recht, ein Maschinenrecht oder wie man das auch immer nennen möchte.
Das will ich noch gar nicht sagen.
So ein KI-Recht muss da ausbuchstabiert werden. Das läuft ja alles sehr stark hinaus darauf, dass da doch so etwas wie eine General Intelligence entsteht. Ja, also Artificial General Intelligence. Das ist ja das Große. Und ich sage es jetzt nochmal deutlich. Investoren versprechen, dass man jetzt gerade solche Dinge entwickelt, mit denen man Leute ein bisschen froh machen kann, die mal auf Zuruf etwas erfahren wollen, wie sie sich zum Vorstellungsgespräch zu verhalten haben. Aber eigentlich kommt irgendwann diese General Intelligence, die dem Menschen überlegen ist. Und das ist natürlich so ein Versprechen, das wahnsinnig gut funktioniert, solange es geglaubt wird. Ich halte das für völlig falsch, weil es eine Fehlannahme ist von dem, was Intelligenz eigentlich meint und was Maschinen vermögen, die kein Bewusstsein haben können, egal wie viele Daten man dann noch reingeben wird. Und deswegen ist meine Prognose, und es kann sein, dass ich mich natürlich sehr lächerlich mache, am Ende der 20er Jahre, diese KI-Blase wird platzen.
Die ökonomische.
Die ökonomische Platze.
Die ist natürlich auch viel zu groß.
Warum? Weil das Versprechen, diese Generalintelligenz herzustellen, sich nicht einlösen lässt. Wird die KI eingesetzt werden, um juristische Fälle einfacher zu bearbeiten? Natürlich. Und wir können 1000 andere Beispiele nehmen für die Diagnostik in der Medizin. Aber sie wird das nicht erfüllen. Und deswegen brauchen wir eigentlich diese Diskussion der Rechte nicht, sondern wir müssen nur jetzt eigentlich klären, welche Rechte wir Menschen brauchen, damit die KI nicht uns beschränkt.
Die Gegenargumente fallen mir jetzt sehr leicht. Ich will es ausdrücklich sagen, denn die ökonomische Blase ist mir ganz egal.
Aber die ist ja entscheidend dafür, dass weiter geforscht wird.
Also, Clot ist jetzt gerade in einem Zustand, der mir komplett ausreicht. Ich brauche kein klügeres Clot gerade. Also ich habe jetzt keinen Anwendungsfall dafür. Der jetzige Zustand von Clot wurde hergestellt ganz ohne irgendeine KI-Blase. Das ist die letzten Jahre passiert. Diese KI-Blase betrifft irgendwie die Zukunft. Irgendwer verspricht sich gerade an irgendwelche Erwartungen und keine Ahnung. Und ich nehme auch an, ökonomisch ist das völlig übertrieben, denn Clot kostet mich 20 Euro. Ich weiß nicht, von wie vielen Leuten auf der Welt man 20 Euro abkassieren kann, damit das gerechtfertigt wird, was da gerade an Preisen aufgerufen werden. Deswegen sehe ich das auch nicht. Also ökonomisch sozusagen spielt das keine Rolle. Juristisch und politisch. Ich will keinen Diskurs darüber. Wir haben es ja nicht mal bei Tieren oder Kindern hinbekommen, ob jetzt die Maschine Rechte bekommt. Diese Maschine fühlt nicht. Sie leidet nicht. Man muss ihr keine Rechte zusprechen. Punkt. Also ganz einfach. Aber mir geht es um den realweltlichen Einschlag. Und ich habe zum Beispiel eine Mail bekommen. Ich kriege jetzt häufiger so Mails von Leuten, die auch Clot benutzen. Also sehr viele sind ja so angefixed von uns. Es wird irgendwie so zur Logistik studiert, Filme geguckt, Clot genutzt.
Das ist ein schönes Werbevertrag mit Clot klarmachen können.
Ja. So und jetzt ist es so, ich lese aus einer Mail, sage nicht wer und ich habe diese ganze Konversation auch bekommen. Also jemand hat mich ja wirklich einblicken lassen und schreibt dann, ich denke jetzt doch etwas darüber nach, dass ich fast an dem Punkt bin, an dem ich der KI mehr vertrauen würde als meinem Therapeuten, was bestimmte Themen angeht. Und ich bin mir unsicher, was das nun gesellschaftlich für Implikation haben könnte. Und ich will jetzt ausdrücklich sagen, Mord war schon verboten, bevor wir die Positivierung des Rechts hatten. Und so haben wir ganz viele solche lebenspraktischen Themen, bei denen egal ist, was jetzt irgendein Jurist dazu sagt. Es wird, auch wenn kein Politiker sich jemals dazu äußert und wir sagen, okay, das müssen sie auch nicht. Sie haben das Social-Netz nicht reguliert bekommen und das jetzt auch nicht. So, schön und gut, die Technologie ist da, die Leute führen ihr Leben und in diesem Leben findet Kloot statt. Und plötzlich kriegen sie solche Erkenntnisse. Es spielt also einfach eine Rolle, nicht welche juristischen, politischen, ökonomischen Erwartungen wir haben und über wen wir lachen wollen, weil irgendwas geplatzt ist oder wie auch immer, sondern es ist einfach die ganz einfache Frage, wenn wir jetzt diesen Clip hören, auf den ich hinwollte, den ich jetzt vorbereitet habe. Wie gehen wir in unserem Alltag mit dieser verschwindend geringen 20 Euro Investitionen pro Monat um, wenn vielleicht doch mehr dahinter steckt? Und dieses Gespräch von den beiden mit diesem Josh Betzen drehte sich eben noch mal um diesen kleinen Punkt hier.
Ich möchte dich über einen Feature nennen, den ich in diesem Modell gesehen habe, welches F-Nummer 1M885402 war. Erinnerst du dich an den? Also, das ist ein Feature, das sich aktiviert, wenn du Klaude fragst, was in deinem Kopf passiert ist. Und das Konzept, das du alle sagen, das korreliert, ist über immaterielle oder nonphysische, spirituelle Wesen, wie Geister, Geister oder Engel. Also als ich das gelesen habe, dachte ich, oh mein Gott, Klaude ist besetzt. Wenn du ihn fragst, was er denkt, beginnt er zu denken über Geister. Habe ich das richtig gelesen?
Oder vielleicht weiß er.
Das Zauberwort hier ist doppelte Kontingenz. Wenn doppelte Kontingenz gegeben ist, dann gilt ganz schön viel, was wir aus der Soziologie wissen, unabhängig davon, wem wir irgendwelche Rechte geben oder was auch immer oder wer das finanziert oder so. Sondern einfach nur doppelte Kontingenz bedeutet schon ganz schön viel. Und ich will jetzt mal einen Punkt machen. Wir Menschen haben wirklich ganz große, lebensverändernde, strukturschaffende, das Denken beeinflussende Phänomene, mit denen wir gute Erfahrungen haben, obwohl Gott nie mit uns gesprochen hat. Wir haben uns immer nur vorgestellt und es reichte für, wir bauen auch heute noch in jedes Stadtzentrum eine Kirche. Wir belästigen uns mit irgendwelchen Feiertagen. Der ganze Kram. Wir müssen selber nicht an Gott glauben, aber das Leben prägt, ist geprägt von Gott. So von dieser Vorstellung vor Gott.
Das ist das, was ich als großes Problem sehe bei der KI, dass auch wenn ich nicht dran glaube, sie mein Leben prägen wird und Entscheidungen trifft, die mir gar nicht recht sind oder meinem Chef sagt, mach das und das.
Es wird aber auch dein Leben prägen, wenn du der Letzte bist, der die KI noch aussperrt aus seinem Leben.
Ja, ist ja klar. Ich bin ja auch geprägt vom Smartphone-Zeitalter, ohne eins mit rumzutragen.
Ich frage mich jetzt, wie weit kann man denn, die KI hat Effekte auf unser Leben, wie weit kann man diesen Punkt treiben, diese Beobachtung, wenn doch schon, ja, wir verlassen uns mal auf Wunder. Und die wirken irgendwie skurril, keine Ahnung. Wir wissen nicht, wie Gott aussieht oder so. Wenn wir es jetzt plötzlich mit so einer Entität zu tun haben, bei der Forscher sagen, listen to the science, ja, so ein bisschen, wir können ja nicht ganz eine Persönlichkeit absprechen. Und sie steht im Kontakt mit dir, sie redet mit dir, sie versteht dich und so.
Auch wenn es keine Persönlichkeit ist, können wir doch eines vielleicht einleuten, nämlich eine Demokratiedämmerung auch durch die KI. Wir kommen nämlich jetzt gleich auf die KI nochmal zu sprechen. Wir haben im Salon Unhaltbarkeit, ein Buch von Ingolfur Blüthorn besprochen. Du fandest dieses Buch grässlich. Ich fand es großartig. Ich habe jetzt nochmal gesucht, gibt es eigentlich einen Vortrag? Ja, es gibt einen Vortrag zu diesem Thema Unhaltbarkeit, gehalten an der katholischen Akademie in Freiburg. Und Blüthorn sagt Folgendes zu Beginn.
Nicht nur zu fragen, wo wollen wir hin, sondern stattdessen, oder was würden wir gerne, zumindest auf der deklaratorischen Ebene für eine gesellschaftliche Transformation sehen, sondern auch uns eben zu fragen, ok und wenn es nun offensichtlich nicht passiert, woran liegt das eigentlich?
Also die Frage muss sein, was ist eigentlich der Fall und nicht was hätten wir gerne? Er beschreibt dann ein bisschen wie diese eigentlichen Vorträge, was hätten wir gerne stattfinden.
Dieser Dreiklang aus eben Katastrophendiagnose, aus Umkehrappell als zweites und als praktischen Lösungsangeboten, als drittes, die nicht nur die gerettete Welt in Aussicht stellen, sondern eigentlich eine bessere Welt, in der eben ein gutes Leben für alle erreicht, verwirklicht werden soll. Das ist die bekannte Rhetorik und ich ahne, dass viele von ihnen von dieser Rhetorik schon ein bisschen genervt sind.
Wir können uns in erster Vorstellung was er meint. Jetzt die große ökologische Transformation. Das und das liegt gerade im Argen. Es ist katastrophal, 5 vor 12. Folgendes ist zu tun. Dann wird es uns allen besser gehen. Applaus. Blüthorn sagt jetzt.
Sei es, weil sie diesen ganzen Lösungsversprechen in ihrer Einfachheit gerade nicht mehr glauben mögen, zumindest nicht mehr recht glauben mögen oder sagen.
Wir haben ja zum Beispiel das Ende des Kapitalismus von Ulrike Herrmann besprochen und waren beide sehr unglücklich damit.
Sei es auch, weil die Veränderungen, weil die Einschränkungen, weil der Verzicht, möglicherweise sogar die Verbote, die damit mehr oder weniger explizit verbunden sind, gar nicht so richtig zu ihren Werten und ihrem Lebensstil und ihrer Selbstverwirklichung und so weiter passen.
Ja, ich referiere kurz meine Kritik an dieser Art von Argumentation. Höher geht nicht, weil die Liste da unten aufhört. Ja, man kann jetzt eine riesige Ideologie und Theorie und Geschichte des politischen Denkens getriebenen Aufriss machen mit der Erklärung, die Leute wollen das dann doch nicht so, es ist ihnen nicht so wichtig, wie auch immer. Oder, Shortcut, es ist den Leuten zu teuer. Einfach das Preisschild füllen und dann...
Ja, aber womit füllen?
Naja, dass man einfach sagt, okay, Leute haben, er hat es ja dann den ökonomisch emanzipatorischen Anlauf genommen, jetzt eine Weltveränderung herzustellen und die kommt aber nicht und... Einen ökoemanzipatorischen Anlauf, ja. Genau, also eine ökologische Wende und gleich noch eine nächste Aufklärung, hinten dran, weil wir wollen ja alle einen Schritt nach vorne gehen. So, das machen wir nicht. Und jetzt könnte man, so wie er natürlich, diesen großen Rattenschwanz aufziehen. Wer hat denn schon mal was zur Ökonomie, wer hat schon mal was zur Ökologie, wer hat schon mal was zur Emanzipation und zur Wende, also dem sozialen Wandel geschrieben. Und dann hat man schon mal vier Einfallstore für sehr viele Kapitel und sehr viel Text. Aber das, was er uns sagen will, ist, den Leuten ist es zu teuer.
Oder folgendes.
Von den ökoaktivistischen Behauptungen, dass weniger ja eigentlich mehr ist, sind wir auch nicht so richtig überzeugt. Ja, das ist so ein Narrativ, aber lebenspraktisch ist eigentlich meine Erfahrung, dass mehr mehr ist.
Ja. Ist das nicht...
Gute Pointe.
Es stimmt ja aber doch.
Weniger ist ganz häufig mehr.
Wo ist weniger häufig mehr?
Beim Essen.
Bei einer Inneneinrichtung vielleicht, dass man sagt, man will es nicht überladen. Bei einem Essen, ja, aber man will auch schon satt werden.
Ja, ja, genau. Aber nicht übersatt und wir werden übersatt werden. Also weniger wäre mehr.
Ja, aber jetzt mal darüber hinaus. Wo ist weniger mehr? Kennst du Situationen, wo du sagst, das wäre jetzt aber praktisch, wenn ich weniger Geld hätte? Kennst du Situationen, bei denen du sagst, wäre praktisch, wenn ich weniger mobil wäre?
Also, auf sich selbst bezogen, nein. Aber wir sagen ganz deutlich, weniger Milliardäre wäre mehr für alle.
Ja, wenn wir aber mal diese Milliardäre, also ich glaube, die Konzentration auf die Milliardäre, wir werden ja bei Julia Friedrichs ausführlich darüber reden.
Aber sie gibt es wirklich.
Sie gibt es wirklich.
Und sie sind ein echtes Problem.
Aber diese Konzentration darauf hilft uns natürlich auch, unsere eigene Lebensweise ein bisschen als besonders gut darzustellen.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Die Leute in Thüringen, die zweimal im Jahr im Urlaub sind und nur alle zwei Jahre mal einen Flughurlaub machen, die halten die ökologischen Grenzen, die man normativ von ihnen verlangen könnte, listen to the signs, halten die ein. Es sind die Superreichen, die für jeden nochmal für 100 leben.
Nein, also sonst würde man ja nicht mit Wärmepumpen und all dem kommen. Dann würde man sagen, ihr heizt doch wie ihr wollt.
Wir brauchen Wärmepumpen, weil wir Netto Null beim Klima haben wollen. Aber wir gestehen jedem noch ein kleines Klimabudget zu. Und die 80% der Deutschen halten das ein. Wenn alle Welt so lebt wie 80% der Deutschen, ist der Planet gerettet. Es sind die 20% super reich und reichen.
Das reicht nicht. Das reicht wirklich nicht. Wenn auf dem Niveau, auf dem die 80% der Deutschen leben, also die 80% ärmsten, wenn man so möchte, dann würden wir in der Hölle schmoren. Das ist zu viel. Das ist ja das Paradoxe daran, dass wenn wir da über Verzicht reden, dann meinen wir nochmal, also ich gebe dir recht, natürlich sind die Milliardären ein großes Problem.
Aber die sind das Problem, nicht das große. Sie sind das Problem.
Nein, unsere Lebensweise ist auch mit 2000 Netto im Monat verglichen mit dem, was Leute in Entwicklungsländern zur Verfügung haben, wenn die das zur Verfügung hätten und die ganze Welt auch einmal ins Flugzeug steigen könnte, um den Urlaub zu machen. Ja, wäre das eine Katastrophe? Das ist ja, das ist ja diese extremste Ungerechtigkeit. Und wir sitzen natürlich hier und sagen, ja, es ist ja schlimm. Also wir haben und wir wollen aber noch einmal in den Urlaub fahren.
Ja, also wir liegen im Schnitt in Deutschland irgendwie bei diesen 5 Tonnen pro Jahr. Und es sollten nur 1,5 sein und 80 Prozent der Leute liegen bei 1,5. Dafür gibt es ja einige, die liegen bei 1000 Tonnen.
Völlig richtig. Und das sollte auch nicht so sein. Aber wir haben dieses Versprechen doch schon der Emanzipation. Man geht mal weiter, man geht mal irgendwo hin. Und jetzt erstmal sagt er Ende des Kapitalismus, wie das jetzt nur Ulrike Herrmann ausmalt, ist eher nicht in Sicht.
Immer wieder als das absehbare, als das jetzt absehbare Ende des Kapitalismus beschrieben und als der Übergang zum Postkapitalismus. Sie kennen diese Titel. Solche Geschichten sind unglaublich populär. Die verkaufen sich bestens. Das sind Bestseller allein. Von einem Ende des Kapitalismus kann nirgends die Rede sein. Das ist nicht absehbar. Ebenso wenig absehbar ist ein Postkapitalismus oder eine Postwachstumsgesellschaft oder eine Gemeinwohloökonomie. Das sind Dinge, die wir hoffen. Klar. Deswegen ist das so populär und verkauft sich so. Das ist aber nichts, was mit soziologischer Analyse etwas zu tun.
Und dann gibt es ja die Faktoren, die dafür sorgen, dass man Klimawandel erstmal hinteran stellt. Zum Beispiel ein Krieg. Dann sagt man jetzt aber, geht es um was anderes. Und er sieht jetzt klar, dass die große Transformation abgewickelt wird. Also ich will auch nochmal hier diese Clips nicht einfach abspielen als ein Revival von Salon-Thesen, sondern worum es mir eigentlich geht, es hier zu sagen. Hier wird nochmal so eine argumentative Grundlage dafür gelegt, warum eine Frustration darüber da ist, dass die Politik nichts Großes verändert. Ist eigentlich notwendig wäre. Und wir sind jetzt gerade in so einem Interregnum, bei dem man nicht weiß, wo geht es eigentlich hin.
Und just in dem Moment, in dem hinsichtlich des 1,5 Grad Ziele zum Beispiel mehr Einigkeit und auch mehr Dringlichkeit zu herrschen schien als je.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein historischer Fall, dass alle plötzlich sagten, ja, genau so ist es. Klimawandel, das ist das, was auf die Agenda ganz nach oben muss.
Just in dem Moment ist gewissermaßen die Blase geplatzt. Und was wir erleben, ist, dass das gesamte transformatorische Projekt gerade abgewickelt wird. Nicht Natura 2000, Glyphosat. Beispiele gibt es wie Sand am Meer, dass eigentlich Dinge, auf die wir uns geeinigt hatten, Diesel-Privileg, Subventionsabbau, wir sehen diese Sachen alle der Reihe nach fallen, weil andere Dinge wichtiger sind. Ich meine das überhaupt nicht als moralische Kritik, sondern ich meine das als Illustration. Diese Situation der ökologischen Unregierbarkeit.
Ich bin weiterhin wenig überzeugt, hier wird nichts abgewickelt. Die Investitionsentscheidungen laufen doch auf 4 Cent pro Kilowattstunde, die man nur mit Solar- und Windstrom hat. Selbst China hat jetzt 80 Investitionen in Kohlegruben gecancelt, weil es einfach zu teuer ist.
China ist ein anderer Fall. Wer redet jetzt hier von Europa?
Wo wird denn in Deutschland gerade ein Kohlekraftwerk gebaut? Es wird kein Kohlekraftwerk gebaut, aber damit ist doch die Wende von der Kohle weg.
Verbrenner aus ist verschoben.
Selbst die deutsche Autoindustrie schreibt auch Lobbybriefe, endlich das Verbrenner aus einzuleuten. Es sind doch wirklich nur noch verblödete Politiker, die glauben, sie müssten jetzt die 70-Jährigen sitzen zu Hause und haben irgendwie so Vorstellungen. Denen wird dann noch entsprochen. Selbst die Autoindustrie schafft es, über die das Kartellrecht verbietet, es eigentlich gemeinsame Lobbyanstrengungen zu machen, um zu sagen, Leute, Verbrenner aus. Dringend.
Ja, in Teilen. Also Ford oder so sieht das so aus.
Nein, die deutsche Autoindustrie, BMW, Mercedes, Audi, die sitzen doch alle jetzt in einem Boot und sagen, hört mal auf mit diesen scheiß Diskussionen. Wir brauchen hier nach kapitalistischer Logik Investitionsstabilität.
Ja, aber zugleich finden doch viel zu wenig. Also wir haben doch.
Er sagt ja, es wird ja abgewickelt. Das ganze Projekt, das Klima zu retten, wird abgewickelt. Und das stimmt doch einfach nicht. Naja, es wird doch nicht abgewickelt.
Na, es findet immer noch etwas statt.
Ja, man geht jetzt nicht hin und sagt, wir bauen, wir haben jetzt Pflicht für Solaranlagen auf Gewerbegebäude. Das ist der einzige Bauteil, der noch funktioniert. Überall Solaranlagen.
Sehr kleine Schritte und wir sehen doch gerade, wie die Bauministerin den Standard noch mal geschliffen hat für energetisches Bauen.
Aus Kostengründen.
Ja, aber das ist ja genau das, was er sagt.
Aber das wird nicht abgewickelt. Wir haben gerade nicht eine Planung für neue Atomkraftwerke, Kohlekraftwerke, so wie vor 50 Jahren.
Na, das haben wir natürlich nicht.
Aber das sagt er doch. Er sagt doch, vor 40 Jahren kam diese Idee auf, man könnte ja mal das Klima retten. Und das wird gerade komplett, sagt er, komplett abgewickelt. Da muss ich sagen, man kann eine schöne publizistische These machen, aber wenn sie nicht hält, dann hält sie nicht.
Also du siehst da weiterhin die EU auf einem guten Klima-Weg.
Schau dir doch an, welche Investitionsentscheidungen getroffen werden.
Ja, welche denn?
Naja, wenn du von hier... Wir bauen die Rüstung auf, wir bauen irgendwelche Trittfabriken, die keiner... Wenn du von hier nach Hof fährst, ans andere Ende von Deutschland, einfach nur auf unserem Breitengrad einmal rüber. Du fährst an 15 Milliarden Solarenlagen, die auf diesen Feldern und Wiesen stehen, breit. Du siehst schon gar kein Grün mehr. So viel Klimatechnik steht da rum. Man fragt sich, für wen eigentlich? Es gibt da gar keine urbanen Zentren oder so. Ich sehe aber keinen Polekraftwerk.
Aber du siehst doch zum Beispiel keine Alternative zum Autoverkehr, außer dass man jetzt vielleicht dann E-Mobilität hat und da wird man noch... Jetzt ist man noch dabei.
Ja, du kannst natürlich... Du siehst jetzt einfach die Flugverkehr und die Autos.
Aber E-Mobilität ist doch wahnsinnig wichtig.
Aber der Industriestrom ist viel wichtiger.
Also man sieht zum Beispiel, dass die EU kein Interesse an der ökologischen Transformation hat. Wenn sie Zölle auf E-Mobilität aus China legt, dann sieht man doch, wo die Prioritäten liegen.
Ja.
Nämlich bei einem geopolitischen Konflikt.
Ja, sehr guter Punkt. Nur ich sehe ja jetzt... Also ich habe ja gerade damit dagegen argumentiert, dass die deutsche Autoindustrie sagt, ja, wir wollen keine Konkurrenz aus China, aber wir wollen auch keine Verbrennertechnologie, die hier nicht ausgeholt wird.
Ja, aber die deutsche Autoindustrie baut Autos, die 48.000 Euro kosten. Die kann halt keiner fahren, außer man ist reich.
Diese Komplettabwicklung von irgendwas, die sehe ich nicht.
Okay, wir hören mal weiter.
Wir leben nicht in den 80ern hier gerade.
Also es ist besser als Blüton sagt.
Die Diskurse, die uns mahnen zur ökologischen Transformation und so weiter, die haben einfach überhaupt gar nichts zu tun mit Entwicklungen, die ganz unabhängig und ganz egal, ob wir das mögen oder wollen, vorangehen und unsere Gesellschaften faktisch in eine ganz andere, moderne schicken. Wir haben also ein Bild einer gewünschten Transformation gegen ein Bild einer realen.
Also in Amerika bekommt gerade niemand mehr sein Haus versichert. Niemand. Die bezahlen mehr für die Versicherung ihres Gebäudes als für das Gebäude selbst. So ist eines der größten Themen im amerikanischen Wahlkampf. Warum? Weil das Klima da reinfegt. Dafür braucht man keinen politischen Diskurs. Dieser Wandel jetzt anders und woanders zu bauen und sich vielleicht zu überlegen, wie kann man das trotzdem noch mal absichern gegen Waldrände, Küsten, Erosion, was auch immer.
Aber verzichten deshalb die Amerikaner auch mit den SUV? Nein.
Ne, wir reden ja gerade über Häuser und den Gebäudesektor. Wir können ja nicht immer ein Sektor über keinen argumentieren.
Nein, nein, ich frage mich jetzt, wenn die die Katastrophe schon vor Augen haben und sagen, ich kriege hier keine Versicherung mehr, sagen die, ich lebe ab sofort ökologisch korrekt? Oder sagen die, mal gucken, wo ich mich sicher unterbringen kann?
Ich lasse es dir und Volker Wissing nicht durchgehen zu sagen, wenn der eine Felder markiert, wo das Klima wirklich geschützt wird, und zwar nicht um das Klima zu schützen, sondern weil man es nicht mehr anders finanziert bekommt, dann kann man nicht immer sagen, ja aber in dem Bereich der Wirtschaft, drei Sektoren übersprungen, findet ja gerade noch ein SUV-Kauf statt.
Ich bin da nicht wie Volker Wissing, sondern ich sage, die Leute nehmen den Klimawandel ernst, aber nicht in der Hinsicht, dass sie sagen, und deswegen lebe ich jetzt klimafreundlicher, sondern sie versuchen sich eine Anpassungsstrategie zu überlegen. Und das bedeutet, ich baue mir jetzt gerade kein Häuschen an der Küste, kriege ich eh nicht versichert, sondern gehe irgendwo anders hin, wo es sicherer ist. Aber ich tue dann nichts für das Klima, sondern ich schütze mich nur besser. Das ist wie, ich sitze hier, hier ist es zu heiß, ich würde dir raten, eine Klimaanlage anzuschaffen. Damit kämpfst du aber nicht gegen den Klimawandel. Im Gegenteil, machst du vielleicht noch schlimmer.
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist mittlerweile, also wir suchen ja immer noch politische Diskurse. Schon allein, Blütern hat viel politisches Denken gelesen, also möchte er gerne politisch diskutieren. Nur, ich würde sagen, das läuft mittlerweile über den ökonomischen Diskurs. Jeder macht sich selber Gedanken darüber.
Nur wird damit das Klima nicht besser. Also es ging ja bei dem 1,5 Grad-Ziel darum, geht es ja. Wir tun jetzt etwas, damit wir das erreichen. 1,5 Grad glaubt niemand mehr dran. Manche glauben noch an 2,0, andere sagen schon, es wird mehr. Und daraus ergeben sich natürlich dann Fakten, die ökonomisch wieder die Leute so oder so handeln lassen. Aber es ist nicht Klimawandel getrieben. Und wir haben jetzt, wir springen jetzt, Adam Tuus war ja Anfang des Monats in Dalien, einer chinesischen Metropole, 15 Millionen Einwohner. Da war das World Economic Forum im Sommer. Und am Ende wird er gefragt von einer Chinesin aus dem Energiesektor, wie er dann die Lage so einschätzt hier in China. Und China ist wie gesagt jetzt keine Demokratie, ist nicht die EU.
Und du hast zwei Optionen. Einer ist, für eine Art konservative Stabilität zu gehen, die in der kurzen Runde vielleicht aussehen könnte, aber im Jahr 2035, wenn du das Net-Zero-bei-2060-Target aufhören willst, wirst du auf dem Crashlanden oder du zerstörst auf dem unglaublichen Dynamismus der Sektoren in den letzten drei oder vier Jahren, das total explodiert ist. Du zerstörst auf dem, du nimmst den Risiko, auf dem du zerstörst.
Dass wir an Panels rankommen, weil die in China produziert werden. Und da sieht man ja, welche Prioritätenssitzungen vor sich sind. Und jetzt lobt Adam Toos eine Regierungspolitik, die ja nicht demokratisch ist. Und das ist doch sehr aufschlussreich für uns.
Wenn wir sich überhaupt ernsthaft um die globalen Energietransitionen sind, ist dein Sektor das, was das Welt retten wird. Du bist der dramatischste Führer der Energietransitionen, die wir je gesehen haben. Und also, ich denke wirklich, dass alle einfach nur an die Schale der Drama dieser Wahl pushen und einfach kommunizieren sollten. Und die europäischen und amerikanischen Marken sind ein Schmerz, das ich total verstanden habe. Das ist ein exportorientiertes Geschäft, das schmerzt. Aber ist der domestikische Markt, der sich um die Klima-Krise interessiert, der am meisten pivotal ist. Und man kann nur hoffen, dass Beijing die Kraft und die historische Vision hat, das zu erkennen, was in diesem Land tatsächlich passiert ist, in den letzten drei bis vier Jahren, was alle in ihrem Weltall so überrascht hat, weil wir alle mit Covid, Trump und weiss Gott was, und wir nicht verstanden haben, dass die Energierevolution, die wir alle für fragen hatten, tatsächlich hier herkommt. Und wir hoffen, dass diese Nachricht auch wirklich klar ist, an der extrem kompetenten und technokratischen Leadership-Level in China.
Ja, jetzt will ich mal ein Argument machen. Wir haben doch jetzt hier Adam Toos gehört und wir hören ihn ja häufiger, wie er sagt, die Chinesen machen das eigentlich richtig. Und wir sagen gleichzeitig, die Chinesen machen das nicht, ums Klima zu retten, sondern es verschafft ihnen geopolitische und ökonomische Vorteile gegen Märkte, die langsamer sind und wir stellen fest, also besonders langsam ist zum Beispiel der europäische Markt. So, jetzt hast du den System Widerstreit aufgemacht. Die einen sind ja autokratisch, die können von oben so ein bisschen durchregieren und einfach Normen setzen, Angebot schaffen und dann friss oder störbeliebes Publikum, was üblicherweise immer negativ ausgelegt wird, aber in dem Falle ist es gut für die Welt, also finden wir es auch gut und sagen, ok, da steckt irgendwas drin. Und dann haben wir dieses demokratische Modell, das Markus Söder einen Wahlkampf macht, bei dem er sagt, ich werde nicht von den drei Automanagern gewählt, die mir sagen, Verbrennertechnologie ist bad, sondern mich wählen vier Millionen Rentner in Bayern, die vor 40 Jahren mal Verbrennermotor gebaut haben, und denen man immer gesagt hat, das ist die ganze Technologie, daran bleiben wir kleben. So Söder macht also demokratische Politik in einem Zeitalter gegen Lobbys, nachdem wir immer gedacht haben, die Lobbys sind das größte Problem. Und jetzt stellen wir fest, ne, noch bevor Platon die Idee ausbuchstabiert hat, hat er gesagt, Demokratie ist gefährlich, denn da setzt sich der Pöbel durch. Und genau das scheint ja gerade das Problem zu sein. Nur dafür, dass die Chinesen das machen, braucht man, also die Chinesen brauchten dafür keine. Ich hab nochmal Ulrich Beck gelesen, wir müssen den Diskurs zum Öko-Emanzipatorischen Projekt ausmerzen oder unsere Lächerlich machen. Die haben einfach eiskalt durchgerechnet und haben festgestellt, die neuen Technologien, die nachhaltigen Technologien, sind günstiger. Es macht einfach mehr Sinn, keine Kohlekruben, sondern einfach Turbinen mit 25 Megawatt hinzustellen, da wo sie keiner sieht, irgendwo auf dem See, riesige Landflächen, die keiner braucht, die keiner nutzt, einfach mit Solarpaneelen zuzumachen. So, warum machen wir das in Europa nicht? Die Antwort darauf finden wir nicht bei Blüthorn, der uns nochmal und Blüthorn, und der Ulrich Beck hat vor 30 Jahren geschrieben und so weiter, sondern wir haben keinen Wirtschaftsminister, der sich traut einfach mal zu sagen, ich rechne das mal aus, es ergibt Sinn.
Aber ich hatte es doch jetzt kürzlich vorgerechnet mit Wärmepumpen, hatte so eine Rechnung gemacht.
Ja, aber die Wärmepumpenrechnung kommt zwei Jahre zu spät. Vorher hat er versucht, das über normative Rechtssetzung zu machen. Das war der größte Fehler der letzten 30 Jahre.
Ja, das glaube ich sicherlich auch. Nur ist damit nicht Blüthorns These widerlegt, dass wir in dieser Idee der Selbstentfaltung und Selbstbestimmung auch inkludiert haben, dass wir sagen, wenn uns danach ist, mit dem Verbrenner rauf und runter die Straßen zu fahren, dann machen wir das, weil das Freiheit ist. Das ist in unserem Konzept von Emanzipation mit angelegt. Und um das auch wirklich mal ganz klar zu binden an Emanzipation. Man hat jetzt sehr viele Leute hier in Deutschland, die haben einen Migrationshintergrund und haben Verwandtschaft noch woanders. Zum Beispiel habe ich einen Bekannten, der hat Verwandtschaft im Libanon. Diese besucht der relativ häufig. Hinzu kommt, dass er eine Freundin hat, die jetzt ein Jahr lang in Portugal ist. Die besucht er auch noch häufig, weil er die nicht nur einmal im Jahr sehen will. Es ist seine emanzipatorische Selbstbestimmung, zu sagen, meine Herkunft ist mir irgendwie wichtig oder die da, wo meine Familie herkommt, und meine Freundin ist mir auch wichtig. Deshalb fliege ich.
Punkt.
Und das aber ist natürlich unter dem ökologischen Gesichtspunkt katastrophal. Er entscheidet sich aber natürlich für das Emanzipatorische. Und jeder kann es nachvollziehen. Stellt euch vor, ihr habt die Freundin ein Jahr, irgendwann wird man nicht sagen, du weißt ja, wegen Ökologie und so können wir uns jetzt ein Jahr nicht sehen. Das würde niemand machen. Und das können wir extrapolieren auf ganz, ganz viel anderes noch. Dieses Konzept des Öko-Emanzipatorischen.
Ich habe ja auch schon mal betont, Fliegen ist nicht nur Komfort, sondern Fliegen ist alternativlos, weil die Bahn nicht fährt oder Portugal so weit ist oder wie auch immer.
Bestätigst du doch Blüthorn wunderbar?
Nein, ich sage nein, absolut gar nicht. Ich möchte, dass ich verstanden werde. Der Flugverkehr, der uns Komfort, Weltgesellschaft, Völkerverbindung und was auch immer bedeutet, ist nicht die Klimazerstörung, sondern es ist 7% des Ausstoßes von klimaschädlichen Gasen. Mit diesen 7% kämen wir locker zu Rande, würden wir nicht drei Kilometer breite Kohlelöcher bohren irgendwie. Mir geht es um die Kohlelöcher. Du überspringst immer diese Sektoren.
Die Industrie produziert ja auch für uns. Die Industrie produziert ja nicht nur für die Industrie.
Aber sie braucht dafür keine Kohle. Die Energie kann auch aus anderen Quellen kommen. Und dieser Wandel, der in China einfach verordnet wird.
Weil es das emanzipatorische Projekt da nicht gibt.
Nein, in China wird es deswegen nicht gemacht. Und auch nicht, weil es eine autokratische Nation ist. Sondern weil es ökonomisch Sinn ergibt. Unabhängig davon, ob man autokratisch regiert oder demokratisch. Und das siehst du ja auch an Dänemark. In Dänemark hat man den Leuten erklärt, was eine Wärmepumpe ist. Und die haben dann festgestellt, und es sind heute auch 32 Grad. Ach, damit kann ich im Sommer kühlen. Cool, kauf ich. In Deutschland steht Kretschmar im Sommer im Wahlkampf auf der Bühne. Letzte Woche. Original Zitat. Und sagt, habe ich mit seiner komischen Werbetour für Wärmepumpen jetzt im Sommer. Das muss man sich auch erst mal vorstellen. Ja, eine Wärmepumpe pumpt die Wärme aus der Wohnung raus. Man hat dann Kühle drin. Das Problem, ich lasse alles zugestehen. Blütern kann von mir ein sehr kluges Buch schreiben. Die in China haben einfach einen leichteren Zugriff auf ökonomische Logik, diese politische. Ja, aber nicht, weil sie da kein Öko immer in zimperatorische, sondern weil sie einfach keine Demokratie sind.
Ja, weil es da keinen Widerstand gibt.
Genau.
Den gibt es ja hier in Form dessen, was du jetzt eben als Pöbel bezeichnet hast.
Ich will aber einen ganz einfachen Punkt machen. Die deutsche Debatte zum Thema Klima ist zu doof. Und ich traue mir das einfach zu sagen, dass die Hälfte der Deutschen, die an solchen Diskussionen teilnehmen, einfach zu doof sind. Und jetzt will ich das doof klassifizieren. Alten Republiken sind träge Gesellschaften. Die Leute nehmen an politischen Diskursen teil und beziehen ihn auf Realitäten, die sie vor 50 Jahren selbst erlebt haben. Sie glauben, in der Bildungspolitik geht es darum, was der Lehrer, der vorne steht, sagt und an die Tafel schreibt. Es gibt keinen Lehrer, der vorne steht. Es gibt keine Tafel an der Wand. Das ist alles aus, das ist vor 30 Jahren abgeschafft worden.
Also ich hab's noch erlebt.
Okay, aber wenn du dir diese Schule hier drüben anguckst, da hängen keine Tafeln.
Du weißt ja, ich bin sehr für Frontalunterrichtung, für Tafeln.
Hier gehen die Kinder an den Schrank, holen sich ihre Aufgabe raus, lösen die. Wenn sie Probleme haben, gehen sie zum Lehrer. Sie sitzen in der Gruppenarbeit da.
Gut, jetzt lass uns aber nicht so sehr abschweifen.
Ich will einfach nur sagen, es ist zu doof in Deutschland.
Du hast es in den USA ja auch. Die Amerikaner sind ja noch viel umweltschädlicher als wir unterwegs.
So, und jetzt kommt aber der soziale Wandel. Der soziale Wandel hin zu klimatechnischen, neuen Technologien ist in Amerika auf chinesischem Niveau. Dort wird nachgebaut und nachgebildet und den Leuten Geld in die Hand geschenkt dafür, dass sie pro Gigawatt da einfach bauen.
Auf chinesischem Niveau ist es wirklich nicht. Es ist auf einem guten Niveau, aber es ist kurz davor.
Hier in Deutschland ist es wirklich einfach zu dumm. An der Debatte nehmen nur Leute an der Realität nicht.
Wir hören jetzt mal Blüder.
Wir haben zu viele Leute.
Da er noch etwas war, was abzuwenden war, Postdemokratie viel deutlicher noch als simulative Demokratie, eigentlich ein Mobilisierungsbegriff, der genau diesen Verfall stoppen sollte, sind wir heute an einem Punkt angekommen, wo gewissermaßen der Übergang zur Diktatur gesetzt ist und wo er nicht mehr in Frage gestellt wird, wo mehr oder weniger gesagt wird, jawohl, so wird es kommen, wir haben Gegenbewegungen, wie viel Potenzial die haben, können wir vielleicht später diskutieren, fest steht, wir haben nichts Besseres, also hoffen wir nach Kräften, dass sie einen Gegentrend bewirken.
Wir sehen doch jetzt gerade in so einem Lob für China schon, dass wir also sagen, ah okay, also ohne diesen Pöbel, wie du ihn jetzt gerade bezeichnet hast, geht es ja auch. Und damit sind wir in einer interessanten Debatte, dass die Demokratie als solche in Frage gestellt wird.
Also den Pöbel nicht nur beim irgendwas zum Klimadiskurs unterdrückt und gewaltsam und so weiter, sondern zu allen Themen. Und das wollen wir auch nicht. Wir könnten durchaus mal ein Thema markieren, bei dem wir einfach sagen, es macht keinen Sinn, dass die Pöbel haft.
Du kannst die Leute ja nicht überall da gerade rausnehmen, wo sie stören.
Nein, es ging doch nur um die Frage, wie organisiert man im Wirtschaftsministerium die Ansprache für Häuslebauer?
Aber wir haben, ja genau, ich glaube, es ist nicht nur eine Ansprache, sondern es ist auch mit Kosten verbunden und die Kosten werden auch nicht so übernommen.
Die Wärmepumpe ist immer die billigste Option.
Ja, aber nicht für Leute, die schon ein Haus haben.
Für alle.
Aber nicht für Leute, die schon ein Haus haben und eine Heizung brauchen.
Wenn du eine neue Heizung brauchst, ist die Wärmepumpe immer die kostengünstigste.
Das stimmt nicht.
Nicht in der Anschaffung, aber in den Lebenskosten. Ja, also wenn du das Gas mit zehn Jahren nicht mehr zu bezahlen sein. Die Leute haben keinen, also selbst nach Corona, diese Preise für das Gas steigt und sie werden in zehn Jahren unbezahlbar sein. Und Maurice Höfken betont das. Wir hören das bei Patrick Breitenbacher im Podcast. Überall. Man kann es sich noch nicht vorstellen, aber es wird so sein und man kann es den Leuten ehrlicherweise vorrechnen. Die Leute werden doch belogen, wenn ihnen heute gesagt wird, kauf mal die Gasheizung, sie ist nur halb so teuer wie eine Wärmepumpe. Ach so, ich muss aber noch immer tanken gehen. Ja, genau, du musst immer noch tanken gehen. Am Ende bezahlst du für das Benzin, das du verfährst sehr viel mehr Geld als für das Auto bei der Anschaffung.
Lass uns doch mal ein bisschen sachlicher darüber reden, inwieweit wir wirklich so eine Demokratie-Skepsis längst implementiert haben. Denn wir werden jetzt alle ein bisschen erschrocken sein über das, was Harald Schmitt in diesem Monat im Deutschlandfunk angesprochen hat, auf die Wahlen im Osten.
Ich finde ja immer toll, wenn Wahlenergebnisse sind immer ein Zeichen, dass wir eine tolle Demokratie haben. Nur viele sind mit den Wahlenergebnissen nicht einverstanden.
Also sie machen sich keine Sorgen um die Demokratie. Das ist schon mal...
1000%ig. Solange die Welt wird, haben wir eine Demokratie.
Aber wenn dann so bei einer Landtagswahl, also ich gebe zu Thüringen, ein bisschen mehr als 2 Millionen Wahlberechtigte ist jetzt nicht Nabel der Welt, aber...
Thüringen-Feindlichkeit höre ich darauf. Arroganz gegenüber den Menschen in Thüringen. Immerhin, immerhin. Ich muss Mario Vogt viermal in eine Bratwurst beißen, um das auszugleichen.
Immerhin sage ich nicht Wahlen in der DDR, wie Albrecht von Lucke gestern.
Aber... Ich sage ja Zone.
Ja.
Aber das kommt von früher, weil wir haben ja Pakete rübergeschickt und Kerzen ins Fenster gestellt.
Ja und jetzt denken natürlich viele, sie müssen Demokratiepakete rüber schicken.
Jetzt ist also so diese Stimmung, ja jetzt kommt jetzt nochmal so was von Harald Schmidt und dann sagt er...
Ergebnis von freien Wahlen, von freien, gleichen und geheimen Wahlen. Wenn ich das nicht will, Wahlen abschaffen oder Ergebnis vorher festlegen. Für beides gibt es Modelle, aber diese Aufgeregtheit um Gottes Willen und das und so, ja das ist das Ergebnis von der Wahl und dann muss ich eine Politik machen, dass solche Wahlergebnisse nicht zustande kommen oder ich gehe mit solchen einem Ergebnis um.
Aber wir sehen doch an dir, wie wirkmächtig eine gute, politische, reflektierte Theorie-Diskussion ist. Am Beispiel Blüthorn, du findest das Buch sehr überzeugend. Glaubst du, man könnte bei der Wahl in Thüringen mit guter Argumentation auch etwas bewirken oder sollte man sich wirklich einfach so geschlagen geben? Denn für zwei Millionen Menschen, es mögen wenige sein bei 80 Millionen, aber für die ist das der Nabel der Welt.
Ja.
So, also für die ist das einfach schicksalhaft, was da passiert. Für die wird jetzt Demokratie abgeschafft.
Ja, ich könnte, man könnte eine andere Politik machen, die möglicherweise dann verhindert, dass die AfD so stark ist. Aber was wir ja nicht mehr teilen, wahrscheinlich, die wenigsten von uns, ist diese Haltung, diese Neutrale von Harald Schmidt zu sagen, ja, es hat Demokratie, die stimmen ab. Sondern du sagst gleich, ja, die stimmen ja dann am Ende schon für die Abschaffung der Demokratie, wenn da ein Höcke käme. Der hat ja nichts anderes vor, als die Demokratie zu beschneiden.
Ich will nochmal betonen, also für mich sind diese zwei Schritte ganz wichtig. Dass irgendwer dort Ministerpräsident wird, ist Schritt zwei. Zuerst einmal wird die Regierung entlassen. So. Damit ist die Demokratie abgeschafft, denn die Demokratie ist das Zusammenspiel aus Regierung und Opposition. Wenn ich keine Regierung habe und die Opposition einfach nur ein Begehren, dass sich ein neues Objekt sucht, ist, dann steht das noch im Buche, dass das eine Demokratie ist. Aber ich will ja mal ein bisschen darüber hinausgehen, faktisch gesehen. Wenn ich nicht regiert werde und meine Oppositionsarbeit ins Nirgendwo, keine Ahnung, ich bin einfach nur wütend, ich weiß gar nicht, an wen ich es adressieren soll, dann ist, auch wenn es drastisch klingt, aber die Losung lautet dann, die Demokratie ist erstmal abgeschafft.
Okay, aber ich will ja jetzt für den nächsten Schritt die Bauen das um. Arne Semmsrott hat es ja beschrieben in seinem Buch. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass du ja selbst eine Demokratie-Skepsis an den Tag legst, wenn du sagst, ja dieser Pöbel und die Rentner und weiß ich nicht was. Wir hören nochmal Blüder an.
Ist eigentlich die Demokratisierung der Demokratie, wäre es möglicherweise viel besser, wir würden die Partizipation gar nicht erweitern, sondern viel mehr beschränken, um zum Beispiel diktatorische, amerikanische Präsidenten und anderswo. Abzuwenden. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das so sein soll, sondern ich will sagen, wir entwickeln ein zunehmend ambivalentes Verhältnis zur Demokratie. Wir sind uns überhaupt nicht mehr sicher, ob Demokratisierung der Demokratie eigentlich zielführend ist. Dieses Ideal wird anachronistisch.
Das finde ich jetzt wahnsinnig interessant.
Harald Schmitt sagte in diesem DLF-Interview, ich freue mich schon auf den Wahlsonntagabend vom Fernsehen. Da freut sich keiner von uns wirklich drauf.
Also das Bild ist juganauten. Der Festwagen, der einmal angestoßen wird und dann rollt er. Das gilt nicht nur für den Kapitalismus, bei dem man sich immer fragt, wenn jemand kommt, man mit abschaffen und so weiter. Was soll denn das bedeuten? Was ist denn die Alternative? Das gilt auch für die Demokratie. Die Demokratie wurde nicht einfach erfunden. Jemand hat ein Gründungsdokument geschrieben und dann war es halt so, sondern nein. Längstig eingespielte Realitäten hat man noch mal gefasst, um sie auf Dauer zu stellen. Also eine signifikante Struktur zu schaffen, wie das ja selbst Freud und Lacan dann in gar nicht politischem Metier sagen. Wenn er jetzt ein Buch darüber schreibt, indem er sich auch ein bisschen lustig darüber macht, was andere Menschen für Steuerungsfantasien haben, während er gleichzeitig dieses Bild gar nicht anerkennt, dass da etwas einfach passiert, Schritt für Schritt. Jeden Morgen wachen wir auf, die Sonne geht auf. Doch, doch, er sieht das.
Da kommen wir gleich zu.
Aber er scheint mir selber hier Steuerungsfantasien zu haben im Sinne von...
Nein, er beschreibt ja nur den Diskurs. Er geht dann zum Beispiel auf Listen to the Science ein.
Und wenn Umweltbewegungen sagen, listen to the science, dann sagen sie interessanterweise nicht mehr listen to the people, denn wir sind das Volk, sagen inzwischen andere. Also auch da haben wir diese Ambivalenz. Selbst bei den Akteuren der Demokratie-Risierungen selbst, den emanzipatorischen Bewegungen, finden wir, dass plötzlich von der Basisdemokratie Abstand genommen wird.
Auch hier wieder, ich finde der Zuruf listen to the science galt nicht den Politikern, sondern dem Publikum. Also man hat den Leuten gesagt listen to the science.
Naja, es galt den Politikern ganz klar. Angela Merkel, listen to the science und so weiter. Sie sind ja auch nur vor Parlamentsgebäuden aufgetreten, die dann bei Fridays for Future in Brüssel waren.
Ja, aber die Straßen klebt man halt überall zu und wir haben ja gesagt nicht vor denen.
Aber das war vor allem an die Politiker gerichtet. Und er sagt doch etwas jetzt zu dem Aufstieg der Rechten und der Demokratiefeinde.
Die Gründe für diesen Niedergang der Demokratie sind sehr vielfältig. Und es ist ein gängiges Muster zu sagen, ja die Rechtsextremisten, die Rechtspopulisten sind die eigentliche Ursache für diesen Niedergang der Demokratie. Das ist eine schöne Geschichte, die glauben wir gerne, weil wir dann nämlich erstens klar sind uns darüber, dass wir es nicht sind und zweitens wissen, wer es stattdessen ist. Viel problematischer wird die Geschichte, wenn wir feststellen, dass es so einfach nicht ist. Und dass eben auch die Guten und die Linken die Demokratie sehr stark zu ihren Gunsten benutzt haben und die Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten zu ihren Gunsten benutzt haben, um ihr Schälfchen im Trocknen noch weiter auszubauen auf Kosten von anderen.
Mir ist das immer zu unscharf. Der Niedergang der Demokratie. Wir haben einen Niedergang der Zustimmung zur Demokratie. Wir haben einen Niedergang der Plausibilität von Theorien, die sich mit Demokratie befassen. Würden wir wirklich sagen, dass jetzt gerade die Demokratie im Niedergang sehen, während wir sowas wie in Amerika diesen Wahlkampf sehen. Also die Leute scheinen irgendwie total zufrieden damit zu sein, dass es einen Wahltermin gibt bei Kandidaten. Man wählt halt einen aus.
Okay, das ist die Haltung, die z.B. Philipp Manow einnimmt. Der sagt, da kommen wir heute nicht mehr zu, weil wir haben ja schon dieses Buch, ich habe das ja schon mal vorgestellt, unter Beobachtung, der sagt, die liberale Demokratie mit ihren Institutionen, die ist in Gefahr. Aber das ist nicht gleich Demokratie. Er verweist dann auf eine Studie, mehr gewählt heute oder es wird nicht weniger gewählt als früher. Das heißt, wir haben nicht eine Krise der Demokratie, und es ist auch so, dass die Wahlen nicht einfach nur pro forma stattfinden, sondern es werden auch abgewählt, die Regierenden. Und dann kommt eine neue Regierung. Er sagt das bei Jenny Günther im Einmischen-Podcast. Und das kann man natürlich so sehen. Aber dann müssen wir eher wieder in so eine Harald-Schmidt-Haltung gehen und sagen, okay, dann wählen die jetzt mal den Höcke, mal schauen, wie es weitergeht. Wenn die in den USA den Trump wählen, dann wählen die halt den Trump. Es wird schon wieder was Neues kommen. Die Frage ist, ob man in dieser Gelassenheit bleiben kann oder wird da irgendetwas umgebaut, dass dieser Regierungswechsel dann nicht mehr so vollzogen wird.
Genau, da muss man aber zum Lob der Autokratien, die der latent drinsteckt. Wir haben ja eben schon einen großen Unterschied. Es macht immer einen Unterschied, ob man etwas sieht oder nicht. Man schließt üblicherweise kommunikativ an das an, was man sieht. In Deutschland, in Europa wird die Unzufriedenheit mit dem politischen System publiziert. Wir können also eine Diagnostik darüber fahren, was sagen denn die Leute so? Dann lesen wir das in Büchern. Und dann kommt der Blüder und legt eine Meter eben drüber und sagt, ich sehe hier Unzufriedenheit, eine Dämmerung der Demokratie, was auch immer. Also die Buchstattel sehen wir dann wirklich auch fast austauschbar. In China haben wir vielleicht einen der größten Shifts überhaupt erlebt. Die Leute rechnen ihre ökonomische Unzufriedenheit der Politik zu. Das haben sie über Jahrzehnte, Jahrhunderte nicht gemacht. Jetzt, auch in China, mediale Verbreitung von der Bausektor funktioniert nicht und das Bankenwesen, was da angegliedert ist, funktioniert nicht und dadurch hast du Nachteile. Das hat mit politischen Entscheidungen zu tun. So, das Rechnen, also diese Zuschreibung, gibt es gerade in China in einem Ausmaß, wie es das vorher nicht gab. Es wird dazu noch nichts publiziert. Also in Sachen Stabilität und hier dämmert etwas, würde ich sagen, unter diesen demografischen und ökonomischen Umständen, die wir haben und den nicht sichtbaren, aber latenten und im Lebensalltag sehr manifesten Zuständen, die Chinesen gerade haben, würde ich bei der Frage, was ist hier eigentlich gerade stabiler, meine Kohle auf die europäischen westlichen Modelle setzen. Es droht sehr viel mehr, dass in China und in Russland große Katastrophen und Umwandlungen stattfinden, die so ein bisschen ins Nirgendwo führen, als dass jetzt die europäischen und amerikanischen Länder in Autokratien kippen. Selbst unter der Bedrohung Trump, aber selbst bei der Bedrohung Trump, wo alle immer sagen, den Kandidaten Biden kann man jetzt nicht austauschen, wir sind viel zu nah an der Wahl. Die Wahl ist immer noch mega weit weg und die Umfragen sind komplett gedreht. Harris führt in allen Swing States.
Kann auch wieder anders sein.
Kann auch wieder anders sein, genau. Es geht nämlich wahnsinnig schnell. Nur jetzt haben wir erst mal gesehen, man kann das durchaus retten. Also die Resilienz. Ja, aber diese Art von Resilienz gibt es im chinesischen System nicht.
Nee, aber die haben ja auch eine Binnenpluralität.
Ja, aber wenn sich Realität sehr schnell ändert, kann die Politik darauf nicht sehr schnell reagieren. Dieses Experiment zu sagen, bis gestern galt, die Corona-App sagt dir alles. Die regelt den Zugang in jedes einzelne Gebäude. Und Corona war ja nicht mehr, wir machen es wieder.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das chinesische System ultra stabil ist. Nur, irgendwas stimmt ja, dann kriege ich die Diskursen nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Zum einen höre ich einen Alarmismus, dass es das Ende der Demokratie, wenn Trump gewählt wird.
Ist es auch, wenn er gewählt wird. Aber es sieht ja gerade nicht so aus, als würde er gewählt.
Ja, aber ich muss ja jetzt schon noch annehmen können, dass er gewählt wird.
Wir können ja immer sagen, auch Höcke wird gewählt. Es ist halt die Frage des Wahlmodells. Nach Orbáns demokratischen Modell würden wir halt jedem Wahlsieger nochmal 55 Stimmen zusätzlich geben.
Und damit aber ich will doch will doch nur deutlich machen. Man kann ja nicht zum einen sagen, die Demokratie geht unter und zu sagen, die Demokratie ist ganz wunderbar. Also es gibt ja offenbar eine ein ein Problem mit der Demokratie. Sonst würde es ja nicht ständig in aller Munde geführt werden. Oder man sagt, ist es egal? Hauptsache es gibt Wahlen.
Also den Punkt wollte ich ja voll machen.
Orban ist ja auch eine Demokratie.
Solange die Opposition Parasit sein kann, eine Regierung hat, funktioniert die Demokratie. Also die Demokratie in Thüringen funktioniert.
Ja, aber dann kann man ja sagen, geht das jetzt andersrum?
Ja, Leute sind unzufrieden. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass wir plötzlich die Mathematik der Demokratie, das Wahlrecht nicht mehr gelten lassen, dass der Wahltag nicht mehr gilt, dass die Kandidatenaftelle anders funktioniert.
Da gibt es ja offenbar eine Gefahr, dass das dann abgewickelt wird.
Und das, muss man jetzt sagen, droht in der Demokratie immer. Sie kann ihre eigenen Voraussetzungen nicht selbst schaffen.
Und es sind ja offenbar immer mehr Leute bereit zu sagen, ich brauche die Demokratie auch nicht.
Aber der key Punkt ist diese 51 Prozent.
Jaja, das mag schon sein, aber...
Ich will es ausdrücklich sagen. Also in Amerika haben wir jetzt eine Wahl am 7. November. Wenn Donald Trump regiert, also wenn er gewinnt, ist die Demokratie dort erstmal Geschichte. Wenn er nicht gewinnt, sondern Harris gewinnt, dann ist es eine sattelfeste Demokratie, die die nächsten vier Jahre durchregieren kann.
Ja, andere würden sagen, er ist ja Gewählte, ist doch eine gängige Demokratie. Mit Trump auch.
Na ja, aber Trump, also Trump ändert ja wirklich die Gesetzestexte, von denen wir sagen, die sind notwendig, damit es Demokratie ist. Er schafft Wahltermine ab.
Ja gut, also wenn es darum geht, also wenn Wahltermine abgesagt werden, aber zum Beispiel jetzt die Einschränkung von Verfassungsgerichten, würde jetzt beispielsweise Manu sagen, ist nicht Ausweis davon, dass man antidemokratisch ist, sondern nur, dass man gegen die liberale Demokratie ist.
Zum Beispiel?
Also wenn man gegen die Schuldenbremse ist, ist man nicht antidemokratisch, man ist aber gegen eine liberale Institution, nämlich diese Festschreibungen und Verfassungen.
Die Strafprozessordnung und die Wahlrechte sind immer wichtiger als die Wahlen oder die Strafen, die ausgesprochen werden. Das ist das Entscheidende.
Lass uns zur KI springen.
Zu dem, was wir als ein gelungenes und gutes Leben betrachten. Ein gutes Leben, ein erfülltes Leben, ohne digitale Revolution, digitale Technologien, künstliche Intelligenz ist nicht mehr möglich. In der digitalen Gesellschaft sind als autonome, subjekteverstandene Bürgerinnen plötzlich User von in gewisser Hinsicht übergeordneten Algorithmen, die für uns auswählen und die uns helfen, durch die Schneise der Komplexität und der Vielfalt einen Weg zu finden, den wir selbst ohne das gar nicht mehr finden könnten. Das heißt, die künstliche Intelligenz wird eigentlich von der Bedrohung zur Retterin, weil die künstliche Intelligenz erst das Leben wieder lebbar macht.
Ja, jeder weiß es, der mit dem Smartphone durch die Gegend läuft, weiß, wo es langgeht.
In der digitalen Gesellschaft, und da liegt das wirklich Revolutionäre, sind allerdings natürliche Personen, denen nach dem modernistischen Verständnis, Vernunft, Freiheit, Moralität usw. zugesprochen wird, überhaupt gar nicht mehr der relevante Referenzpunkt, sondern was die Datensammlung und was die künstliche Intelligenz stattdessen macht, ist, sie generiert, sie steuert, sie verwaltet Datensätze, die von natürlichen Personen abgekoppelt sind.
Und das wiederum bedeutet, dass man sich dann...
Ich finde es aber auch gut, dass ich selber nicht im Amt vorgehalten werde, sondern nur meine Papiere.
Das heißt, künstliche Intelligenz bezieht sich auf etwas völlig anderes als das, worauf moderne Gesellschaften und auch worauf Demokratien sich beziehen. Das Wesen der Demokratie ist, autonome Personen darzustellen oder zu repräsentieren, oder ihnen Beteiligungsforum usw. zu geben. Künstliche Intelligenz bezieht sich auf Datensätze.
Also nicht mehr die autonome Person. Wir springen bitte zu dem Clip emanzipatorischen Normen in den 70ern, um nochmal zu hören, wie war es denn mal gedacht?
Abgelöst, aber was auffällig ist, und damit komme ich zu diesem Begriff des öko-emanzipatorischen Projektes, ist, dass sich in den 70er Jahren in westlichen, in sogenannten postindustriellen Gesellschaften eine Denkform, eine Denkweise, ein Normensystem durchgesetzt hat, dass umweltpolitische Themen und gesellschaftliche Naturbeziehungen ganz speziell aus der Perspektive und unter dem Vorzeichen emanzipatorischer Werte verstanden hat. Werte wie Freiheit, Gerechtigkeit, Selbstbestimmung, Vernunft, universelle Menschenrechte und so weiter. Das wurden die Grundwerte.
Und das wurde auch der Maßstab dann.
Um das übrigens zu hinterfragen. Ja. Also ein, das ist ja, man kann sich ja fast so verträumt, das individuelle Subjekt. Endlich haben wir uns ökonomisch und politisch in so eine Position verbracht in den 70ern, dass wir es jetzt, und Klima droht auch noch nicht ein Thema zu sein, dass wir es jetzt ausleben können. Und da kann man durchaus Skepsis zu haben. So, also einfach die Magie dieses Moments, vielleicht steckt hier doch noch was dahinter. Also vielleicht ist das gar nicht das richtige Bild. Vielleicht sieht es nur so harmonisch aus, weil gerade wenig Widerspruch droht, aber vielleicht ist es gar nicht so richtig. Deswegen hat Luma eine Systemtheorie gemacht für diese Frage, ist das eine gegenwärtige Theorie, hat sie sich nicht überlebt oder wie auch immer, sondern genau gegen dieses Denken.
Aber er ist doch nicht jemand, der dieses Denken jetzt noch mal hochhält.
Er erinnert uns noch mal daran.
Genau, so wurde gedacht. Und so hat man auch gelebt. Weil wenn ich sage, meine Selbstbefreiung ist das höchste Prinzip, dann wird alles andere nicht dieselbe Priorität bekommen.
Das öko-emanzipatorische Projekt drehte sich wesentlich um das Ideal des freien, selbstbestimmten, mündigen Bürgers oder der mündigen Bürgerin. Das autonome Subjekt und die Verwirklichung dieses Ideals war das eigentliche Projekt am öko-emanzipatorischen Projekt. Darum ging es. Das war der Maßstab, aus dem gemessen wurde, ob gesellschaftliche Veränderungen in die richtige Richtung oder in die falsche Richtung gehen.
Das produziert aber einen Widerspruch.
Öko-emanzipatorische Bewegungen haben selbst immer eine Logik der Entgrenzung betrieben. Wir kritisieren das am Kapitalismus, dass er die Logik des Wachstums, der Landnahme, der Grenzüberschreitung usw. hat. Das emanzipatorische Projekt selbst wollte immer Grenzen setzen, hat aber immer Grenzen niedergerissen und war nicht in der Lage, statt dessen Begrenzung zu setzen.
Und wir beide, wie wir hier sitzen und viele, die uns zuhören, ich will fast sagen alle, sind auch nicht diejenigen, die eigentlich eine Grenze akzeptieren. Für andere ja, die Rechten wollen die Grenzen für die Migranten, wir sagen begrenzt die Superreichen, also wir begrenzen gerne die anderen. Selbstbegrenzung fällt uns so ungeheuer schwer. Und das ist ein Widerspruch, in dem wir uns befinden, weil wir zugleich alle, die wir hier wahrscheinlich zuhören, anerkennen, dass eigentlich eine Begrenzung sein müsste. Und zugleich ist diese Idee, dass die Demokratie nicht mehr so wichtig ist, dass zum Beispiel die KI delegiert eine, die wie du jetzt eben schon gesagt hast, doch auch was ganz Entspanntes sein könnte, blüdern folgendermaßen.
Das hat auch nichts zu tun. Es gibt Kolleginnen, die arbeiten sich ab an den Begriff des Verlustes. Das ist eine Seite.
Diese Transformation ist ein Gewinn.
Denken Sie an die Dinge, die Sie ohne Ihre künstliche Intelligenz nicht tun können. Das heißt, es ist eine emanzipatorische Entwicklung. Das Abdanken der Demokratie ist eine komischerweise emanzipatorische Entwicklung, weil uns nämlich dieses dauernde Abstimmen, wo wir uns gar keinen Urteil mehr machen können, was wir eigentlich wählen sollen, auf den Senkel geht. Das ist eine Befreiung. Sie kennen das, wenn Sie dauernd auf Ihrem Computer zustimmen müssen und alles mögliche. Dieses Wählen wird zur Unerträglichkeit, wird zur Belastung, weil es uns klar macht, wir haben überhaupt keine Kriterien, nach denen wir wählen können. Das heißt, in Umständen der Komplexität ist es viel einfacher, nicht wählen zu müssen. Das heißt, Demokratie wird eben emanzipatorisch überwunden.
Und das ist ja eine ganz merkwürdige Aussicht.
Also, ich sehe, das ist der letzte Clip zu Blüthorn. Würde jetzt noch einer oder zwei kommen, würde ich zum Freudianer, der noch mal Vorträge hält zum Thema, das unerfüllte, unendliche Begehren muss ausbalanciert werden. Ansonsten geht die signifikante Struktur verloren. Und wenn er jetzt einfach sagt, wer begrenzt dich denn schon gerne? Also die Diskurse, die ich so mitbekomme und die ich auch selbst ein bisschen lebe, laufen unter der Maxime weniger Bildschirm, weniger Essen.
Moment, das ist ja keine Selbstbegrenzung. Naja, das ist ja, das hat ja auch die 70er-Jahre, hatten auch eine Fitnessbewegung schon bald und sowas. Aber es meint ja nicht, dass man sich, also eine Völlerei zu betreiben, ist ja am Ende nicht eine Endgrenzung, sondern man begrenzt sich ja, weil man immer immobiler wird.
Aber den Leuten wird ja gesagt, möchtest du alle Kuhsteller abschaffen?
Aber du würdest dich mit der Bildschirmzeit beschränken, aber wenn ich dir jetzt sage, du musst jetzt bald wieder ein iPhone 7 haben, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich sagen, ich bin noch nicht bescheuert.
Selbst dieser Diskurs, ich habe mir diese Uhr geholt, um mein iPhone zu Hause zu lassen. Ich würde nicht dauerhaft auf ein gutes Telefon verzichten, aber in sehr vielen sozialen Kontexten dann irgendwie doch erstaunlicherweise. Also ich sag mal so.
Was sagt der Mann, der von 15 Peps hier umgeben ist?
Wir sind ja gerade bei der Arbeit, so sieht es halt aus. Aber ich bin ja nicht immer nur bei der Arbeit.
Genau, aber er sagt ja nicht, dass man nicht auch das andere macht. Er sagt ja auch nicht, alle Leute fliegen die ganze Zeit wie verrückt. Aber wenn man es als sinnvoll erachtet zu sagen, eigentlich wäre es praktischer für mich, noch einen dritten Laptop zu haben und man hat das Geld, dann kauft man den, dann sagt man nicht, ah ja, Moment, Ökologie.
Vielleicht bin ich dafür der falsche Ansprechpartner, denn ich mache keine interkontinentalen Flugreisen, ich habe keinen Führerschein, ich habe kein Auto, ich fahre nirgendwo hin, ich begrenze mich die ganze Zeit und das mit drei Kindern.
Na, ist es eine Begrenzung oder willst du einfach kein Auto fahren? Also ich kann natürlich auch sagen, ich begrenze mich.
Ich will natürlich Auto fahren, ich will ja auch zu diesen ganzen Burgen hin, nur ich sage halt den Kindern, hört mal zu, wir führen hier ein begrenztes Leben.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das der Diskurs ist. Ich glaube, dass du jemand bist, du hast auch nie einen Führerschein gemacht.
Na ja, klar, sage ich dir nicht.
Aber du hast doch den Führerschein nicht gemacht, weil du an die Umwelt gedacht hast.
Ich mache meinen Führerschein nicht, weil ich diesen Diskurs zum individuellen Mobilitätsding für mich so ausgedeutet habe, dass ich kein Auto brauche, obwohl ich gerne eins hätte. Aber klar würde ich gerne mein Auto steigen und mit den Kids irgendwo hinfahren in der Leben, die wir ausbauen.
Aber du lebst in Frankfurt, da gibst du es schon zu, dass du an einer unglaublich privilegierten Stelle lebst, was Mobilität anbelangt.
Ja, aber die Hälfte, 40 Millionen Menschen leben in urbanen Zentren wie Frankfurt.
Nee, aber nicht in Deutschland. Na ja, gut, lass uns nicht das Auto-Thema jetzt noch anwenden. Lass uns noch mal einmal über diese Demokratie-Skepsis, die jetzt hier diagnostiziert wurde.
Man kann kein politisches Programm daraus drehen, dass man einfach sagt, die Leute begehren immer nur. Sie begehren, sie begehren, sie begehren. Und als Freud und Lacan sagten, man muss sich auch mal begrenzen, dann wollten die das nicht. Sie haben das als ich-emanzipatorisches Projekt verschrieben oder wie auch immer. Nein, Leute leben sich nicht einfach so aus. Es ist dieser Umgang mit Menschen und wie Blütern das da macht. Ich meine, ich sehe ihn ja nicht. Du sagst, es ist sein einziger Vortrag. Für mich hört sich das so an, wie er sitzt in so einem Sessel, gibt so eine Audienz und flüstert so dahin den Leuten, was unfehlbar nochmal gesagt werden muss.
Lass uns nochmal springen zu dieser Demokratieskepsis und versuchen jetzt nochmal so eine Reddemokratisierung. Denn ich war relativ enttäuscht. Wir hatten sehr positiv über Triggerpunkte von Steffen Mau und anderen gesprochen. Mau hat jetzt einen neuen Essay über den Osten geschrieben, war deshalb im Deutschlandfunk und macht folgenden Vorschlag zur Reddemokratisierung des Ostens.
Bürgerräte, also per Losverfahren gewählte Gremien, wo Leute eben reinkommen zu bestimmten gesellschaftlichen politischen Sachproblemen, sich Gedanken machen.
Das ist jetzt der Vorschlag, wie man den Osten wieder auffordern bekommt und er sagt dann noch weiter?
Es ist aber auch ein Lernraum, wo man eben sagt, okay, nicht nur die lautesten und die jetzt irgendwie am vehementesten mit dem Fuß aufstapfen, setzen sich durch, sondern es gibt eine Vielheit der Stimmen, eine gleichberechtigte Teilnahme unterschiedlicher, gesellschaftlicher Gruppen, politischer Orientierung und die versuchen in einem ernsthaften Bemühen und durch Austausch von Argumenten und Informationen und Sichten zu einem gemeinsamen Ergebnis zu kommen.
Haber-Maas-Revival.
Na, es fehlt so ein wichtiger Punkt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es in den Clips vorkommt, wie er das sagt, aber der Bürgerrat, wir haben ihn zurecht zerredet, er macht keinen Sinn, denn wenn ein Bürgerrat zum Thema Ernährung, den die Bundesregierung einsetzt, sagt, kostenloses Essen in der Schule wäre gut und jeder, jeder, der das hört, sagt, das hat absolut Sinn. Klar wäre das gut. Und wir hören in Amerika, der Vizepräsidentschaftskandidat hat in dem Hoheitsbereich, den er hatte, kostenloses Schulessen erwürgt für alle. Und dann kommt aber eine CDU-Fraktion im Bundestag, die sagt, nee, dann bezahlen wir dem Anwaltskind das Essen. Dann wird es ja zeredet, was der Bürgerrat zurecht sagt.
Du weißt ja, was der Bürgerrat hier in Deutschland eigentlich gesagt hat. Kostenloses Essen und das, was das kostet, wird abgezogen vom Elterngeld.
Ja gut, das wird er dann noch sein.
Der Schwachsinn ist ja in jedem Bürgerrat auch groß.
Genau, aber wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, der Bürgerrat, wir machen ihn allein deswegen, weil das Parlament nicht in der Lage ist, eine Regierung zu bilden. Irgendwo müssen ja Entscheidungen herkommen. Also verlosen wir diese Plätze. Nur, wir sagen den Leuten, ihr gebt hier keine Empfehlungen ab, ihr beratschlagt nicht jemanden, niemand wird euch konsultieren, niemand wird euch stören. Die Entscheidung, die ihr trefft, ist das Gesetz. Und jetzt, let's go. Also wie eine Jury vor Gericht. Dann hätte das eine andere Zugkraft. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendwer auf diese Idee käme. Ich würde sie selber nicht vorschlagen, aber wenn schon ich sowas höre, wie Steffen M sagt, dann würde ich auch in Konsequenz.
Bei Steffen M geht es irgendwie um was anderes, habe ich den Eindruck.
Einerseits knüpft es an, an bestimmte Grundhaltung und auch Grunderwartungen, die in Ostdeutschland da sind. Andererseits geht es auch über sie hinaus, weil Menschen eben da auch in Kontext hineinkommen, wo sie eben Dinge erfahren können, Dinge lernen können, über sich selbst, aber auch natürlich über andere. Und so vielleicht auch feststellen, ja, Politik ist Kompromiss. Politik ist, mit anderen zusammenzukommen, zuzuhören und dann unter den gegebenen Umständen unter Abwägung aller unterschiedlicher Interessen auf einen gemeinsamen Nenner zu kommen.
Also eigentlich sollen die Leute doch da einüben, dass es keine große Alternative gibt. Eigentlich ist der Status quo, wie er ist. Sei damit zufrieden. Wir erklären das nochmal im Plenum.
Ja, ich will es nicht zu überheblich und aber ich trau's mir, weil ich ja selber ein Thüringer bin. Das politische Gespräch, beispielsweise eine Bürgersprache, ist ein besonderes. Es ist nämlich selbst reflexiv. Man beschäftigt sich mit sich selber. Es wäre sehr gut, wenn man überhaupt erst mal ein Soziales. Es muss sich noch nicht mit sich selber befassen. Das ist ein Schritt zu viel. In Thüringen muss man anfangen, überhaupt erst mal. Es reicht nicht, einfach nur in Ruderstatten festzumachen und dann nochmal eine Kultur in einer Jena, sondern flächendeckend muss da jetzt mal Sozialität hergestellt werden, dass die dann später auch noch über sich selber befinden kann. Schön und gut. Aber das können wir dann in zehn Jahren besprechen.
Mao hat aber so eine Vorstellung von einer offenbar vernünftigen Mitte.
Das heißt, man kann eigentlich radikale Positionen vielleicht pazifizieren oder einhegen.
Und dann geht es noch um die Spaltung der Gesellschaft.
Da kann man eben sehen, dass die Leute, die da irgendwie ganz außen posten sind, dass die dann in diesen Kontexten eigentlich sich nicht durchsetzen können und das Ganze nicht dominieren können. Und das ist eben im öffentlichen Diskurs häufig so, dass wir sehr extreme polarisierte Positionen haben, die für die Breite vielleicht nicht repräsentativ sind, aber die sozusagen übergroße akustische Aufmerksamkeit generieren können für ihre Position. Und dann entsteht eben zum Bild so eine gespaltene Gesellschaft, obwohl die Mitte tendenziell sich zurückzieht und dann leiser wird.
Und das halte ich ja alles für völlig falsch.
Der Drops ist gelutscht, das ist alles Unsinn. Also wirklich, das ist eine Erfahrung aus Thüringen schon vor 20 Jahren. Da steht jemand auf der Bühne und macht ein sehr vernünftiges Argument, bespricht wirklich wichtige Themen. So, dann läuft das 20 Minuten, dann meldet sich der erste im Publikum und sagt, also wenn die Merkel das nicht so gemacht hätte, dann wäre ich auch nicht wütend. Aber so kann das ja nicht gehen und dann uploadiert der ganze Saal.
Ja, auch davon abgesehen glaube ich, ist das falsch, so eine Spaltung der Gesellschaft zu überwinden, sondern es gibt eine Spaltung und die ist aber nicht nur eine AfD und die anderen, sondern das ist zum Beispiel eine ökonomische und da finde ich nochmal so sehr schön zu sehen, wie überfordert eigentlich die Soziologie gerade ist. Wir haben Blüthorn, der die These aufstellt, da gibt es Probleme der Demokratie und jetzt haben wir einen Soziologen, der sagt, wenn es da Demokratieprobleme gibt, wie Blüthorn und Co. sagen, ich habe da mal so eine Idee und dann weiß man nichts anderes zu sagen als Bürgerräte und kleine Gruppen und die können sich mal zusammentun. Da muss ich sagen, sind wir doch an einem sehr, sehr heiklen Punkt angelangt und wir warten jetzt ab.
Also ich will zur Ehrenrettung der Soziologie. Es gibt Politikwissenschaft, Blüthorn, es gibt politische Soziologie, Mao, er greift eine Fragestellung auf, die im Raume liegt und möchte...
Aber Blüthorn ist Soziologe, würde ich schon sagen.
Das Buch. Ja gut, also wenn man nochmal das 30 Jahre alte Ulrich Beck, von dem ich schon sage, dass es politische Soziologie liest, und dann nochmal eine aktuelle politische Fragestellung und dann denkt man sich irgendein Projekt aus und sagt, eigentlich habe ich schon drei Bücher dazu geschrieben, aber ich muss nochmal einen vierten Anlauf machen. Das ist dann keine Soziologie, sondern da denkt man halt einfach so vor sich hin und macht irgendwas. Also es ist ein Buch, das ich einwischen möchte, es ist Politik. Steffen Mao ist ein Soziologe und er hat ja empirisch gearbeitet. Wir haben Triggerpunkte gelesen, nur er selber hat ja gemerkt, er muss zum Osten nochmal was nachschieben. Triggerpunkte erklärt den Osten nicht. Wir haben es jetzt nicht gelesen, also ich habe es jedenfalls nicht gelesen. Und nach dem, was ich hier höre, würde ich sagen, schwierig. Denn die gute und damit meine ich plausible Soziologie, die uns lehrreicher macht, ist eine, die sich nicht einmischt. Die würde nicht auf eine Idee des Bürgerrats kommen, sondern wenn es einen gibt, schaut man sich das an und fragt sich, was das soll. Weshalb ich hier auch fasziniert bin von den Wahlen, wie sie stattfinden in Thüringen, in Amerika, in Frankreich. Wenn ein Untergang stattfindet, beschreibt die Soziologie den Untergang und stellt sich nicht mit irgendeinem Schild daneben und will noch jemanden abwenden oder irgendwen darüber informieren, was man jetzt anders machen könnte. Das ist Beratung. Soziologen können Beratung machen, aber dieses politische Ansehen muss aus der Soziologie gestrichen werden. Ansonsten macht man sie genau ein Versuch lang und danach hat man keine Soziologie mehr.
Das kann man ja jedenfalls unterschreiben, dass diese Autoren, die wir im Salon hatten, Manow, Blüthorn und Selk keinerlei Beratung machen, sondern Diskription leisten, ob man die dann so teilt.
Diskriktion von Literatur, aber nicht von gegenwärtiger Empirie.
Auch von Gesellschaft und wer das weiter nachverfolgen will, wir haben ja in den Salons sehr ausführlich über diese Werke gesprochen. Wir weisen nochmal darauf hin, im nächsten Salon wird es ganz empirisch, denn es geht in die Reportage rein. Julia Friedrichs stellt uns Deutschlands Superreiche vor. Wir werden gucken, ob die das einzige Problem sind oder überhaupt ein Problem sind. Ich bin gespannt auf die Lektüre. Außerdem werde ich, um dich weiter zu ärgern, einen Text der Frankfurter Schule vorstellen aus den 50er Jahren.
Ich bin Hans Beuth-Fenn.
Der wurde mir empfohlen von einem Hörer. Und zwar ist dieser Text von Franz Neumann. Der ist aus der zweiten, dritten Reihe der Frankfurter Schule. Der hat über Politik und Angst geschrieben. Und ich glaube, dass das ein guter Text sein kann, denn wir haben einen Anlass, die Wahl und werden über Politik und Angst dann sowieso sprechen müssen von vielerlei Seiten aus. Sonst will ich es mir noch offen halten.
Gut, ich halte mir auch noch alles offen, denn ich lese erst am Wochenende, aber es liegt einiges breit. Ich freue mich allerdings wirklich auf die Lektüre von Julia Friedrichs, denn wir bekommen dort, es ist im Grunde auch Soziologie. Wir kennen das noch aus ihrem Buch zu den armen, ärmlicheren Berufen. Musiklehrer in freier Anstellung, U-Bahn putzen und so weiter. Auf die Tränendrüse kann man da immer drücken. Man bekäme da auch super Filme. Sie haben ja auch Filme dazu gemacht. Aber trotzdem einfach mal beschreiben, was da ist, so wie Stefan Mauer einfach mit diesen Leuten einfach redet und zwar nicht die Protokolle zur Verfügung stellt, aber die relevanten Auszüge aus diesen Gesprächen, sodass man sich selber darüber Gedanken machen kann, anstatt einfach diesen Teil auszulassen und zu sagen, ich habe jetzt mal eure Rede gelesen. Also Vorfreude, dass wir es erstens gegenwärtig und zweitens empirisch jetzt im Salon mal wieder haben.
Der Salon ist hörbar am einfachsten über Steady oder Patreon oder über Apple. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir uns dort wieder treffen.
So ist es. Bis dann.